So.
Rock.
Mal du erst was trinken, ja.
Ich hab grad unten
huge
Pepo-Fett gemacht.
Ich hab, äh,
drei Würstchen gefuttert.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ich war in letzter Zeit
so wenig on, weil mich tausend Sachen
abgelenkt haben.
Muss jetzt wieder ein bisschen regelmäßiger
streamen. Ich hab ja teilweise, ich glaub,
ich hab die letzten drei Wochen
nur am Sonntag gestreamt.
Zweieinhalb, drei oder dreieinhalb Stunden.
Sonst nix. Ganze
Woche nicht. Und außerdem,
bald ist es soweit,
bald wird's kühler, ne, wenn man sich jetzt
mal hier anschaut.
Jetzt will einer auf dem Handy was. Geil.
Aber ich joiner heute bestimmt
nicht dem täglichen
Austausch daily. Ganz bestimmt
nicht. Ich arbeite montags nicht.
Äh, jetzt hab ich ganz vergessen, was ich
sagen wollte. Lull. Vollkorn.
Mischbrot. Dankeschön. 19 Monate
Hyper-Subscription.
Habt ihr schon das neue Stack Overflow
Survey 2000? Spricht man das
überhaupt so aus? Survey? Survey?
Wie spricht man das aus?
Pronunciation.
Wie spricht man das aus? Survey.
Survey.
Survey. Survey.
Na, war doch gar nicht so verkehrt.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon gesehen habt.
Gab jetzt ja hier eine neue
Umfrage vom April
oder so? Ah, Mai. Mai.
Hier. Äh, vom Mai.
Und die haben sie jetzt ausgewertet. Das ist tatsächlich
recht
interesting.
Abofalle. 22 Monate. Ja,
scheint zu funktionieren. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscriptions.
Ja, und außerdem
Wetter Online. Hanau.
Außerdem wird's bald kühler.
Und ich muss endlich einstellen, dass ich
meine Heizung an- und ausschalten kann. Das müssen wir
jetzt fertig machen.
Scam Train ist am Start. Ja.
Ja, nachdem ich die letzten
drei... Ich muss... Leute, ich muss mich ein bisschen beruhigen.
Ganz, ganz... Wir machen heute wieder äußerst
äh, dass ich auch eine Weile
online bleiben kann. Muss ich ein bisschen
beruhigen.
Und dann auch gleich nachdenken, was wir
machen.
Ja.
Und demnächst wird's
kühl. Sieht man ja hier schon.
Minimaltemperatur. Acht bis sechs
Grad. Nächste paar Tage.
Ich muss heute nicht arbeiten.
Ich hab montags immer frei. Ich hab halt...
Ich hab die letzten Wochen einfach nur so wenig gestreamt.
Bald Schnee, ja.
Genau. Gartenstelz.
So. Und deswegen
bald, äh, muss ich
die Heizung einschalten. Na, wenn man sich das hier
so anguckt.
Tagsüber 17, 18, 13 Grad.
Da muss ich die Heizung
einschalten. Und die Heizung
würde ich natürlich am liebsten von
meinem Home Assistant Dashboard einschalten.
Und deswegen muss ich den Kram
jetzt endlich fertig programmieren. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man genau
steht. Oh.
Oh. Broken AF.
Oder auch nicht. Ja, was denn
jetzt?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ha, lull. Lull. Feedback.
Kack, wait.
Ja.
Und ich will die Heizung einschalten können.
Und wir haben ja hier schon so einen Testserver installiert.
Lass mal kurz IP gucken.
Äh.
Was für eine IP hat das Ding? 2, 1, 3, 3.
Ja.
Ich hab mir hier schon so einen Test, so einen Home Assistant
Testserver gemacht, der halt nichts, nichts,
nichts hat. Ja.
Ähm.
Vielleicht müssen wir den auch mal updaten.
Weiß ich nicht, der ist ja schon ein bisschen,
ein bisschen, schon 2, 3 Wochen
am Laufen. Waren das jetzt
nochmal
System? Echt?
Ist das die neueste?
Ja gut. 3.9 muss ja die neueste
sein. Ja.
Oh. Na gut,
egal.
Ja. Und ich will halt einen Button haben,
wo ich hier sagen kann,
Heizung an, Heizung aus.
Heizung aus.
Und bloß noch ein paar Infos von meiner Heizung.
Und ich will die hier in der Integration
drin stehen haben, komplett als
eigenes Gerät. Dass das alles
schön gruppiert ist. Das heißt,
ich muss mir jetzt erstmal angucken, wie das überhaupt
richtig funktioniert mit der Home Assistant
MQTT Discovery.
Das haben wir nämlich das letzte Mal nicht gemacht.
Das letzte Mal haben wir glaube nur
Abfragen
gemacht vom
von der Heizung selbst.
Ja. Wir haben das letzte Mal nicht viel
gemacht. Also wenn man sich das mal anschaut, dann ist das
das letzte Mal 61 Zeilen hingekriegt
haben. Und wir wissen ja,
Bezahlung nach Zeilen ist ja eh das Beste.
Haben wir nicht viel verdient.
Dings, Dings, Bums, Bam.
Dings. 15 Monate.
Huge Subscription.
Der Nero-Mam ist auch am Start.
5 Monate hier.
Huge Subs.
Ja. Weiß ich, ob ihr das, wie gesagt,
weiß ich, ob ihr das hier gesehen habt.
Scheint ja wohl relativ neu
zu sein.
Der Dark Reader an.
Ah, muss ich mal kurz wegmachen.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle, dass er schon
Monate alt ist.
Ne, siehst du, das kam letzten
Monat raus. Und ich glaube, das haben wir uns noch nicht zusammen
angeguckt.
Was ich diesmal wieder ganz interessant
finde. Eine Güte.
Oder haben wir uns das schon angeguckt? Doch, ich glaube,
das haben wir uns sogar schon angeguckt.
Wird das auf GitHub veröffentlicht?
Ich fürchte, dass Brethi nichts bringen,
wenn wir das auf GitHub veröffentlichen.
Weil du wahrscheinlich eine ganz andere Heizung hast.
Was hast du denn für eine Heizung?
Also ich habe eine, ich habe
von Wiesmann eine
222W
oder so.
Sowas hier.
Ich glaube, das ist meine Heizung.
Oder 222F oder sowas.
Ja. Also man braucht ja da
mehrere Komponenten. Du brauchst auf jeden Fall
ein Raspberry Pi
an der
Heizung mit dem offiziellen
Ob du, also es muss kein offizielles
muss kein offizielles Kabel sein,
aber du brauchst ein Raspberry Pi
und ein Opto-Link-Kabel
und V-Control von
GitHub. Ah ja,
nice, nice. Ja, dann kannst du das wahrscheinlich
verwenden.
Ich muss mal gucken. Das Steuern
habe ich hinbekommen. Das ist
das Ein- und Ausschalten.
Da musste man das letzte Mal
musste man da
musste man selbst rausfinden,
wie das funktioniert.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das habe
ich als Heizung. Und es ist auch ein
bisschen davon abhängig, wie dann V-Control
eingestellt ist.
First line of code. Es gibt
1% der Leute, die haben hier ihre
erste Zeile programmiert, als sie
jünger als 5 Jahre waren.
Ja.
Ob ich das mal glauben soll?
Das ist ja beim Programmieren nicht so
wie bei den ganzen
Klavier, Geige, sonst was
Genies, die dann irgendwie
mit 1,5 Jahren das erste Mal
Klavier gespielt haben.
Du musst ja, wenn du das programmierst,
so halbwegs im Kopf
verarbeiten können, was da
logisch passiert. Guck mal, es gibt
sogar Leute, die haben erst mit
64 Jahren und älter angefangen.
Aber die meisten Leute, gut ja,
in dem Alter habe ich auch angefangen.
Rockers, Stelz.
Wisst ihr, dass ich eigentlich
ursprünglich das komplett gehasst habe
zu programmieren? Wir haben in der Schule
hatten wir bei irgendeinem komischen Lehrer,
ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß, aber den mochte
ich nicht. Der hat uns versucht,
ein bisschen C beizubringen.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, also jetzt so
im Nachhinein, glaube ich,
hat er selbst keine Ahnung gehabt, was er da eigentlich
fabriziert hat. Und ich habe das
komplett gehasst, aber der hat das auch nie richtig
erklärt. Außerdem ist C,
naja, weiß nicht, so als
Einstieg vielleicht eh nicht das Beste.
Ist ja nicht so, als hätte es damals nicht auch schon irgendwas
Alternatives gegeben. Und sei es
noch Visual Basic oder
oder irgendwas.
Irgendwas, wo man die Leute vielleicht nicht ganz so
abschreckt.
C ist immer noch besser als Java.
Zum Einstieg weiß ich nicht.
Mein Vorteil an C ist halt, dass es äußerst
minimalistisch ist.
C kann halt nichts, außer das, was es kann.
Und es kann es halt gut.
Also du hast ja bei C,
würde ich ja nicht mal von einer Standard-Library sprechen.
Da würde ich vielleicht von
absolut notwendigen
Essentials so quasi sprechen,
was da dabei ist.
Und
ich glaube nicht, dass C so eine wirklich gute
Einstiegsprogrammiersprache ist.
Also dann hätten sie lieber mit
uns in der Schule damals,
ich meine, es muss ja nicht Visual Basic sein.
Es hätte auch Pascal oder irgendwas sein können.
Irgendwas, irgendwas
anderes als C.
Vor allem, unser Lehrer hat uns dann auch
irgendwas von Pointer erzählt.
Ich hab's halt damals überhaupt
nicht gecheckt.
Wisst ihr, wie lange ich
gebraucht habe,
um wirklich, dabei ist es eigentlich eines der
elementarsten Sachen schlechthin,
wie lange ich gebraucht habe,
um mir unter einem Pointer was vorstellen,
zu können?
Dabei ist es eigentlich total einfach.
Ein Pointer ist die Kombination
aus einer Speicheradresse
und einem Typ.
Fertig.
Ein Pointer sagt dir, als was
du das, was an dieser Speicheradresse
stehst, interpretieren kannst.
Ja gut, bei C kannst du sagen,
das ist ein Void-Pointer, ja dann hast du prinzipiell
gelitten, wenn du es nicht eh schon weißt.
Weil kriegst du sonst nicht raus,
was es ist.
Das ist eigentlich, eigentlich ist es eines der
elementarsten Sachen.
Und ich glaube, das
lag mit an diesem Lehrer,
dass ich da so
keinen Bock drauf hatte.
Die meisten können es nicht erklären, weil sie es selbst nicht verstanden haben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Übrigens, heute hat mich auf Twitter einer voll verwirrt.
Er hat mir gepostet,
ja,
hat mir das hier gepostet,
gestern auch drüber gesprochen.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, was ist,
ich mein, ich bin dann drauf gekommen, dass es wahrscheinlich
Swift ist.
Aber da hab ich mir gedacht,
ich hab mir gedacht, was zum Teufel ist das für
eine Sprache? Ich dachte erst mal, als ich es gesehen habe,
hab ich gesagt, Javascript. Aber dann ist mir
aufgekommen, Moment, das da
und das da, das passt ja überhaupt
nicht zu Javascript.
Dann dachte ich, dass das irgendwie sowas vielleicht wie Go
ist, wegen Funk ist es aber auch nicht, kann es
auch nicht sein. Und irgendwann
bin ich dann drauf gekommen, dass das
wahrscheinlich Swift sein müsste.
Hat recht, es ist Swift.
Ah, siehst du, siehst du, und Dollar Null
ist so Pearl Magic Variable.
Was ist das für ein Font?
Ist das bestimmt
so ein Font, der auch so geile
Extra-Zeichen
für größer gleich und gleich gleich
und so hat. Ich hab, wie hieß
der Kram nochmal?
Font
Ligatures
Ligaturen
wahrscheinlich auf Deutsch, keine Ahnung.
Wo du dann solche Dinger machst.
Wann kommt der dritte
KekWSS Service Stream?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich war die letzten Wochen ein bisschen
abgelenkt mit allen
möglichen Sachen. Plus dazu, dass ein richtig
cooles RPG
gerade rausgekommen ist, was ich nebenbei abends
immer noch spiele. Also
ich hab die
letzten Wochen ein bisschen wenig gestreamt.
Ich war zu sehr abgelenkt durch alles mögliche.
Wir machen aber
dann, ich würd sagen, nächstes Wochenende.
Nächstes Wochenende, wir müssen KekWSS Service
endlich mal
to the moon, ja,
an den Start bringen.
Wer sich
fragt, was KekWSS Service ist,
das ist ein Streamprojekt,
gibt's sogar auf Github.
KekWSS Service.
Ähm,
das ist nicht das.
Ist aber auch von jemandem aus dem Stream.
KekWSS Service, nein,
das ist nicht mein KekWSS Service.
Äh, wo
ist es denn? Ja, ist es doch.
Ja.
Das ist so ein kleines Mini-Projekt.
Warum sind da so viele
Einser drinne? Zumindest
Einser, na gut, dass ich Einser
kopieren kann. Ja.
Das ist, das ist ein Projekt, wie
man eine minimal ASP.NET Anwendung
dann nach
und nach in die Cloud bringt. Das haben wir so
mit letzten paar Streams schon gemacht.
Es macht nichts
anderes, wie KekW als Bild zu nehmen
und dann immer weiter zu rotieren.
Wann hab ich denn diese Einser in die Readme
reingemacht? Äh,
so schon mal nicht. Hab ich hier
die Einser in die Readme gemacht?
Auch nicht. Wann hab ich denn
diese ganzen Einser in die Readme gemacht?
Alter, man weiß es nicht.
Na gut,
gucken wir mal. Wann hab ich denn
die Readme angepasst? History.
Fix Randomness.
Aha.
Ah, also ich die Randomness
gefixt habe. Alles klar.
Sehr, sehr schlau.
Mhm.
So sieht das also aus, wenn man Randomness
fixt. Alles klar, Max.
Ach stimmt, das war, dass ich
meine GitHub Actions
testen konnte, wo ich die
Readme immer geändert hab. Stimmt.
Lull.
Ganz, ganz ver... Ja, das wär...
Das ist vielleicht auch was, was ich hätte reverten sollen.
Naja.
Ansible ist... Ja, es ist wirklich POG.
Richtig massive POGers.
Hast du einen Tipp für Zeugs, dass ich lernen kann,
nachdem ich jetzt die Basics von HTT...
äh, von HTML, CSS
und etwas... jQuery.
jQuery braucht man eigentlich nicht mehr.
jQuery ist eigentlich...
Es ist zwar immer noch das weitverbreitetste Web-Framework,
aber nur, weil es in so vielen
Sachen noch mit drin ist. Also jQuery
braucht man eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ja, dann...
Ja, also wenn du wirklich noch mehr Webzeug
machen willst, würde ich dir empfehlen,
dass du irgendein halbwegs verbreitetes
Web-Frontend
lernst. Da gibt's eigentlich drei
Stück.
Aber vielleicht, vielleicht
vier, vielleicht vier,
wenn man Svelte noch mitnimmt. Aber genau,
du hast die drei.
Du hast Angular, React und Vue.
Also wenn ich dir was zum Einstieg empfehlen
würde aus diesen drei, dann ist
das eindeutig Vue.
Weil ich das von der Struktur her und den Tutorials
und dem ganzen...
Find ich persönlich am schönsten. Oder React.
Angular ist
Business Factory Manager Singleton
Pattern Observer...
Kram.
Angular ist zu bloated für Kleinkram.
Sag ich als jemand, der noch nie was mit
Angular gemacht hat.
Ja, also die zwei,
würde ich dir empfehlen, wo mein persönlicher
Favorit ja das ist.
Aber React ist eindeutig das verbreitetste
von allen.
Also React ist mit Abstand das verbreitetste.
So, danach Angular und dann
ungefähr gleich auf Vue, würde ich sagen.
Was übrigens auch schön ist bei JavaScript
Frontends,
Frontend Frameworks,
die letzten Jahre, über das sich da nicht mehr so
viel tut. Also es ist
nicht jede Woche ein neues
Hip Framework angesagt. Das ist zwar immer
noch so, dass es bei JavaScript
quasi jeden Tag neue Frameworks gibt
und die auch gewisse
Fahrt aufnehmen, immer auf GitHub.
Aber so bei den
großen drei Frameworks, da tut sich
die letzten drei Jahre schon relativ wenig.
Es ist entweder Angular, React oder Vue.
Und gerade mit Vue 3
muss man sagen,
ist das, also zumindest
so, was ich jetzt als jemand, der nicht viel
mit React gemacht hat, aber so sieht das
für mich so aus, als ist Vue 3
relativ nah
dran an dem, wie es React
schon immer gemacht hat.
Also wenn man die Composition-API von
Vue verwendet.
Gut. Und Angular ist halt
bloated as fuck.
So, es gibt noch jede Menge, jede Menge
anderen Sachen. Svelte ist auch total angesagt.
Aber ich würde dir empfehlen, eins
von diesen drei. Mein persönlicher
Tipp wäre Vue oder React.
Angular ist zum Einstieg vielleicht jetzt nicht so das Beste.
Ja.
JavaScript und schön in einem Satz.
Ach, ich find,
die Sprache an sich ist
natürlich auch wichtig, aber gar
nicht mal so entscheidend, weil
JavaScript kannst du halt so schön verbiegen
und Vue hat das halt
schön verbogen, sodass es gut
benutzbar ist.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, aber das mach ich jetzt nicht auf.
Angular ist ein bisschen,
wie gesagt, ich hab damit nie groß was gemacht,
Angular ist ein bisschen so wie
Ruby on Rails.
Der Kram muss so heißen,
wie sich das die Angular-Entwickler gedacht haben.
Ja, bei Ruby on Rails war es das gleich.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab vielleicht,
das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt Boomer Talk.
Ich hab ja nochmal, ich hab ja in der Zeit
schon Web-Anwendungen gebastelt, wo Ruby on Rails
noch angesagt war.
Ich glaube, weiß nicht, wie viele von euch schon mal
was mit Ruby on Rails gemacht haben,
aber da war das auch so,
das Zeug musste so heißen. Also
Controller mussten immer bla bla bla
irgendwas Dings
Controller heißen oder
fällt mir jetzt gar kein anderes gescheites Beispiel
zu ein. Ja, oder auch
diese Datenbank, wie hieß
das nochmal bei Ruby on Rails?
Action?
Oh, wie hieß das Datenbank-Zeug
bei Ruby on Rails? Irgendwas mit Action, glaube ich.
Action Record, kann das sein?
Ich weiß
keiner mehr genau. Ja, da musste auch,
da musste auch alles
ganz exakt so
heißen, dass Ruby on Rails
das erkannt hat. Und ich glaube, bei Angular
ist es ähnlich.
Die coolen Kids nennen das
Angela
Was?
Angula
Ach, was auch immer, was die coolen Leute sagen.
Die coolen Leute sagen auch nicht
Ubuntu, sondern Jubantu.
Was eigentlich viel falscher nicht sein könnte.
Der Brezelsnacker,
Dankeschön für die 7 Monate Subscription.
Ja, Timescript ist so ein Ding.
Ich hab Timescript schon verwendet,
da hat es Version 0.08 oder sowas
gehabt.
Ich hab das damals mir angeguckt,
also wirklich, als es ganz ganz frisch war.
Ähm,
als, weil
das der ehemalige
C-Sharp Lead Designer
nen Talk drüber gegeben hat.
Das ist ja der gleiche Typ dahinter.
Und
da hab ich das damals ausprobiert und fand das ganz cool.
Aber ich verwende es aktuell
gar nicht.
Es ist lustig, ich hab das
verwendet, da war das noch ganz neu und überhaupt nicht cool.
Das war so die Zeit, wo alle gesagt haben,
ja nice, aber wozu, kann ich alles
in JavaScript machen.
Aber jetzt, wo das richtig Mainstream ist
mit Timescript, mach ich eigentlich so gut
wie nix damit. Guck dir mal
Mint an, ist eine
was, eine
DSL für
WebDev, beziehungsweise
ist das irgendwas,
wo ich dann in YAML hinschreibe,
wie meine Webseite aussehen soll
oder sowas finde ich
sowas finde ich auch schon immer bei diesen ganzen
Server-Config-Frameworks ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Deswegen finde ich ja Ansible eigentlich
ganz gut, weil das immer noch recht prozentual ist.
Von oben nach unten ist
und nicht
ganz so abstrakt von dem, was unter der Haube
passiert.
Mich wundert, dass das .NET Framework noch Platz 1 hat.
Wo meinst du jetzt, hier in der Umfrage? Ne, wo?
Auf was
bezieht sich das jetzt?
Mint
Programming Language.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Mint lang.
Bisschen wie Dart.
Ja, Dart ist auch die überflüssigste Sache.
Hat irgendwie einer eine
tolle Erklärung dafür,
warum sie für Flutter Dart genommen haben
und nicht einfach JavaScript
oder meinetwegen auch Go,
wenn es von Google ist.
Man hätte auch gleich eine ordentliche Programmiersprache nehmen können.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Ja, das, was ich von Dart bisher gesehen habe,
ist durchaus
in Ordnung, aber
bisschen laut.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Also, wo der Sinn davon ist, dass man
eine eigene Sprache,
gerade weil Go so angesagt ist.
Ja, aber hätten sie ja mit Go auch.
Ja, aber
genau das könntest du mit Go auch machen.
Gut, ohne, ohne
Shit, aber
Go läuft auch so gut wie überall
drauf.
Ja, ich weiß nicht so genau.
Keine Ahnung, warum auch immer.
Ja, das stimmt schon,
aber bei Go ist ja alles schon da.
Also,
ist ja nicht, als hätten sie das jetzt neu bauen müssen.
Klar, ganz viel Webzweig,
gerade im Cloud-Bereich ist
mittlerweile Go voll angesagt.
Aber ich gehe mal,
ja, ich gehe davon aus,
die haben da schon ihren Grund gehabt.
Naja.
Why Flutter uses Dart?
Oh.
Oh. Oh.
Ne, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch, aber
ich glaube es euch, dass sie einen Grund dafür gehabt haben.
Das ist mir jetzt zu viel.
Aber, ja.
Haben die TLDR oben drüber?
Ne.
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Aber, ja,
dass sie einen Grund dafür gehabt haben.
Gut, bei Google bin ich mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Äh.
Äh, wie hieß das?
Geld bei Google?
Ja.
Bei Google bin ich mir da nicht so ganz so
sicher, ob das immer sinnvoll ist, was sie treiben.
Also,
weil Google hat ja nun wirklich schon viele Dinger
fabriziert. Konnte man das
nicht nach Jahr sortieren lassen?
Viele Dinger fabriziert,
die nicht so durchdacht waren.
Google Chrome Apps sind weg.
Ok, habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Hat auch kaum einer verwendet.
Ok, das ist das allererste
AngularJS.
Das habe ich tatsächlich mal in einem Tutorial
durchgemacht. Das ist aber auch so ziemlich das einzige.
Das hat ja wohl mit dem aktuellen
gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Das meiste habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Beispielsweise Google Bookmarks, wusste ich nicht mal,
dass das überhaupt existiert.
Andere Kram kennen.
Fitstar Yoga. Oh, PP Hands.
Das haben die bestimmt aufgekauft.
Fitbit und Fitstar. Und dann haben sie
gesagt, jetzt vorbei, RIP.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, mal auf dem uralt Android
Tablet war dieser Mist mitinstalliert
und wollte unbedingt, dass ich mich anmelde.
Naja, ich würde sagen, fangen wir mal an.
Nix
gegen Stadia.
Ja, nix Handfestes, aber
Stadia, keck, wait, alter.
Programming language for writing
single page applications.
Und warum genau braucht es dafür eine eigene
Programmiersprache und eigene
Functions und eigene
Classlibraries und eigene
was auch immer.
Sollen wir mal auf Shithub gucken, wie beliebt
das ist.
Für Javascript Projekte nicht so beliebt.
Also alle
Javascript Projekte unter 15.000
Sterne sind nicht
beliebt. Das ist
leider echt so. Bei anderen Projekten
ist 3,5 Tausend Sterne
saumäßig beliebt. Aber
bei Javascript nicht.
Alles unter 10.000 Sterne
ist bei Javascript nicht beliebt.
Kann ich euch auch beweisen.
Guckt mal. Wir machen jetzt mal
Search nach Language. Ging das überhaupt
noch? Search nach
Javascript und dann
nach
Stars.
So.
Mit Mindeststern machen wir mal
5.000.
So, bam.
Search.
Natürlich gibt es die.
Warum soll es die nicht geben?
Ah, muss ich mal ein größer
5.000?
Aha.
So, guckt mal
hier.
Vue.js. 188.000
Sterne. React.
175.000 Sterne.
Bootstrap.
Jetzt glaube ich sogar mittlerweile ohne
jQuery. 153.000
153.000
Sterne.
Also man sieht
alles unter 10.000 Sterne. Wir gehen jetzt mal auf
Seite 100.
Es ist einfach unter
10.000 Sterne. Kannst du vergessen.
Ist nichts
dabei.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist doch
der Wahnsinn. Also
man muss echt sagen. Wisst ihr,
warum kann man hier nicht ordentliche
Page-Geschichten machen, dass ich wenigstens
eine Page eingeben kann.
Wo ich sagen kann, ich will Page.
Ich kann hier oben sagen Page 30,
aber das ist doch Usability pur.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also
selbst, guckt mal, das ist ein Repos mit
14.000 plus Sterne.
Ich habe
davor noch nichts gehört.
Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas Altes.
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal
irgendwo gelesen.
Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung.
Nie gehört, nie gehört, nie gehört, nie gehört.
Das habe ich gehört.
Das ist Outdated.
Das benutzt keiner mehr.
Das war mal ein Package Manager für
Frontend-Libraries. Das verwendet keiner mehr.
Heute verwenden alle ganz normal NPM.
Oder Yarn.
Oder was ist denn gerade noch so angesagt?
Eine Zeit lang war NPM
wurde gehatet und alle haben gesagt Yarn
besser als NPM. Und dann haben sie
V2 rausgebracht und keiner
wollte das mehr. Und dann
weiß ich nicht, was jetzt angesagt ist.
Wahrscheinlich einfach NPM.
Snap.
Ne, Deno ist wieder ganz was anderes.
Deno ist quasi Node.js in Rust.
Was? Gab es eine Frage?
Was Github ist?
Achso.
Ich bin kein Informatiker, aber was macht man
mit Github?
Du teilst deinen Source Code mit
der restlichen Welt.
Wenn du irgendwas programmiert hast,
kannst du den Source Code auf Github hochladen.
Und es kann jeder
daran mitbauen, der will.
Oder gucken, wie du das gemacht hast.
Oder Kommentare schreiben.
Oder Fehler melden.
Oder einfach nur
einen Stern geben, weil es ihm gefällt.
Das ist quasi so das Facebook
für Programmierer.
Ist jetzt vielleicht nicht der beste
Vergleich, weil Facebook ist
Boomershit.
Das Instagram für Programmierer.
Vielleicht eher.
Ohne Bilder.
Kenn ich alles nicht. Was ist das?
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung.
Cool.
Wenn die Buchstaben für die Libraries
ausgehen. Cool.
Kein Schimmer. Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Doch, das kenn ich. Das ist eine Template-Geschichte.
Das kenn ich tatsächlich.
Nie gehört, nie gehört, nie gehört, nie gehört.
Achso. Doch, kenn ich.
Das kenn ich auch.
Nie gehört, nie gehört, nie gehört, nie gehört.
Also Bullshit-Generator.
Der Bullshit-Generator hat
15.000 Sterne auf GitHub.
Warum? Ah, ja.
Na, jetzt ist alles klar.
Also,
ich denke schon, der hat's, glaube ich,
schon verdient.
Er scheint jetzt auch nicht so groß zu sein, oder?
Der Bullshit-Generator.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was der Typ da treibt. Aber er hat
15.000 GitHub-Sterne. Warum nicht?
Warum denn nicht?
Ich gönn ihm seine GitHub-Sterne.
Das hab ich, glaube ich, schon mal irgendwo verwendet.
Warum braucht man denn extra...
Warum kann ich einfach Fetch verwenden?
Weiß ich. Nie gehört, nie gehört,
nie gehört, nie gehört,
Discord-JS.
Das hab ich, glaube ich, mal ver...
Also, wie gesagt. Also, im Prinzip
alles unter 10.000 Sterne
JavaScript-Libraries sind nicht beliebt.
Was programmierst du denn so?
Ist ja aktuell, ehrlich gesagt...
Ich glaub, wir haben heute noch nicht
eine Zeile
...
... hingeschrieben, ja?
Aktuell bin ich am Schwätzen. Aber heute
machen wir das, was im Titel
steht, weil es wird bald kalt
und ich muss endlich meine Heizung
ein- und ausschalten können.
Von meinem...
... von meiner Heimautomatisierung aus.
Dass es prinzipiell geht,
haben wir das letzte Mal schon ausprobiert.
Das ist... das ist ein schöner...
... schöner Tagestopic-
... Punkt hier.
Ja, ich würd sagen, wir fangen jetzt auch mal an.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir haben ja so gut wie nichts gemacht,
weil ich auch gesagt hab, wir machen Entspannungsstream
und wir haben da nix gemacht.
So.
Also.
Ich muss mich mal kurz auf meinen Raspberry Pi verbinden.
Wobei, ne, muss ich gar nicht.
Also, ich hab nen Raspberry Pi im Keller stehen,
für alle, die sich fragen, wie ich an meine Heizung drankomme.
Ich hab nen Raspberry Pi im Keller stehen
und ich hab so nen Kabel am Raspberry Pi dran.
So nen Kabel.
Das kommt vorne in die Heizung.
Und kann dann mit zwei Infrarot-LEDs
...
... kommunikaten mit der Heizung.
Das ist ein neues Kabel.
Das ist das...
Das ist ein Kabel...
... es ist ein Kabel, was jetzt funktioniert.
Das alte hat ja...
... nicht mal richtig getan.
Genau.
So.
Das heißt, wir greifen auf den Raspberry Pi unten im Keller zu
und schicken dem Kommandos, was der machen soll.
So.
Und ich muss mal kurz gucken, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Hier.
Und um an die Heizung Sachen zu schicken,
muss man so tolle...
... muss man so tolle Befehle verwenden.
gettemp wwwist
Also nicht, dass ihr denkt,
ich hab mir das ausgedacht oder so.
Die Steuerung von der Heizung
hat so komische...
Wobei das auch falsch ist.
Es ist nicht wirklich die Steuerung von der Heizung,
sondern die Implementierung
von diesem Heizungsprotokoll
verwendet das halt.
Also sprich, das hab ich mir nicht ausgedacht.
Das müsst ihr mich nicht hauen
für diese komische
englisch-deutsche Mischung.
Also zum Beispiel mit
gettemp wwwist
kann ich die Warmwassertemperatur aktuell abfragen
oder gettbetriebart
kann ich auch machen.
Genau.
Wir gucken mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert,
was wir da gebaut haben
das letzte Mal.
Test.
Aha, interessant.
Dann kann ich mal nachvollziehen, ob es funktioniert.
Das ist natürlich auch ganz toll.
Test.
Was hab ich denn gemacht?
Run.
10 Mal.
Was zum?
Kkw return true?
Warum?
Da hab ich irgendwas
erklärt das letzte Mal, oder?
Sonst können wir alles rausschmeißen.
So.
Was hab ich denn?
Warum führe ich das Ganze nochmal
10 Mal aus?
Ah, ich wollte gucken, ob der
Ah, ich weiß wieder.
Ich wollte gucken, ob der das ordentlich queut alles.
Selbst wenn ich multithreaded drauf
zugreife. Ah ja, okay, okay.
Verstanden, verstanden, verstanden.
Okay, gettemp wwwist.
Was haben wir denn da das letzte Mal
gebaut? Wie funktioniert denn
der Kram nochmal?
Das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr.
Kommentare sind prinzipiell eh
overrated.
Dumme Frage zu React beziehungsweise
Vue. Ist das sowas wie Bootstrap?
Nein.
Also Bootstrap ist ja auch keine
JavaScript Library. Bootstrap ist
mittlerweile, ist das ja auch komplett
jQuery free und sowas.
Bootstrap ist eine User Interface
Komponenten Library.
Hauptsächlich CSS
und für die Funktion ein bisschen
JavaScript. Also Bootstrap ist
GUI gedöhnt.
Hauptsächlich CSS.
Und
Vue beziehungsweise React
sind JavaScript Frameworks
für
Webanwendungen.
Guck dir mal die Vue.js
Beispiele an, dann sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Heizung,
die mit dem Chat kommunizieren kann.
Das könnte man tatsächlich machen,
aber ich will nicht meine Heizung vom Chat steuern lassen.
Was habe ich denn hier gebaut?
Ich blick da überhaupt nicht mehr durch.
Also Endpoint. So,
Endpoint ist die IP vom Raspberry Pi.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Alles klar.
Halt genau, Heizung nach Youtube Views.
Wenn ich wenige Views im Monat habe,
gibt es keinen Strom für die,
gibt es, wird nicht mehr,
gibt es keine Werbe mehr von der Heizung.
IP-Leak. Oje, oje.
Schon wieder.
Huge IP-Leak.
Erst mal
Hackerman machen auf
192.168.1.1.2.9
Heizung nach Kontostand.
Naja.
Nachdem ich nie Geld ausgebe,
wäre es hier immer übelst warm.
Ich weiß, wo dein Haus wohnt. Ja, hier.
Auf Port 3002.
Ich gebe echt kein Geld aus, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das einzige, was ich mache, ist ab und zu,
wenn ich mich dazu entschieden habe,
mal irgendwie, was weiß ich, ich brauche
einen neuen Rechner oder irgendwie sonst was,
dann kaufe ich einmal ein bisschen was größeres,
aber ansonsten, ich gebe nie Geld aus.
Ich glaube, ich sterbe irgendwann mal mit
irgendwie,
was weiß ich,
viel auf dem Konto.
Machst du Urlaub? Selten.
Also, so richtig Urlaub irgendwo
an den Strand fahre ich selten.
Warm und Strand
ist eh nicht so meins.
Island fand ich ganz nice.
Aber das mache ich auch nicht so oft.
Also, ich gebe eigentlich kein Geld aus.
Das komplette Gehalt in Stonks.
Ja, das sollte ich.
Das sollte ich eigentlich machen,
dass es nicht weniger wird mit der Zeit.
Komm mit nach Norwegen Nordlichter anschauen.
Oder was?
Norwegen ist aber auch nice.
Norwegen würde ich mir auch mal wieder geben.
Äh, nicht wieder.
Norwegen würde ich mir auch gerne mal geben.
Du hast dein Geld wirklich auf dem Konto liegen.
Ja, das liegt da, wo es ankommt.
Einmal auf meinem Business Konto
und einmal auf meinem privaten Konto,
wo ich Monatsgehalt draufkriege.
Zum größten Teil, nicht alles.
Wieso Patrick, fährst du nach Norwegen?
Oder warst du in Norwegen?
Also ich,
das ist auch was,
würde ich mir auch mal gerne angucken.
Ich fahre jetzt nicht mit oder so,
aber das ist auch was,
wo ich mir prinzipiell mal gerne angucken würde.
Oh, jetzt kommen hier die Finanztipps.
Ich empfehle den A1JX52ETF Eats Money.
Der Zwergengringer.
Nee, nee.
Ich habe gar nichts.
Ich bin, wenn es danach geht,
total der Kack-Loop.
Überhaupt nichts.
Ich, Leute, alles in.
Ich glaube, da kann man nichts falsch machen.
So, wo sind wir denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben?
Ich versuche gerade zu verstehen,
was ich da letztes Jahr gebastelt habe.
Letztes Mal, nicht letztes Jahr.
Ich habe, ja gut,
wie gesagt, ab und zu kaufe ich mir sowas,
wie den Klo mit Spülung und sowas.
Also mit Popos
Spülung, nicht Spülung,
wie man das kennt.
Ich lasse den Chat Aktien kaufen.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht so gut.
Oder aber,
das funktioniert gut, dann gibt es als nächstes
den Stock Champ.
Dann kann man dann das Aktien kaufen
an den Chat crowdsourcen.
Das wäre der Hit.
So, also
was habe ich denn hier gebaut?
Sekunde, ich muss mich mal kurz konzentrieren.
Ich muss mal irgendwas machen.
Wie bekommt man Visual Studio für Linux?
Gar nicht.
Das ist nicht Visual Studio, das ist Rider.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Gibt es Updates?
Oh, okay.
Wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht machen.
Wenn es das jetzt gibt, na gut.
Dann
konnte man das nicht mal ordentlich minimieren.
Also, alles in GameStop.
Also was habe ich denn hier gebaut?
Ich wollte testen, ob ich
get temp wwist und
get betriebsart abfragen kann.
Was habe ich denn hier gebaut?
Also, also
Endpoint, das ist die IP.
So, dann gibt es hier irgendeine
Endlosschleife, die
Commands einliest
und dann sage ich
queue command und write das in
die
Schleife. Ich queue überhaupt
nichts. Das ist
Fake. Der macht überhaupt
nichts. Das ist gebetet.
Der
macht überhaupt nichts. Der gibt einfach nur
Test aus, anstatt das wirklich abzuschicken.
Was ist denn das hier?
So geht das aber nicht.
So.
Erstmal
aus irgendwelchen Gründen diese Schleife da raus.
Wo auch immer ich die da reingebaut habe.
Man weiß es nicht.
Hast du schon mal datacrypt benutzt?
Nö. Habe ich schon nie gemacht.
So, ich will jetzt erstmal gucken, was kommt denn bei
get temp wwist, also ich muss das nochmal
kontrollieren, was ich da letztes Mal
gebastelt habe. Was kommt denn bei
get temp wwist und get betriebsart
raus?
Wie führe ich das denn jetzt überhaupt
aus? Was habe ich denn hier gebaut? Okay.
Try write.
Ah.
Ich glaube so.
Ich glaube so ist das gedacht.
Ich glaube so ist das gedacht, was ich hier
gebaut habe. Okay. Schauen wir mal
ob das funktioniert, was ich jetzt
gemacht habe. Q commands.
So.
Und wo kriege ich jetzt hier
die Ausgabe?
Hier.
Also mal schauen, ob da jetzt irgendwas halt
sinnvolles rauskommt. Ja, das ist jetzt
zwei Wochen alt. Das ist legacy. Okay, es scheint
zu funktionieren. Es scheint zu funktionieren,
Leute. Also.
Get
temp wwist ist
51,40002
Grad Celsius.
Also, es ist wirklich
derjenige, der die Ausgabe
und die Kommandos da sich ausgedacht
hat, der gehört wirklich geschlagen. Ich meine, was ist das denn?
Get temp wwist
und dann so eine Ausgabenformatierung.
Das ist doch wirklich absoluter Bains
Champ.
Das ist bestimmt ein Rundungsfehler, ja.
Denke ich auch.
So. Und get betriebsart ist
ww.
Ww bedeutet Warmwasser.
Also, es gibt als Betriebsart für die Heizung
es gibt ww, das ist Warmwasser
und es gibt h plus
ww, das ist Heizung
plus Warmwasser. Okay, ich glaube
ich habe wieder verstanden, was ich das letzte Mal
gebaut habe. Alles klar.
Gut. Ähm.
Warum habe ich das denn
so umständlich gemacht mit Q
und allem? Warum habe ich
das denn so komplett so umständlich gebaut
das letzte Mal?
Ah, ich weiß es, ich weiß es.
Das ist, das ist, dass der
in einer TCP Session
mehrere
Kommandos ausführen kann, ne?
Hier.
Ah, ja, ja, ja, verstehe.
Ah, ja, okay.
Okay, ich glaube, ich glaube,
ich habe wieder verstanden, was ich hier gebaut
habe.
Also, der verbindet sich zum Raspberry Pi
zu der Adresse hier.
Der verbindet sich zum Raspberry Pi
...
Ehm...
und liest das Ergebnis
davon aus.
Und das macht er alles in einer TCP Session,
weil es dann schneller
geht...
Okay...
Okay, das habe ich verstanden.
Und die Sache ist nur die,
wie bekomme ich denn jetzt
die antwort hier wieder raus ob das war nicht sonderlich durchdacht was ich da
gebaut habe ich sollte das hier in der extra klasse verpacken und dann so eine
unkomplizierte callback oder irgendwas in der richtung einbauen aber das machen
wir heute nicht wir bauen heute an einem anderen teil weiter weil die eigentliche
also dass heizung auslesen dass das weiß ich jetzt wie es funktioniert ich muss
gucken wie ich in mein home assistant ein button bekomme bzw wie ich mein
home assistant mein meine heizung des kaffee lassen kann dass das probiert
das probleme heute mal aus also weil home assistant hat so ein eigenes
discovery protokoll für geräte über mq tt und man kann wenn man das richtig
formatiert also wenn man das so hier macht so wie hier beispielsweise
beispiel drin ist leider ist halt das beispiel von den ziemlich ziemlich
gut da ist es halt das beispiel von denen ziemlich ziemlich
ziemlich gut da ist es halt das beispiel von denen ziemlich ziemlich
ab also wenn man so was hier schickt dann erkennt das home assistant als
eigenes gerät und man kann dem sogar mit liefern was es für ein gerät ist also
ich könnte zum beispiel haben es ist und sagen hallo ich bin ich bin gerät a und
ich habe einen sensor einen schalter und einen weiteren temperatursensor und sowas
das heißt ich könnte das schön zusammen kopieren als ein gerät mit 56 verschiedenen
sensoren und sche alter das muss ich jetzt probieren ob ich das hinkriege
diese device Department s
string braucht oder wir können wir können auch water water temp und auch ganz ausschreiben ist
aber wurscht so und jetzt versuche ich mal den sensor irgendwie anzulegen über mqtt in home
assistant so so da irgendwie so dass er das erkennt da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt ob
ihr ob das hinhaut also wie macht man wie macht man device discovery denn so braucht man ein
beispiel ja hier also schlechter formatiert hätten sie das jetzt schreiben können dass
hier meine ich das hier meine ich genau create new sensor manuell also dass da will ich machen
okay dass das probieren wir jetzt aus das probieren wir jetzt aus also wir machen das
ganze mal über command line und schaut mal ob das funktioniert also mein ziel ist jetzt dass
ich es schaffe dass meine heim automatisierung ein neues gerät erkennt
schau mal mqtt admin kleck 3d alles klar sub okay meine credentials stimme schon mal also
message wie macht man das denn jetzt home assistant binary sensor garden config wir
machen einfach mal das beispiel das ist das topic das ist das topic funktioniert doch im leben nicht
was ist wenn ich das jetzt einfach abschicken passiert dann schon irgendwas natürlich nicht
das wäre auch zu einfach wie geht das denn jetzt ok ich kopiere einfach mal diesen mist damit wir
machen wir machen einfach mal das beispiel also name garden device class motion state
topic bei ja meinetwegen bam so hat er jetzt was erkannt dass die bildet nur das beispiel funktioniert
nicht mal das beispiel geht so wie sollte wie sollte der dann heißen der sensor der sensor sollte
heißen garden ok na ja ist am start gut ja das kann übrigens gar nicht funktionieren was ich
hier gemacht habe nun etwas recht sind zu viel zu viele quotes so geht das jetzt wahrscheinlich da ist
er beim binary sensor garden jawohl
aber hier hat er kein device drin stehen warum aber immerhin ja garden wunderbar dass das da die
welt gebraucht so und wie löscht man das jetzt wieder die lizenzer sending mt message okay das
heißt ja aber den garden sensor wenn ich den jetzt löschen will dann schicke ich das hier
nur mit mt message hat nicht funktioniert doch es hat funktioniert nice alles klar
so okay das ist aber noch nicht alles weil ich muss nicht einfach nur ein bein resend so anlegen
ich muss dem sagen dass es zu meiner heizung gehört so und dazu muss ich jetzt sagen die weiße scooby
weiß da weiß ich halt nicht wie es funktioniert die weiß glas ich habe irgendwas mit identifier
im hinterkopf identifier
Okay, das ist wahnsinnig aussagekräftig, die Hilfeseite.
Identifiers, Home Assistant, MQTT.
Google hilft uns.
Identify.
Gibt es denn nicht einfach mal irgendein Exempel für Adding Devices?
Exempel.
Why?
Warte mal.
Exempel.
Muss es doch irgendwas geben.
Discovery.
Da muss es doch irgendwas für geben.
Also ich weiß, dass es funktioniert.
Ich habe das auch schon mal mit Curl ausprobiert.
Aber das ist schon so lange her.
Keine Ahnung mehr.
A-A-MQTT-Device.
Da können wir uns bestimmt abgucken, wie die das machen.
Library that provides tools to simply...
Jawohl.
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Ist das Rust?
Nee.
C++?
Das ist C++.
Oder?
Was ist das?
Source.
Ah!
Muss das sein?
Das ist die einzigen Beispiele, die wir finden.
Identifiers.
Oh Gott, das versteht auch wieder kein Mensch, was der Typ da treibt.
Was zum Identifier?
Ist das nicht irgendein Exempel für...
Meine Güte, da muss doch was zu finden sein.
Das war...
Ich krieg das nicht mal zusammen.
Device Identifier.
Das...
Ich krieg's nicht mal richtig zusammen, wie das...
Wie das, ähm...
Home Assistant selbst sagt, schreib's in die Jammel.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Home Assistant sagt nicht, schreib's in die Jammel.
Weil ich weiß ja noch gar nicht, was ich für ein Gerät habe, was ich in die Jammel schreiben kann.
Das soll der ja discoveren.
Das geht.
Das kriegen wir alles.
Das kriegen wir hin.
Ich brauch nur mal ein ordentliches Beispiel, wo man das sieht.
Ah, haben die vielleicht eine Erklärung dafür?
Identifier.
Nee, nee, wir machen das über die Discovery.
Ich muss nur rauskriegen, wie das funktioniert.
Haben wir vielleicht was in der History dazu schon?
Identifier.
Nein, leider nicht.
Wie ging das denn nochmal?
Also, wie man das prinzipiell anlegt, haben wir ja verstanden.
Das war ja gar nicht so kompliziert.
Das steht ja hier.
Ja.
Gibt es hier noch irgendwas?
Aber was kann man denn hier noch alles anlegen?
Name, Device Class, State Topic.
Es gab irgendwas wie Device.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Ich hab das ja schon mal gemacht.
Vor einer Weile.
Also mal Curl ausprobiert.
Das hat funktioniert.
Da muss es doch ein gescheites Beispiel für geben.
Home Assistant MQTT Discovery.
Device.
Identifier.
Hey, ist irgendwas mit Identifiers?
Das weiß ich noch.
Sorry, Leute.
Flashbang.
Achtung.
Warum ist denn meine?
Flashbang.
Sonst schlafe ich ein.
Identifier.
Nein.
Wo steht denn das, wie das geht?
Okay, wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Wir lassen jetzt.
Lass mal.
Habe ich irgendwas, was ich discovern lassen kann?
Wo ich einfach mitschneiden kann, was es macht?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was.
Okay.
weiß dann noch mal einen sub wie auch immer sub objekt und dann da drin so was noch mal wie name
herr name heck w und dann gab es noch mal identifiers oder sowas und das war dann array
aus noch noch irgendwas ganz ganz wir war das deswegen brauche ich mal ein beispiel dafür
was man auch vielleicht hat es jetzt funktioniert es hat noch nicht mal angelegt natürlich dann aber
ich habe eine idee wir können uns wir können uns einfach an den an den fehlermeldungen lang hangeln
woran sagt dass das nicht passen kann schau mal wie reality oder das motor das man genau das würde
ich ja immer konnte man sich hier nicht loks angucken normalerweise hatte man nicht so ein
drop down für für
für unterschiedliche sorten loks das jetzt weg das ist jetzt woanders das ist das ist das denn
das sensorzeug das ist das meine ich nicht es gab doch hier normalerweise auch loks wenn es
bei der discovery nicht funktioniert ja ich könnte mir auch diese c++ library angucken
das problem ist immer ziemlich schwierig aus source code der jam der jason zusammenbaut
herauszufinden wieder das jason an sich aussieht man vielleicht haben die hier ja irgendeinen
example drin ich muss mal kurz normalerweise loks warte mal ich leute ich muss mal kurz parallel
schauen auf meinem live home assistant ob es da auch so aussieht nee da kann ich hier da kann ich
hier loks durchschalten da gibt es mehrere sachen loks da kann ich zum beispiel auch vom core mir die
loks angucken und dann sieht man auch discovery fehler wo ist denn das hier warum gibt es das hier
nicht warum gibt es das hier nicht wo sind die loks
normalerweise ist hier einen button normalerweise ist hier einen button wo man umschalten kann
zwischen wasser anzeigen soll was wir starten jetzt wir starten das ding jetzt einfach mal
neu configuration starte einfach die komplette vm neu lul bam piss dich aldo nochmal neu starten
das ding nein nein nein ich versuche kein element mit einer id zu finden versuch über die home assistant mqtt discovery ein ddr
weiss zu discoveren das nicht einfach nur ein device sondern was halt zu nehmen also mehrere
sensoren die zu einem device gehören so dass es in der discovery auftaucht da muss ich erst mal ein
beispiel für finden so ein neustart neustarten schadet nie was okay wir haben die gleiche ip wie
vorher alles gut mal reloaden da sind wir wieder home assistant hat restartet
warum zum teufel habe ich hier keine loks mehr ich habe gerade geguckt bei mir im live ich habe hier loks ich kann hier unterschiedliche loks auswählen zwischen was ich sehen will ist das jetzt ist das jetzt woanders oder so aber wir können update okay ich update mal vielleicht vielleicht ist vielleicht ist das problem dann gefixt ja ja ich habe ein bisschen ältere irgendwie broken update
ah wir brauchen kein backup
siehst was willst du von mir wo ist das problem das ist die offizielle installation man warum geht das nicht reload jawohl restart jawohl server error vor was was willst du von mir ist ist die docker container registry gerade down oder was oder wo ist das problem haben die irgendwas haben die irgendwas verkackt haben die irgendwas verkackt okay da müssen wir mal kurz nachdenken
der hilfe suchen das ist eigentlich nicht das was ich jetzt machen wollte und
kann install update fails okay wir brauchen glaube ich ein bisschen mehr update
fehlt wo stand jetzt das mit unauthorized das steht aber auch nicht immer da ja
warum geht das nicht ja genau und was hat er was hat er was hat er denn sonst noch
für schmerzen aber das scheint ja alles zu stimmen try restarting home assistant
try restarting home assistant
ich habe gerade ganze vm neu gestartet scheint ja äußerst komplex zu sein
warum geht das nicht ein ich meine ich habe ich habe das offizielle image
genommen dass der schritt einfach geht ich meine weißt du was ich jetzt mache
ich so würde ja dass ich restart das ding jetzt doch noch mal aber das ist ja
bescheid reboot haus restart restart core ich mache jetzt gleich das ssh addon
drauf und guck ob das funktioniert guck mal hier wie schnell der restart hat
gut high speed hast du internetanbindung in der form das ist ne gute
frage aber ich wüsste nicht warum nicht sagen wir so installier mal das ssh addon
wobei ich das wahrscheinlich anet installieren ja ich muss ja internetanbindung haben sonst hätte
ich ja gar nicht dass das das mqtt addon und zeug installieren können aber addons
mal gucken ob ich bautein addons installieren kann ssh wie hieß das shell die terminal wie hieß's denn das überhaupt so
und das ist halt eine انcarta anbindung weil ich das indoors habe ich das schon mal
wie ist denn das denn jetzt überhaupt
wie hieß denn dieses
SSH Addon
Home Assistant SSH Addon
SSH und Web Terminal
genau das
das meine ich
ja
das brauche ich
äh musste man das noch
adden das ist schon so lang her dass ich das
letzte mal gemacht habe
Enable Advanced User Mode
jawoll
Advanced
der Advanced User Mode
endlich
SSH
so war das SSH und Web Terminal
wahrscheinlich geht das installieren jetzt auch nicht
was will
der denn von mir
haben die gerade bei GitHub
irgendwelche Probleme
haben die irgendwelche Schmerzen
gerade bei
bei GitHub bei der Container Registry
ne das ist kein DNS
Problem
es ist zwar alles
irgendwie ein DNS Problem aber das ist
glaube ich kein DNS Problem
Shit Hub
Home Assistant
das ist irgendein
versuch mal das Image
neu runterzuladen
hä soll ich da neu runterladen
das ist ein
fertiges VM Image
mit allem was man braucht
ich meine ich kann das neu runterladen
und neu installieren
dann habe ich die neue Version aber das
ergibt ja keinen Sinn dass das nicht funktioniert
fails to update
tja
irgendwas
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung was das ist
wir gucken jetzt mal
ob die Leute auch irgendwelche Schmerzen haben
die Woche
nein da sind keine Beispiele drin für das was ich
machen will
da ist nur ein Beispiel drin
wie man ein Device hinzufügt nicht
wie man
quasi ein Root Device
mit mehreren Sensoren zugeordnet
auf einem
bei dir geht es auch nicht
ja dann liegt das nicht an mir dann ist dann
generell gerade irgendwas im Arsch
tja
gut dann können wir nichts upgraden
was
nicht so schlimm ist
dann mach hier ein Update
das geht wahrscheinlich aber auch nicht jetzt
ok
ob das jetzt geht habe ich so meine Zweifel
OS ging kor nicht
ach stimmt vielleicht sehe ich jetzt
die Logs
Connection rebootet
er jetzt gerade
ah der rebootet ok
also das OS
Update hat schon mal funktioniert
dann haben die gerade Probleme
mit ihren Repos dann liegt
das nicht an mir wenn das da nicht funktioniert
ja stimmt jetzt habe ich
Advanced Mode an vielleicht sehe ich jetzt die Logs
genau das ist eine gute Idee
und die sind ja auch schon auf GitHub
umgestiegen nicht mehr auf die Docker Registry
die Docker Registry haben die
haben ja komische Beschränkungen eingeführt in letzter Zeit
auf
starte
gib alles
vm mach hin
ah wir haben es geschafft ok
mal gucken ob er jetzt anzeigt
beim Home Assistant vm ja ja das ist alles
das ist das offizielle Image von dem
für vm ja und da drin ist dann
glaube minimal
worauf setzen die denn jetzt auf
Debian keine Ahnung
und dann Docker
Docker Shit Kram
der ist aber normalerweise relativ gut
funktioniert
also Supervisor System
ah jetzt kann ich die
Logs auswählen ok
guck mal da sehe ich jetzt nämlich
auch was ich verkehrt mache mit meiner Discovery
aber anscheinend
was auch immer
aber ok
upgraden upgraden kann ich nicht
weil es gerade kaputt ist
das liegt nicht an mir ist aber auch
na gehts jetzt wieder
war das nur was temporäres
temporäres vielleicht
ah ne Shell
ne Login
top macht der was
wer hat sich denn
gedacht das das eine gute Farbe ist
wer ist denn auf die Idee gekommen
anstatt das einfach nur schwarz weiß zu machen
eh
ok da macht
anscheinend wirklich was
guck mal der hat geupgradet
jetzt hat jetzt funktioniert
jetzt ging es
ok das war wirklich
irgendwas temporäres das lag
das lag nicht an uns
jetzt kann ich bestimmt auch
jetzt kann ich bestimmt auch den Kram installieren
Sensor with multiple values ne ne
das ist nicht das richtige
das muss irgendwie so aussehen
zusätzlich Device musst du irgendwie angeben
und dann irgendwie Identifiers
so muss das irgendwie aussehen
das ist hier alles nicht drin
das ist ja auch ein Sensor
mit mehreren Values ich brauch keinen Sensor
mit mehreren Values ich brauch ein
Gerät was mehrere Sensoren
hat und Schalter und so
ich weiß ich weiß prinzipiell
wie es aussehen muss aber ich finde keine
kein richtiges Beispiel dafür
how to turn MQTT
into a device
ok das das das klingt doch schon mal ganz
vielversprechend
ja das ist es
das brauche ich
endlich warum muss man
warum muss man sich so ein Beispiel
genau Identifiers name
das brauche ich
warum muss man sich so ein Crap
aus einem Forum suchen
kann nicht sein
ok
jetzt gucken wir uns mal an ob es ankommt
also jetzt kann ich das nochmal neu ausprobieren
nochmal testweise hier hinschreiben
so
warum kommentiert er das eigentlich
nicht aus und will das ausführen
irgendeine ZSH Config
also was mache ich denn
jetzt hier falsch
ich muss sagen
das ist ein Sensor
ich will ja gar nicht
als das Garden heißt
ok wir bleiben bei dem Standard
Beispiel wir bleiben bei dem Standard
so und was machen die da jetzt
Device das mache ich auch
Name
mache ich auch
auch richtig
ich habe Identifiers falsch geschrieben
oder
Identifiers
habe ich das falsch geschrieben
copy paste das jetzt einfach
aber ich habe das nicht gequotet
guck mal daran wird es wahrscheinlich
sag bloß ich habe alles richtig gemacht aus dem Kopf
und habe Quotes vergessen
sind wir denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben da
Config
ne
nicht funktioniert
also gut
da gucken wir uns jetzt mal die Hilfe
nicht die Hilfe an die Fehlermeldung an
was habe ich denn jetzt hier verkackt
normalerweise sollten hier die Fehler drinstehen
hm
was ist denn jetzt hier falsch
also Device
Device
ich nehme mal das ganze Beispiel von dem Kerl
oh ne
ah wo habe ich denn
MonkaS
habe ich das schon wieder zugemacht
ah Leute wo habe ich
ich habe es doch eben gerade gefunden
wo ist es Chat
welches Tab ist es
ah da
alles klar ok
so ist es angeblich richtig
wir testen mal ob das funktioniert
einfach wenn ich das so mache
wie der Typ das hier geschrieben hat
blub
ne das funktioniert mit den Quotes schon mal garantiert nicht
öh
kann man hier nicht
gescheit raus copy pasten
ja ja die Quotes sind
sind sehr komisch
was ist das denn für komische
Igitt
was sind das für komische Quotes
ich schreibe das jetzt doch nochmal von Hand
ja ein Config Sensor
so Device
also
wir machen es jetzt mal in der Reihenfolge
auch wie dieser Typ hier
so alles weg
also das wissen wir
dass es funktioniert
ok Unique ID
Unique ID brauchen wir glaube ich noch
ja natürlich
wir brauchen das kann ich mich auch noch
wir brauchen irgendeine Unique ID
weil er ansonsten das glaube ich nicht
erkennt weil
mehrere Sensoren zu einem
Device hinzugefügt sind
braucht das Ding irgendwie
ne eigene ID
ok
so und dann macht er was
Device
so hier das da
das ist das eigentlich wichtige
das da brauchen wir
das hier was bei Device drin steht
also Device
so
neues Objekt auf
so Identifiers
das gibt ein eigenes Array
so das Ding heißt ja
was weiß ich 0
wie auch immer ist ja egal
ein Identifier
Name 0w nur weil ich das nicht doppelt habe
so wie ich mich kenne
Moment das stimmt ja auch nicht doch oder
ok
dann macht er noch
Garage Door Model Manufacter
das brauche ich alles nicht
ok
der hat das jetzt auch gepusht
ok hoffentlich geht das jetzt
das 0w Device
es hat funktioniert
jawoll
da ist es
sehr schön
sehr schön sehr schön
jetzt kann ich auch erzählen wofür das da ist
der erkennt jetzt
ein Gerät
und hier würden die ganzen Sensoren stehen
die zu diesem Gerät gehören
das heißt man kann das jetzt gruppieren
so wie ich das vorhin gemacht habe
und so wie das bei denen auch in der offiziellen Seite drin steht
legst du quasi ein Gerät
pro Sensor an
und das will ich ja gar nicht
ich will ja ein Gerät anlegen was mehrere Sensoren drin hat
das ist viel besser
ich weiß nicht warum die
Hilfeseite so kacke ist
so das ist das doch schön
also jetzt wisst ihr schon mal
dass das im Prinzip so funktioniert
so wie füge ich da jetzt Sensoren hinzu
das hätte er eigentlich doch jetzt erkennen müssen
hier unten müsste doch
jetzt eigentlich ein Sensor drinstehen
no entities
ok also jetzt hat er schon mal was zu sagen
ich habe es discovered
und da muss ich jetzt erstmal mal
einen Stand setzen
dass das funktioniert
Garden
oder ich muss eine Device Class setzen
das kann natürlich auch sein
wobei habe ich das nicht hier gesetzt
Device Class
Device Class Motion doch
Unique IT Garden
der sollte jetzt eigentlich erkennen
dass das Device einen Motion Sensor hat
wenn ich das richtig verstehe
das sollte
normalerweise hier unten drunter stehen
aber ich finde schon mal gut
dass der das Device
erkannt hat
da bin ich schon mal froh
so löschen wir das mal wieder
was habe ich denn jetzt hier verkehrt gemacht
ich glaube die Reihenfolge ist egal
brauche ich hier das
mit der Unique ID muss ich mal kurz gucken
ob man das wirklich braucht
ne das braucht man nicht
so jetzt muss ich mal noch mal
das Beispiel angucken von dem Typ oben
ok also
was macht der denn hier jetzt
der macht Name
Device Class
das habe ich auch
Device Class Motion habe ich auch
ähm State Topic
Home Assistant Binary
das wird auch stimmen
State Topic
da hat der irgendwie noch Unique ID drin
ok vielleicht braucht man
das wirklich
ich füge das nochmal hinzu
Unique ID
äh was weiß ich
Heizchamp
das allein hat der nichts gebracht
warum taucht denn der Sensor jetzt nicht auf
muss man vielleicht
wirklich noch was setzen
für den Sensor das da drin steht
habe ich jetzt irgendwas
nicht drin was der Typ noch drinsteht
Model Manufacturer das ist doch eigentlich voll
vollkommen egal
schau mal das hier Developer Assist
Aha
oh jetzt
jetzt wirds abgedreht
ja genau
ist Binary Sensor nicht True False
äh ja
ja ist es auch
ja ist es
aber ich setz ja noch keinen Status aktuell
vielleicht muss ich wirklich einen Status pushen
dass das drinne steht
ich mein die hätten einfach ein JSON Beispiel hin machen können oder
warum haben die nicht einfach ein JSON Beispiel
geschrieben anstatt diesen Krempel hier
mach mal switch anstatt
Binary Sensor
Binary Sensor ist doch ok das ist das einfachste
was man haben kann
ich push jetzt einfach mal
nen State zu meinem Binary Sensor
Binary Sensor
State on
ja
bam
hui
State on
bam so hat das jetzt was
der erkennt gar keinen Sensor da dran
was hab ich denn vergessen
lass mal hier gucken ob
das jetzt bei
Entities
warum steht der da jetzt doppelt drinne
ich ich ich kopier mir jetzt wirklich
ich kopier mir jetzt wirklich mal
das Testing da rein von dem Typ
äh
was war das
Identify RF Bridge genau
ne warte mal wo ist das Beispiel
von dem Kerl nochmal da
Topic Binary
Sensor ok
ich mach jetzt einfach mal
jetzt brauch ich eine Unique ID dafür
das testen wir jetzt aber gleich mal
gleich
Unique ID ist dann
auch so
Off Delay
brauchen wir gar net
und das was bei Device steht ist dann das woran
das alles drunter zusammenfassen soll
also das ist dann
was weiß ich
Root oder so
Moment Name ist doppelt
das Modell kann doch auch weg
Manufaktor
braucht kein Digo
So mal gucken ob das jetzt noch funktioniert
Ha der Heizchamp
da ist er
Ok vielleicht liegt es daran das es nicht funktioniert
Alles klar
Ok jetzt war ah hier guck mal
hier ist jetzt auch mein Sensor
das heißt wenn ich den jetzt einschalte
das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren
und schalte mal angenommen irgendjemand drückt
unten auf der Heizung auf
auf den auf den
Heizung an aus Knopf
gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten entweder man macht es über das Web Interface
oder man macht es über die Heizung selbst
dann sage ich
jetzt hier Binary Sensor on
und zack er ist an
ja wunderbar ok
ich glaube ich habe jetzt halbwegs verstanden
wie der ganze Kram funktioniert guck hier
Sleep 2
und jetzt schaltet er an Bäm
gut gut gut
so ich glaube jetzt habe meine Güte
das ist aber schon echt
Big Brainst
aber das hier ist übrigens
nice wer auch immer das
gepostet hat ich weiß nicht wer war es denn hier
äh
der Chillfreak
hat es gepostet das ist
sehr hilfreich hier
das brauche ich genau sowas
ok
hey ich weiß wenigstens was ich jetzt
bauen muss nice
excellent excellent
ich mache mal einen anderen Test
wir machen jetzt keinen Binary Sensor
ach komm wir programmieren das jetzt
also ich weiß jetzt ja im Prinzip wie es aussehen muss
so so muss es aussehen
kann man das vielleicht ein bisschen
bisschen Zeilen umbrechen
da ich da
irgendwas gescheites noch erkenne
ok das heißt wir brauchen jetzt erstmal
einen MQTT Client für .net
da gibt es
da gibt es einen ganz guten
wartet mal
also wir brauchen
MQTT Client
.net
da gibt es einen recht guten nämlich den da
den verwendet der Preisschamp auch
unter der Haube
ich wusste
ich wusste nämlich nicht was ich für eine Message Queue
verwenden sollte für den
Preisschamp und
der Crawler
den ich dafür verwende der kann bloß
MQTT das heißt ich verwende auch
MQTT.net das meine
Crawler Server an den
Frontend Ausliefer Server schicken
können wenn was verfügbar ist
aber
das ist broken sehe ich gerade übrigens Leute
ich weiß nicht ob von einer
von einem von euch
hier noch den das den Kram verwendet
der Preisschamp geht glaube ich Ende des
Monats offline
ich habe kein Bock mehr neue Geräte reinzubasteln
und
die Verfügbarkeit ist eigentlich wieder ganz ok
ich glaube Ende des Monats
ist Schluss mit dem Preisschamp
ich sag so schonmal ne
du schaust jeden Tag rein
ich meine ich kann es auch
ich kann es auch weiter laufen lassen
es ist jetzt nicht wirklich als das
irgendwie bei mir viel
Aufwand verursachen würde
es kostet mich halt
im Monat irgendwie 40
lass mal überlegen was kostet mich denn im Monat
ich glaube
40 Euro oder so
3 Triple Core Crawler
und ne Frontend Kiste
ich glaube 40 Euro oder so
kostet mich das ich meine
zu viel vom Geld her nicht mal
aber ich werde da halt wahrscheinlich
nie wieder was dran machen
ok also wir brauchen MQTT.net
MQTT
wie alt bist du eigentlich
ja ich bin 37
und benutze
Relive Twitch Emotes
ja man muss
man muss mit der Zeit gehen
so MQTT.net
Managed Client
die zwei Sachen brauchen wir hier
reicht es auch wenn man das installiert
und den Rest die Abhängigkeiten mit installiert
Agiler Boomer so sieht es aus
MQTT.net
Managed Client
Examples
also wir machen jetzt das da
was wir hier auf der Kommandozeile
in vielleicht nicht ganz gut lesbare Art gemacht haben
machen wir jetzt
mal
in .net
also da müssen wir uns erstmal verbinden
wie funktioniert der Kram
ich muss echt hier den Darkreader aus
kann man
GitHub Darkmode einschalten
ohne eingeloggt zu sein
geht das
ich glaube das geht nicht oder
ich glaube man muss eingeloggt sein
ich sehe hier nämlich nichts für
ok muss doch einschalten
ne ich glaube Darkmode schaltet man
im Profil ein und ich habe ja kein Profil
brauchst du alle Topics des
Devices ich leg die Topics ja selbst
fest
oh das sieht Business
Business Strongs mäßig aus MQTT.net
MQTT Client Factory
warum ist das so kompliziert
warum kann ich nicht
einfach sagen
New MQTT Client und gebe
das geht also mit der Standard
ESP32 MQTT Library einfacher
warum ist das so
so anstrengend
zu verwenden
ich habe den Client noch nie verwendet muss ich sagen
ich habe immer den MQTT Server verwendet
und der ist
ganz ok
ok copy paste auf gehts
zack
alles
importieren
das ist ja der neueste Shit gerade
das macht Microsoft auch gerne
also wenn ihr euch mal irgendwelche
ASP.net Sachen von Microsoft anguckt
das sieht alles so aus mittlerweile
Bilder Pattern genau
ich denke mir halt
so
warum
ich meine
ist es wirklich so schwierig zu sagen
sowas hier
irgendwie
PW
ist das zu kompliziert
ist das zu einfach wahrscheinlich
ist das zu einfach
also
Auto Connect Delay
5 Sekunden
Client Options
Client ID
Heiz
Champ
Leute was ist besser Heizung Champ
der Heiz Champ ist glaube ich besser oder
der Heiz Champ
1681.129
Port
muss man hier Port
ne
Port
hier darf ich schon so hinschreiben
der Heiz Champ
der
Wärme Champ
ja der Wärme Champ
ich habe immer Bedenken wenn die Umlaute drinnen haben
das ist das
irgendwie rumspackt
ich nenn es lieber Heiz Champ
Temp Champ
Temp Champ ist auch nicht besser
das hört sich aber so nach Tempore an
TLS
lul lul
als würden wir hier irgendwas verschlüssen
Bild Bild
was zum
jetzt wird es aber übertrieben
HS Yoho 21 Monate
danke für den Sub
Du brauchst ein Managed MQTT Client Options Builder
und dann brauchst du einen
MQTT Client Options Builder
nochmal
das ist ein Managed Client Options Builder
und das ist ein Client Options
die spinnen doch oder
man kann es auch absichtlich
kompliziert machen
ja
da platzt der Kopf
mag ja alles seinen Sinn haben
aber warum
nicht so
wobei wir können das rappen
wir rappen das gleich einfach
wir machen da draus ein
Public Class
Simple MQTT Client
wir rappen das
und dann mach ich das so wie ich das will
aber erstmal kurz gucken ob das überhaupt klappt
was ich hier bastle
MQTT Factory Create New Managed Client
ja gut meinetwegen
achso wie mach ich das hier mit Passwort überhaupt
Passwort
ah
with Authentification
was soll das sein
Message
Byte Array
alles klar
jetzt kommt der Auth Builder gleich
genau
Moment ich benutze bestimmt das falsche
with Credentials
das klingt doch auch nicht
ah ok ok ich hab nix gesagt
ich hab nix gesagt also
Username
aber glaub ich Admin oder
Admin jawoll Admin
Passwort
alles klar ok
meine Güte
ähm
ok
bla bla bla
Bild jetzt brauchen wir eine
MQTT Factory Create Managed
MQTT Client
Subscribe
ne ne ne ne
ich will einfach was Publishen und gucken ob es ankommt
will einfach nur was Publishen
und gucken ob das hier unten erscheint
also MQTT Client
Publish
gut das funktioniert so schau mal
Await Publish
Application Message kann ich nicht einfach sagen Topic
doch Topic Hack
und
Message 123
so und wenn ich das hier
wenn das jetzt alles funktioniert
dann sollte es hier unten jetzt auftauchen
was
Call Start Async
achso ah ich kack noob guck mal da
ja ok
das ist das Funktionalste
das hier ist der
Raspbery Pipe Keller
der sich zur Heizung verbindet
war das ja falsch so
So, so ist richtig.
Aber es funktioniert doch trotzdem nicht.
Ach, 2.
Das erinnert mich an die Fizzbuzz Enterprise Edition.
Ist echt so.
Das ist total übertrieben.
Was die hier gebastelt haben.
Ja, man kann es auch echt übertreiben.
Ah, jetzt geht es.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Nice.
Publish.
Gut.
Jetzt bestimmt auch ohne das Warten hier.
Ne?
Echt nett.
Ist aber ziemlich mies.
Der wartet gar nicht.
Guck mal, der wartet mit dem Publishen nicht.
Ich muss hier wirklich noch ein Readline reinmachen.
Das ist ja schon fail.
Okay.
Aber ich muss mir ehrlich sagen,
also die Handhabung gefällt mir ja wirklich gar nicht.
Ich meine, was ist das denn hier?
Egal.
Komm, wir rappen das jetzt mal so.
Dass mir das besser gefällt.
Simple MQTT Client.
So, also wir brauchen einen Konstruktor.
Der will...
Also, Konstruktor will haben einen Endpoint-Server.
Einen Port.
Irgendwie sowas.
Was ist der Default-Port?
Default-Port ist 1883.
MQTT Default-Port.
Ich glaube, ja, da steht doch schon.
1883.
Ja, richtig.
Ähm.
Ja.
Passwort.
Auch standardmäßig leer, falls man das nicht braucht.
Und...
Nee, nicht Passwort.
Mal hier.
User.
Standardmäßig leer.
Und Passwort standardmäßig leer.
So.
Weil jetzt kann ich den ganzen Krempel,
nämlich anstatt das hier...
Naja, geh mal kurz hier weg.
Jetzt kann ich das nämlich einfach so anlegen.
Wir machen mal...
Wir verschieben das jetzt mal in ein eigenes File.
Äh...
Ah, das kann der noch nicht.
Guck mal, da ist Ry damit überfordert.
Wenn man...
Ähm...
Wie heißt denn das?
Diese...
Also, wenn man die Files nimmt, ohne diese Class-Main-Geschichten drumherum.
Wie heißt denn das offiziell bei denen?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Das ist ja neu, seit dem letzten oder vorletzten C-Sharp,
dass man sein Main-Programm ohne irgendwelche Sachen einfach in der Datei reinschreiben kann.
Okay, dann legen wir jetzt hier mal an.
Also, New Class.
Simple.
Simple MQTT Clients.
IP-Adresse als C-Sharp-Klasse benutzen?
Nee, wir benutzen was anderes.
Zeigt dir auch gleich was.
Wir benutzen an der Stelle wieder ein IP-Endpoint.
Und dann kann man sich nämlich auch den Port sparen, weil er steckt dann da schon mit drin.
Okay, ähm...
Jetzt kann ich das nämlich in meinem Main-Programm einfach so anlegen.
War MQTT-Client gleich New MQTT-Client Endpoint.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Pass.
1.0.2.1.6.8.2.1.3.3.
Und dann Passwort Admin.
Also User Admin, Passwort 1.2.3.5.6.
Das ist doch deutlich schöner als dieses andere Gedöns, was ich da vorher machen musste.
So.
Jetzt muss ich nur noch gucken, dass ich das hier ordentlich, ordentlich rappe alles.
Options.
A-Import.
Import.
Client Factory.
Wunderbar.
Naja, mach mal, importier mal alles.
Start.
Ey, ist irgendwie ja gut.
Awaiten im Constructor funktioniert nicht, aber ich muss das auch nicht erwaiten.
Einfach starten und dann startet er halt, wenn er gestartet hat und gut ist.
So.
Das ist doch jetzt schon viel, viel schicker als die andere Geschichte.
Jetzt brauche ich noch...
Irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, was zu Publishen.
Schön in Bilder, in Bilder weggerappt.
Ja.
Ich meine, was ist das hier?
The fuck?
Bilder, Bilder.
Jetzt fehlt, hier fehlt wahrscheinlich noch Credentials-Bilder.
Die gibt es bestimmt auch noch.
Ah, fast.
Hätte ich gedacht, Credentials-Bilder gibt es auch, gibt es vielleicht auch noch.
Okay, äh, also.
Public.
Async.
Brauchen wir wahrscheinlich jetzt.
Task.
Pub.
Einfach nur Pub.
Wir machen das ganz kurz und knackig.
Publish.
Plotet.
Fünf Buchstaben gespart.
Gibt, gibt Bonuspunkte.
Publish.
So, wir wollen Publishen.
String.
Topic.
Message.
Fertig.
Wir wollen keine Bytes oder sowas publiken, wir wollen einfach nur Strings publischen, sonst nichts.
So.
Ähm.
Ach so, den sollte ich mir vielleicht mal speichern.
Habe ich noch nicht.
Okay.
So.
MQTT-Client.
Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Is always assigned before used.
Jaja, das jetzt, jetzt, jetzt nicht mehr.
MQTT-Client.
Publish.
Topic.
Message.
Das ist jetzt relativ, relativ kurz.
Ja, aber, nein, warum soll ich mehr nachbauen, als es eigentlich, eigentlich sein müsste?
So.
Und das soll es eigentlich gewesen sein.
Die IP solltest du aus den Parametern nehmen.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist ziemlich bescheuert, die da zu verwenden.
Kann man hier vielleicht direkt?
Einen Endpoint eintragen?
Ernsthaft jetzt?
Ein MQTT-Client-TCP-Options-Builder.
Wirklich?
Ist das euer Ernst?
Was soll ich noch alles bilden?
Oh Mann, hör mal auf, ey.
So, ich brauch mal kurz eine andere Playlist.
Äh.
Oh, ne. Anstrengend.
Ja, hier. Wunderbar.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Die übertreiben es jetzt echt.
So.
IP Endpoint.
Doof, dass man das nicht einfach übergeben kann.
Hallo?
Kann man das?
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Kann man das toStringen und es funktioniert?
Kann man den Endpoint toString machen und es kommt, kommt was richtiges raus?
Das hab, weiß ich gar nicht.
Muss ich jetzt mal kurz ausprobieren.
Ähm, hallo?
IP Endpoint.
Pass.
Ja, 1111, 3002, was auch immer.
So, und jetzt.
ToString.
So, was kommt denn da jetzt raus?
Kommt da jetzt was ordentliches raus?
Aha!
Guck mal.
Das, das muss ich sagen, das ist wirklich was, was ich an der .NET Standard Library mag.
Die macht in der Regel das, was man erwartet.
Und das ist eigentlich so das Höchste, was man wollen kann.
Dass der Mist sich einfach so verhält, wie man, wie man will.
Dass er sich einfach so verhält, wie man, wie man haben, wie man das haben will.
Ja, Client ID sollte ich auch übergeben.
Und hier sollte ich vielleicht auch nicht Hardcoded reinschreiben, sondern
User und pw.
So, Heizchamp, Client ID.
Komm, klick da auch noch hin und dann.
Client ID.
Tja, gut.
Die Client ID sollte ich, sollte ich vielleicht gar nicht optional machen.
Braucht man überhaupt eine Client ID?
Ist aber ganz bescheuert.
Braucht man eine Client ID?
Dann soll er sich eine Random Client ID ausdenken.
Ist mir doch egal.
Die Client ID juckt mich mal absolut gar nicht.
MQTT Client.
Hopp.
Await.
Da haben wir ja gelernt, das funktioniert, das reicht nicht.
Deswegen muss ich tatsächlich mal nochmal einen Readline dran machen.
Hopp.
Keg.
Null.
So.
Mal schauen, ob das jetzt Published.
War ich nicht dabei, als das gepub...
Funktioniert nicht.
Warum nicht?
Es ist broken.
Welchen, welchen Sinn?
Welchen, welchen Sinn hat der ganze Bilder-Kram?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Also normalerweise hat es...
Moment.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Also normalerweise hat es den Sinn...
Also das ist die Geschichte, das hat, das hat sich Microsoft mal ausgedacht.
Ich glaube, das ist entstanden, vermute ich mal, bei ASP.NET Core als Host-Builder.
Da konntest du, bevor du deine Web-Anwendung überhaupt, also bevor du den Web-Server deiner
Web-Anwendung überhaupt startest, konntest du dem ein paar Optionen mitgeben.
So.
Und damit du nicht eine Instanz quasi erstmal anlegen musst, die du danach per Optionen
customizest und es relativ komplex war, sich das zusammenzubauen, hat Microsoft sich einen
Host-Builder überlegt für ASP.NET Core, wo man dann zusammenbauen konnte, so was weiß
ich, auf welchem Port soll der ganze Kram laufen, wohin soll es loggen und solche Geschichten.
Also im Prinzip eine Web-Server-Config.
So.
Und es gab dann halt Entwickler, die fanden das so geil.
Dass sie es jetzt halt überall reingebaut haben.
Funktioniert Start-Async im Constructor?
Ja, das funktioniert, solange man nicht Awaiten will.
Aber mir ist es ja egal, wann es gestartet ist.
Hauptsache es ist gestartet.
Wobei, jetzt wo ich es gerade sage, vielleicht ist mir das gar nicht egal.
Geht es deswegen nicht.
Ich mache nochmal die Client-ID.
Vielleicht will der ja ohne Client-ID nicht.
Wie ist das Ding?
Heizchamp.
Der publischt nichts.
Warum publischt denn der Client-ID?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Muss ich wirklich.
Muss ich wirklich auf den, auf den Start warten?
Es ist zwar zwar nicht schön, aber ob es daran liegt?
User und Passwort sind leer.
Nee, User und Passwort sind nicht leer.
User und Passwort stehen hier drinnen.
Äh.
Das jetzt nicht.
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Warum geht das nicht?
Hä?
So schwer ist es doch jetzt wirklich nicht gewesen, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Port?
Ey, Port ist Default.
Ach so.
Warte mal.
Was kommt denn hier raus, wenn ich keinen Port angebe?
Zack.
Ja, okay.
Ja, das ist aber dumm.
Das ist aber dumm.
Das ist aber doof.
Funktioniert halt immer noch nicht.
Ne, was war es?
MQD Default.
Default Port.
1, 8, 8, 3.
Warum geht denn das jetzt nicht?
Das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass das nicht funktioniert.
What the fuck?
Da hat sich doch überhaupt nichts dran geändert.
Okay, wartet mal.
String.
Server.
Okay.
Weg damit.
So.
Jetzt ist es doch exakt das.
Exakt das, was ich...
Ach so.
Was ich das letzte Mal auch hatte.
Bloß, kann doch nicht sein, dass man mit so einfachem Kack sich so lange aufhält.
Der publisht einfach nichts.
But why?
Warum publisht der nichts?
Der verbindet sich überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe hier irgendwas verkehrt.
Der verbindet sich erst gar nicht.
Wetten?
Okay, mal checken.
User.
Pw.
Kann doch jetzt ernsthaft.
Das kann doch jetzt nicht sein.
So, Server.
Server.
Verbindet sich.
Da hin.
Ich mache jetzt extra einen Wait hinten dran, dass er das nicht macht.
Konsolen-Debugger-Bestel.
So.
Moment.
Machen wir das nochmal weg.
Jetzt geht's.
Hä?
Was habe ich jetzt anders gemacht?
Ich habe den Port weggemacht.
Ich blick nebenher durch.
Man kann da gar kein...
Man kann da keinen Port angeben.
Kann das sein?
Wie gebe ich...
Wie gebe ich hier den Port an?
Port?
Der will den Port an der Stelle nicht haben.
Kann man hier vielleicht noch einen Port angeben?
Ah.
Mit dem Portbilder.
Genau.
Ah, jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Ja, okay.
Dann machen wir das.
Dann machen wir das doch so, wie ich mir das ursprünglich gedacht habe.
Port.
1, 8, 8, 3.
Komm, wir machen das so.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, da kommen wir am besten hin.
Okay.
Jetzt sollte es aber endlich funktionieren.
Ach, jetzt denkt er, dass das der Port ist.
Okay.
Dann muss man es halt direkt...
Übrigens, das ist ein Feature, was C++ bis heute noch nicht hat.
Named Arguments.
Also eigentlich eines der wichtigsten...
der wichtigsten Dinger überhaupt.
Aber...
haben die sich gedacht.
Nope.
Wollen wir nicht.
Overrated, Cheap-Aided, Outdated.
Da kann man viel zu sehr lesen.
Nein, die haben keine Named Arguments.
Das kann man jetzt ja tatsächlich direkt lesen.
Fast sogar noch...
Fast sogar noch besser als vorher.
Ich habe das Gefühl, meine Maus spackt wieder ein bisschen rum.
Das wäre es jetzt nämlich echt gewesen.
Nach zwei Wochen oder so.
Lull.
Nee, aber scheint jetzt zu funktionieren.
Gut.
Also, nachdem wir jetzt die Basics aus dem Weg haben, die eigentlich noch weniger als Basics sind,
können wir das jetzt verbinden.
Alles klar.
So, jetzt kann ich versuchen, diesen Kram mal in meinen Home Assistant zu machen.
Und zu exportieren.
Binder.
Oh, Delete.
Jawoll.
Geh weg.
Also, wir haben einen MQTT-Client.
Verbinden uns.
Passwort, wie auch immer.
Publish.
So.
Ich würde sagen, wir brauchen irgendeine JSON-Library.
Dann nehmen wir einfach...
das Standard-Ding.
Was ja Microsoft selbst nicht mehr verwenden möchte.
Die haben jetzt ja System Text JSON oder sowas.
Aber ich finde, Usability-mäßig ist das immer noch am besten.
Aber...
Ich habe ein Video gesehen in .NET 6, was wir eigentlich verwenden.
Also, könnte man das wirklich mal ausprobieren.
.NET 6, New JSON API.
Es gibt jetzt neue...
Es gibt jetzt in .NET Extension Sachen für JSON,
dass man JSON.NET nicht mehr braucht.
JSON-Node, pass.
Ich habe das aber noch nie verwendet.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Kann man das hier importieren?
Wir probieren das jetzt mal.
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Im Titel steht .NET 6.
Also, probieren wir jetzt auch mal was .NET 6-mäßiges aus.
Also, deinstallieren wir das wieder.
JSON schreiben ist mit Newtonsoft immer noch einfacher.
Hast du auch das .NET Zeug schon ausprobiert?
Das .NET 6 Zeug?
Weil das...
Also, bisher habe ich auch immer gesagt, das ist abartig as fuck.
Die neuen JSON APIs.
Aber mit .NET 6 ist es angeblich besser geworden.
New JSON Object.
Guck mal hier.
India.
Ja.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
New JSON Object.
Das alte konntest du nicht schreiben.
Mit .NET 6 haben die jetzt was Neues, eine neue JSON-Geschichte obendrauf gebaut,
wo man auch sich Objekte zusammenbauen kann, weil sie selbst, habe ich in einem Webcast gehört,
weil sie gesagt haben, sie sehen immer noch, dass viele Leute JSON.NET verwenden,
weil die Handhabung noch nicht auf gleichem Niveau ist.
Deswegen haben die jetzt so Dinge hier eingerichtet.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Im Titel steht .NET 6.
Wir müssen jetzt auch mal was .NET 6-mäßiges ausprobieren.
Also, New JSON Object.
Was brauchen wir denn da?
So, also wie muss man das jetzt schreiben?
Muss man das so schreiben oder kann man auch...
Muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Kann man auch sowas hier machen?
Age gleich 29?
Nein, passiert nicht.
Okay, man muss das...
Ah, doch.
Doch, anscheinend schon.
Property Name, Node Value.
Also kann ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sagen, keg w und dann value...
Ach nee, value, Komma.
Aha, das geht.
Ich wäre nie im Leben anhand dieser Parameter da drauf gekommen,
dass man das so schreiben muss.
Skillkiller, das verstehe ich auch nur zum Teil.
Die Begründung von Microsoft, warum sie JSON.NET nicht wollen, ist,
ich vermute erstens, weil sie den JSON.NET-Typ eingekauft haben für das ASP.NET-Team
und zweitens, weil sie gesagt haben, es ist zu langsam.
Also sie sagen ja, ihre JSON-Implementierung,
gerade was für Web-Anwendungen, was ja bei ASP.NET eben auch wichtig ist,
wäre das JSON, Newtonsoft-JSON zu langsam und das neue viel besser.
Wie kommt man auf die Idee, dass das...
Ist das die offizielle Schreibweise für einen Key-Value-Pair zum Initialisieren oder so?
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, noch nie, wusste ich nicht,
dass das möglich ist an der Stelle, das so zu schreiben.
Also das heißt im Endeffekt, ich kann jetzt hier sowas machen,
wie, probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Wir bauen jetzt mal den Kram zusammen.
Also, Name.
Name ist Peter.
So.
Gute Frage.
Ich habe in meiner Ausbildung das in der letzten Woche oder in den letzten paar Tagen
habe ich drei Jahre Ausbildung zusammen randomized,
Word-Dokument-mäßig und dann irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 150 Seiten oder so ausgedruckt.
Und daraufhin hat mein damaliger Ausbildungs- oder einer der Leute,
die mich ausgebildet haben, mit noch nicht mal mein Chef damals,
hat gesagt, weißt du was, scanne meine Unterschrift ein und hau es einfach überall drunter.
Der hatte keinen Bock, den Kram zu unterschreiben.
Der hat einfach gesagt, weißt du was, passt schon, scanne meine Unterschrift ein und hau drunter.
Hat auch geklappt.
Wobei die IHK gesagt hat, sie fanden meine Ausbildungsberichte nicht gut.
Aber nachdem die Präsentation gut war,
und meine Prüfung gut war und alles insgesamt gut war,
haben die gesagt, weißt du was, geh heim, alles ist gut.
Also, Name Peter.
So, als nächstes kommt State Topic.
Aber diese Schreibweise von Key-Value-Pair-Initialisierter habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sowas hier mache,
da kommt ein Key-Value-Pair raus?
Nee.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Dann verstehe ich es nicht.
Dann checke ich diese Schreibweise hier nicht, das ist mir zu hoch.
Das muss ja so eine Art Key-Value-Pair-Initializer sein, was ich hier mache.
Aber ich kann da auch mehrere angeben, wie geht das denn?
Moment, das hier ist irgendeine Collection, oder?
Das ist doch irgendeine Collection.
Das ist irgendeine Dictionary Collection oder so.
Mal erstmal kurz gucken, wie das überhaupt funktioniert.
Das Berichtsheft ist maximal unnötig.
Naja.
Ja gut, das hier ist ja einfach nur diese Initializer-Geschichte.
Aber woher weiß der denn, dass das hier quasi sowas wie Add Range ist?
Das muss ich mir nochmal angucken.
Das könnte ich für eigene Sachen auch ganz gut verwenden.
Also, Heater-State-Topic brauchen wir als nächstes.
State-Topic ist das da.
Was aber so nicht stimmt, das muss ich...
Oh, das wird lustig, das muss ich zusammenbauen.
Äh...
Weil State-Topic, das muss ja Unix sein pro Gerät.
Das heißt, ich muss irgendwas mit meiner MAC-Adresse oder so bauen.
Also, State-Topic muss dann quasi Sensorname...
Theoretisch müsste es sein, Sensorname...
Das können wir jetzt an der Stelle gleich ausprobieren.
Das müsste dann sowas sein wie ähm...
Sensorname heißt dann, keine Ahnung, in dem Fall jetzt äh...
Heizung.
Ja.
Das müsste dann sein, sowas wie Sensorname.
Aber davor...
Davor müsste dann noch irgendwie ein Unix äh...
Irgendeine ID kommen.
Irgendwas Randomizedes oder MAC...
MAC-Adresse.
Davor müsste dann noch eine ID kommen.
Weil ansonsten funktioniert das Ganze ja nicht.
Ich mach mal...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht, weil...
Es muss bei jedem Neustart die gleiche ID generiert werden.
Sonst hätte ich auch Randomized irgendwas genommen.
Da bietet sich die MAC an, an der Stelle, würde ich sagen.
Bei...
Was, bei mir haben die Prüfer...
sich die Berichte letztes Jahr sogar angeguckt und dazu Fragen gestellt.
Tja.
Bei mir nicht.
Client-ID.
Ja, die Client-ID ist echt nicht verkehrt, die könnte ich nehmen.
Wobei ich eher sagen würde, die Client-ID setzt sich zusammen aus...
Nee, das sollte irgendwas...
Bin nicht ganz sicher, ob wir das machen können.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Die Client-ID muss ich ja hardcoded vergeben, was aber kein Problem ist, weil...
Das würde ich ja eh einzigartig machen.
Schauen wir mal.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Xiaomi.
Also.
Wir machen mal Sensor-ID, irgendwie MAC.
MAC.
Kommt da noch irgendwas rein?
Also, das ist das Date-Topic.
Ich will ja einfach nur probieren, ob das Chasen-Zeug jetzt funktioniert.
Was im Topic drinsteht, ist total...
Naja, das stimmt schon, aber das ist insoweit nicht egal, dass ich das Topic selbst wiederfinden muss.
Also, ich muss, wenn ich dann später da was reinpushen will, muss ich das ja irgendwie logisch mir selbst wieder zusammensetzen können.
Und es muss jedes Mal das Gleiche sein.
Also, ganz so random kann das nicht sein, weil sonst kann ich es, wie gesagt, später selbst nicht mehr erraten.
Also, ich muss ja, wenn ich irgendwann ein Update pushen will, muss ich mir anhand des Sensornamens zusammen reinkommen.
Ach, wie ist denn jetzt das Date-Topic?
Wie ist denn jetzt das Date-Topic gewesen?
Wir machen dann eh eine Sensor-Klasse dafür.
Mal schauen, mal schauen.
Ich will jetzt erstmal gucken, wie dieses Chasen-Zeug funktioniert.
Random UUID mit festem Seed.
Oh, das ist eine coole Idee.
Aber dann kann ich auch mal eine MAC nehmen.
Ich meine, Unica wird es nicht.
Ich probiere das gleich mal mit meiner MAC aus.
Aber das muss ich mal...
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich probiere das mal gleich mit meiner MAC aus.
Aber jetzt erstmal das Chasen-Zeug zusammen.
Also, Date-Topic haben wir.
Unic-ID jetzt an der Stelle.
Gut, das ist ja wieder was anderes.
Das ist jetzt für den jeweiligen Sensor.
Also, das ist jetzt...
Wobei, die Unic-ID, braucht man die überhaupt?
Moment.
Braucht man die überhaupt?
Man kann doch selbst irgendwas generieren.
Ist mir doch egal.
Ist mir doch egal, was der da macht.
Alter, ich treff den Glocken nicht.
Okay, doch, die braucht man anscheinend.
Die Unic-ID braucht man.
Die muss sein an der Stelle.
State-Topic nutzt man eigentlich nicht.
Aber das schreiben die sogar hier.
Guck mal.
Hier, State-Topic.
Die schreiben das sogar in ihrer offiziellen Dings da.
Dass man das benutzt.
So, Unic-ID.
Unic-ID.
Ja, das würde ich sagen.
Ist wieder sowas hier.
ID und Sensor-Name.
Sowas da.
So, und dann brauchen wir als nächstes...
Ah, jetzt.
Okay, jetzt wird es interessant.
Wie funktioniert es jetzt, dass ich da drin noch was eigenes anlege?
Muss ich jetzt sowas hier machen?
Gleich, New JSON Object.
Ah, guck doch mal da.
Ich muss sagen, das benutzt sich doch recht angenehm bis jetzt.
Wenn das denn funktioniert.
So, dann kommt jetzt hier Identifiers.
Ich paste mir das mal.
Identifiers.
Gleich.
Und jetzt brauche ich ein Array.
New JSON Array.
Hoffentlich geht das so.
Kann ich da jetzt gleich schon irgendwas reinschreiben?
Items.
Heizchamp.
Ja, ich könnte ID aber wirklich einfach Heizchamp machen.
Ich meine, mehrere Heizchamps gibt es ja nicht.
Das würde...
Also beispielsweise würde ich das jetzt auf irgendeinem ESP laufen lassen.
Auf irgendeinem Microcontroller.
Dann wäre das ziemlich doof.
Weil dann müsste ich ja den Source Code jedes Mal anpassen, wenn ich fünf Controller habe.
Aber so einen Heizchamp gibt es nur einmal.
Ich habe ja auch nur eine Heizung.
Aber vielleicht...
Ich gucke mal gleich, wie man das mit MAC-Adressen auslesen macht.
Das interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Da bin ich mir sehr unschlüssig, wie das funktioniert.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Habe ich, glaube ich, noch nie gemacht.
Okay, also.
New JSON Array.
Der Heizchamp.
Okay.
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch Name.
Und dann mal gucken, was da für ein JSON rauskommt.
Name.
Sag mal, warum autocomplietet der wie verrückt hier?
Sag mal, Pappe halten.
Name.
Das ist jetzt der Name für das Device.
Das ist auch Heizchamp.
Okay.
Und jetzt gehen wir das mal aus.
Chasen.
Mal gucken, ob die das toString überladen haben.
So, dass es standardmäßig funktioniert.
Wollen wir mal.
Ha, haben sie.
Tatsächlich.
Guck mal, da kommt jetzt was Sinnvolles bei raus.
Name, Heater, State, Topic, Unique.
Das sieht ziemlich gut aus.
Das sieht tatsächlich so aus, als könnte das funktionieren.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Also.
MQTT Client Publish.
JSON toString.
Und Topic.
Ah ja, gut.
Das stimmt übrigens überhaupt gar nicht, was ich da mache.
Das ist nicht das State Topic.
Bla, bla, bla.
Home Assistant.
Binary Sensor.
Es ist nicht Config.
Es ist.
Das ist totaler Schwachsinn, was ich hier reingeschrieben habe.
Das kann doch nicht funktionieren.
State.
Slash State.
Nicht Slash Config.
Aber pushen.
Pushen muss ich das Ganze auf das Topic hier.
Config.
So, mal schauen, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Das bin ich mal gespannt.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt hier auftaucht als Gerät.
Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen.
Okay, er hat aber schon mal gepusht.
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus, oder?
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz okay aus.
Was ist denn jetzt da falsch dran?
Topic ohne Variablen.
Hä?
Wie?
Was?
Wo?
Hä?
Nee, das sieht doch richtig aus.
Das ist doch okay.
Darf man da vielleicht kein Underscore haben oder so?
Du übergibst das Topic falsch.
Ich sehe es nicht.
Ist doch hier genau.
Ist doch eigentlich richtig.
Ja, State Topic.
Ach so.
Ah, lol.
Ja, Chat.
Der Chat hat es wieder gesehen.
Natürlich kann er so nicht funktionieren.
Da ist er.
Der Heizchamp.
Wunderbar.
Funktioniert.
Eater ist off.
Jetzt auch gewundert, wenn nicht.
Okay, sehr schön.
Sehr schön.
Also, das funktioniert schon mal, das Gerät so anzulegen.
So, und jetzt wollte ich mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie die Unique ID rausbekomme.
Ja.
treiben es jetzt mal hier nicht also aber hier mal den unteren kram weg network interface get
all network interfaces efe nennen wir es leben wir sind das eth ist jetzt einfach gibt es eine
id von der wiesmann anlage die man abfragen kann ja du hast recht dann nehmen wir einfach
das als inventory ja ja du hast recht viel besser inventory id für client id und sensor
prefix ja das ding hat eine inventory inventory nummer die können wir die können wir eigentlich
verwenden da mache ich es einfach die inventory nummer und davor schreibe ich dann heizchamp
heizchamp heißt das heizchamp heißt das heizchamp heißt das heizchamp heißt das heizchamp heißt das
heizchamp underscore inventory nummer underscore sensorname ja das ist eine gute idee chat das
machen wir das ist dann wahrscheinlich get inventory art oder sowas dieses glaube ich
wirklich get get inventory kann man machen ja das machen wir das ist eine gute idee also network
interfaces get ich will trotzdem mal gucken wie man die mac adresse rauskriegt interfaces get all
network interface was kann man sich in der mac physical heißt das bestimmt get physical address
und
ja moment aber ich muss erst mal sagen ja moment aber ich muss erst mal sagen
dass ich bei meinen interface kein loopback und sowas haben will
ja genau das sieht gut so scheiße was gibt's denn da alles die enden alter ja das muss man
überprüfen dass es kein als die enden ist ganz ganz wichtig und auch kein slip was
überprüfen dass es kein als die enden ist ganz ganz wichtig und auch kein slip was wem was es da alles gibt token ring alles klar natürlich wem was es da alles gibt token ring alles klar natürlich
very high speed dsl also was was wir in deutschland wahrscheinlich nie erleben
werden okay es reicht wenn das ethernet ist also hier where interface type type ethernet
geht es vielleicht ein bisschen lang was da ja einmal so übel da kann man sich jetzt die
mac adresse ausgeben lassen guck mal doch mal gehen wir mal meine mac adresse aus also geben
jetzt erstmal name aus oder so was fast das ach nee ja description name okay mal gucken was der
das ausgibt
alles klar ens 33 bridge bridge docker null okay doch keine doch okay wie kriege ich jetzt raus
was mein interface ist was ins internet geht da müsste ich jetzt wahrscheinlich gucken ob das
ob das ein gateway oder so gesetzt hat oder ob das routing eintrag hat für sich als sie boah
fuck gibt's da sowas sowas wie eth root oder oder gateway oder sowas okay was gibt was gibt's denn
da alles zum angucken id description name
speed primary gut ist receive only get physical address to string ja gut das gibt mir die mac
adresse aber das sagt mir nicht ob das mein primary interface ist was haben wir denn hier
get ip properties kann man dann da auslesen alles anycast address da kommen gateway addresses ja
schon mal gut
gateway addresses okay hier hat es microsoft auch ein bisschen übertrieben oder gateway ip address
information collection na klar nimm nimm einfach alle macs als sieht das werden das wäre eine
typische microsoft variante für windows aktivierung und dann ändert sich dann ändert sich der
netzwerkkarte und danach erscheint es als neues device und es funktioniert nicht mehr
gateway address
addresses
okay
ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz gucken was es da was es da ausgibt
Entretens
gateway address information übertreibt seiten aber microsoft
so was kommt da jetzt raus
ah guck mal es gibt nur eine mit einem gateway ja dann muss das mein primary sein ja nicht unbedingt aber für meine verhältnisse sollte es eigentlich reichen
Na, das ist zu Java-mäßig. Man könnte noch ein Interface davon machen, dass man es nicht zu sehr koppelt. Sowas wie iMutable Gateway IP Address Information Collection Factory Adapter. Das wäre noch besser. Und dann noch Interface hintendran, falls einer das i nicht gesehen hat. Das finde ich ist eine gute Idee, das sollten wir machen.
Also könnte ich doch jetzt eigentlich gucken, if eth getIPProperties Gateway Address found größer 0, dann ist das mein Primary Interface.
Das ist jetzt übrigens sowas, wo ich einen Kommentar sinnvoll finde, weil keiner, der das nachher liest und ich in ein, zwei Tagen auch nicht mehr weiß, warum ich das da hingeschrieben habe.
Das ist richtig, es mag nur ein Default Gateway geben können.
Aber es kann mehrere Gateways geben.
So, also, bla bla bla, das kommt weg.
Und jetzt da drinnen einfach eth getPhysicalAddress und dann mal schauen, ob das jetzt meine MAC-Adresse ausgibt.
Bäh!
Ha! Was ist das für eine Kack-Schreibweise?
Na gut, es ist ohne Doppelpunkte einfach nur.
Äh, expect, jo ne, ich nehme die, ich nehme die ID von meiner Heizung.
Kein Problem.
Das ist mir jetzt auch, während ich das gebastelt habe, ist, bin ich, bin ich dann raufgekommen.
Aber ich finde die Idee gut.
Ich wollte bei der Gelegenheit einfach mal gucken, wie meine MAC-Adressen.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich sage toString?
Kommt es dann schöner raus?
Ne.
Na, egal, das passt aber auch.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Ja.
Ey, jemand, der Tasmota verwendet, wird das ähnlich sehen.
Die Tasmota, die Standard-Tasmota-Einträge sehen so aus.
Der nimmt einfach die MAC-Adresse.
Na gut, das passt doch eigentlich.
So.
So, MAC.
Und jetzt, wie kriege ich denn den Hostname raus?
Jetzt, das wird advanced.
Man könnte ja Hostname nehmen, plus MAC.
Ist Schwachsinn, aber ich muss einfach nur, Hostname, wie kriege ich den Hostname raus?
Bestimmt irgendwas mit DNS.
DNS, get Hostname.
Also, DNS, get Hostname.
Da könnte ich dann sowas hier draus bauen, zum Beispiel.
Ähm, Hostname, Underscore, MAC.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute ID, oder?
Also, die, ich meine, die ist, also mehr einzigartig kannst du nicht sein.
Ein MAC reicht, der Hostname, den kann man sich eigentlich sparen an der Stelle.
Die ist nicht wirklich, das ist jetzt nicht wirklich notwendig, dass der Host da drin ist.
Aber eigentlich ist es eine ziemlich gute, gute ID.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Das muss ich mir mal,
das muss ich mir mal, das muss ich mir mal, das muss ich mir mal, das muss ich mir mal,
das muss ich mir mal speichern.
Das kann man bestimmt mal gebrauchen.
Aber für den Fall nehmen wir wahrscheinlich wirklich die ID von der Heizung.
Das erscheint mir sinnvoller.
WTF, MAC schon on?
Ja, seit zweieinhalb Stunden oder so.
Gut, jetzt haben wir das ausprobiert.
Komplett, komplett random, komplett useless, weil brauchen tun wir es nicht.
Aber es war mal gut rauszubekommen, wie es funktioniert, ja.
Okay, das JSON zusammenbauen funktioniert auch.
Das heißt, das heißt so die Basics.
Sachen haben wir rausbekommen, wie es funktioniert, wie.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir das Ganze mal ein bisschen ordentlich machen und mal überlegen, wie.
Wie kann man da jetzt irgendwie ordentliche Klassen draus bauen, dass das, dass da was sinnvolles bei rumkommt.
Ich mache mal kurz ein git, git, git init, git add, alles rein, git commit, A minus M, init, so.
Ich habe jetzt alles mögliche committed, was ich überhaupt nicht committen will.
Aber ich, ich wollte einfach mal, dass ich im Zweifelsfall nachgucken kann, was ich hier gebastelt habe.
Aber weg.
So.
Also.
Es ergibt doch alles so weit Sinn.
Ich überlege gerade, wie wir weitermachen.
Also wir haben jetzt rausbekommen, wie es funktioniert.
Ich kann den Kram jetzt anlegen.
Was machen wir dann jetzt als nächstes?
Ich muss den Schalter, genau, ich brauche einen Schalter.
Ich brauche einen Schalter.
Ich muss gucken, wie ich einen Schalter anlegen kann.
Jetzt.
Jetzt wird es advanced.
Okay, wie lege ich einen Schalter an?
Das hier legt ein Binary Sensor an, der an oder aus sein kann.
Das ist für die Heizung ganz sinnvoll.
Aber ich brauche einen Schalter.
Ich brauche keine, ich brauche keinen, also ich brauche nicht nur ein, ich zeige es mal.
Ich brauche nicht nur Heizung an oder aus, ich brauche einen Schalter, wo ich das an und aus schalte.
So, also, also, also.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt einmal hier.
Den, es ist doch immer gleich, wie serialized man damit eigentlich Klassen?
Jason, Object?
Gibt es da sowas wie Jason serialize oder sowas?
Ah ja, hier, Serializer.
Serialize.
Testen wir mal was, ob das funktioniert.
Serialize, A gleich 1, ja, beste, bester Test.
War A.
Alles klar, ähm, jetzt kann er mal aufhören, Auto, tatsächlich, das funktioniert so.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Du kannst es komplett durch den Switch ersetzen.
Mag sein, mal gucken, mal gucken, hier, Switch.
Switches.
Ne, guck mal, die brauchen mehr, die brauchen mehr.
Die brauchen ein Configuration Topic, die brauchen ein State Topic und die brauchen ein Command Topic.
Das heißt, ein Switch braucht noch mehr.
Willst du die Heizung nur manuell steuern können oder kommt da noch die Automatisierung?
Äh, ich hab schon alles, es geht mir jetzt hauptsächlich darum, also ich hab schon Thermostate, aber Thermostate wohlgemerkt an den Heizkörpern, das funktioniert alles auch schon.
Äh, ich will jetzt erstmal alle Infos von meiner Heizung in meiner Heimautomatisierung haben und ich will die Möglichkeit haben, die Heizung auf Warmwasser und Heizung oder nur auf Warmwasser umzuschalten.
Das geht noch nicht, da muss ich jedes Mal in den Keller.
Das sackt.
Auto vervollständigen ist fast wie cheaten.
Bis, bis es dich mal chebated.
Es gibt ein paar Auto-Vervollständigungen und Refactor-Hinweise in Rider, die ich bisschen fragwürdig finde.
Zum Beispiel möchte der, wenn du Essing Void schreibst, immer, dass du eine lokale Methode verwendest, anstatt Essing Void zu schreiben und sowas.
Das finde ich unsinnig, aber das meiste ist schon sinnvoll.
Nicht in Keller, Pepo fett, so sieht's aus.
Unnötigerweise in den Keller gehen, wenn ich das von hier oben schalten kann.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie wir da ein, ein Switch anlegen würden.
Also, wir brauchen ein, was brauchen wir denn für ein Switch?
Wir können das alles, sondern wir brauchen bloß noch ein Command-Topic.
Ein Command-Topic.
Und wir müssen alles durch Switch ersetzen.
Switch.
State-Topic.
Und wir brauchen noch ein Command-Topic, das Set heißt.
Ein Command-Topic.
Und dann muss man doch bestimmt noch irgendwie angeben, Device-Type-Switch.
Ne, wobei, das weiß der anhand dessen hier.
Okay.
War's das jetzt schon? Das wär jetzt easy.
Das ist ein Switch, oder?
Cool.
Okay, der heißt jetzt genauso wie der andere, das ist natürlich ziemlich bescheuert, aber...
Ähm, was ist ein Switch?
So, und jetzt kann ich nämlich, also, ich mein, der hat absolut keine Funktion, der Schalter jetzt, außer da zu sein.
Aber jetzt kann ich zum Beispiel auch hier hingehen und sag Edit.
So, jetzt machen wir mal neu.
Also, das ist by the way nicht mein echter Home Assistant, das ist eine Test-Installation jetzt für den, für den Stream, ja.
Äh, äh, äh, Title.
Oder, ups, was ist das?
Was machst du hier?
Neue, neuen Titel.
Icon.
Ähm.
Ähm, haben die, haben die ein schönes, haben die ein schönes Icon für Keller?
Material Design Icons.
Muss mal gucken, ob die, ob die was für, für Keller haben.
Diese Seite, die ist ja immer so lang, aber ich hab da schon längst reingeguckt.
Äh, irgendwie ist Floor oder sowas vielleicht.
Ah, guck mal.
0, 1, 2, 3, Floor A, Floor B.
Floor negative 1.
Jawoll.
Das brauchen wir.
Icon, Floor, ne, äh.
Ähm.
Und was ist das Prefix nochmal dafür?
MD?
MDI, genau, MDI.
Ich glaub mal, ich glaub man durfte auch HA machen mittlerweile, oder?
MDI.
So.
Safe.
Guck mal.
Jetzt haben wir einen Knopf für den Keller.
Bam.
So.
Add Card.
Button.
Ja, genau so.
Namen.
Name, Heizung.
Switch.
Show Name.
Show State.
Show Icon.
Äh, Tab Action.
Äh ja, Hold Action Toggle.
Das will, ich will nicht, dass es einfach, äh, dass es einfach beim, beim Antippen schaltet.
Wir können noch ne Confirm Action machen.
Weil das will ich wirklich nur nach.
So, guck mal, jetzt könnte ich die Heizung an- und ausschalten.
Zack.
Oh.
Ich glaub, ich hab nicht das Richtige genommen.
Äh, doch.
Hab ich.
Switch Heater.
Ja.
Also, das steht, das hat noch überhaupt null Funktion, ne?
Das ist einfach nur jetzt ein Knopf angelegt.
Zum Heizung schalten.
Also, man sieht ja, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Hier.
Guck.
Der, der, der schickt die ganze Zeit.
Der schickt die ganze Zeit jetzt hier.
Messages on.
Messages off.
Und es bestätigt keiner was.
Aber von der Idee her.
So soll, so soll's dann sein.
Wir müssen jetzt noch einbauen, dass da Confirmen.
Dass da Confirmen soll.
Wir sagen jetzt hier doch, äh, keine Aktionen.
Default Action.
Code Editor.
Äh, wie ging das nochmal?
Confirm.
Action.
True?
War das so?
Nee.
Ist das Mozilla Webthings?
Nein, das ist Home Assistant.
Action.
Home Assistant.
Da gab's ein extra.
Tab Action.
Confirm.
Confirmation.
Action Toggle.
Tab Action.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt weiß ich, wie ich's machen muss.
Also.
Tab Action.
Und dann.
True.
True, lol, weh.
Äh.
Action.
Alter, lass mich hier draufklicken.
Ech.
Ich hasse solche Seiten, Alter.
Ich hab immer mit, mitdenken müssen.
Okay, ich, ich schreib das Wort Action einfach von Hand.
So.
Default Toggle.
Also, Toggle, Toggle-Wilchmann, ja.
Toggle.
So, und jetzt sollte der mich fragen, ob ich schalten will.
Bam!
Are you sure?
Want to Toggle?
Toggle.
Jawoll.
Gut, weil für Heizung an- und ausschalten will ich auf jeden Fall irgendeine sinnvolle Rückfrage haben.
Sonst schalte ich noch fünfmal am Tag aus Versehen, weil ich da drauf klicke die Heizung an und aus.
Ist sus, die Seite.
Höchst, höchst sus.
Sssss...
So ganz schön sus.
HA樹
Oh.
Das ist auch nicht mehr angesagt, oder?
Ich glaub' das ist nicht mehr so, nicht mehr sooo dabei jetzt.
Das ist ja vollkommen VIP.
Quatsch?
Quatsch, mit SUS?
Das ist ja... Moment mal...
Das muss man, muss man mal sortieren.
Ne, Yeah.
Viewer high.
Das ist ja vollkommen RIP!
Na gut.
Ich kann's insofern verstehen, das macht, das kann man 1-2 Monate spielen, aber danach ist ja irgendwann auch mal die Luft raus.
Okay. So, meine Heizung.
Ein und aus. Wunderbar.
Natürlich funktioniert das Ganze noch nicht.
Und jetzt kommt ja
das Komplizierte
erstmal. Ich muss das irgendwie
verbinden miteinander.
Ja, sechs Wochen Twitch-Meta kommt
auch ungefähr hin, würde ich sagen.
Also, es war...
Also, man muss sagen, Fall Guys
into
Among Us-Meta war das ja auf Twitch.
Das ging so über.
Erstmal haben die Leute zwei Monate Fall Guys
gespielt. Und dann sind
die quasi so rübergeslidet
zu
Among Us. Was ist denn jetzt aktuelles
Twitch-Meta gerade?
Außer halbnackig auf der Banane
rumrutschen. Final Fantasy
14, stimmt. Was auch lustig ist,
ne? Das hab ich im Friseur schon gespielt.
Da war das noch richtig, äh...
Tja...
Nicht so angesagt. Und jetzt haben wir
keinen Bock mehr. Und jetzt ist es voll Twitch-Meta.
GTA RP.
Das stimmt, aber das ist... Wollte ich gerade sagen, das gibt's
auch schon länger. Ich muss ja persönlich
sagen, ich find GTA RP nicht wirklich
spannend. Also, ich kann
es verstehen, warum es die Leute gucken.
Das kann ich bei vielen Sachen
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen. Aber GTA RP
kann ich nachvollziehen. Aber mich persönlich
interessiert's nicht. Wenn ich GTA RP
haben will, dann geh ich einfach Frankfurt an den
Hauptbahnhof. Das ist Real Life GTA RP.
Aber gut, das ist natürlich kein
Argument. Das war jetzt eher ein Witz.
Weil, ich seh's ja selbst so.
Das ist natürlich bescheuert. Warum sollte man
in Real Life Straftaten begehen? Das macht mir
leicht kurzzeitig Spaß machen,
aber bestimmt nicht so viel und nicht so lange
wie in GTA Online.
Außerdem wirst du
in Frankfurt abgestochen, wenn du das probierst.
Genau. Dann lieber GTA RP.
Ne, also ich kann schon verstehen,
warum die Leute
GTA RP gucken, aber ich find's nicht
sonderlich spannend.
Mach Serverless Trigger Function bei Azure und buche
die Zeit bei Self-Learning
in Azure ab. Valorant ist
Dauermeter geworden.
Das stimmt.
Aber
bei weitem nicht so
krass, wie es am Anfang mit den Drops war.
Ich dachte,
Valorant, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
ich dachte nicht, dass es floppt.
So wirklich. Also ich dachte schon,
dass das
uns erhalten bleibt.
Ich mein, da ist Riot dahinter.
Aber ich dachte nicht,
dass das permanent so ein riesen Ding ist.
Ja.
Okay, probieren wir mal
weiter. Also, wir haben jetzt
einen Schalter.
Bin ich schon mal happy.
So, was jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen,
was jetzt der nächste Punkt ist,
ich muss mitbekommen,
wenn ich auf den Schalter klicke,
weil, ihr seht ja,
es passiert ja noch gar nichts.
Das bedeutet, ich muss jetzt nicht nur,
das müssen wir übrigens eh alles mal
in irgendwelche halbwegs
sinnvollen Klassen basteln.
Das ist ja hier untereinander geschrieben, wie
das könnte fast schon
Pearl sein, Alter.
Was der Binary Sensor muss,
es gibt keinen Binary,
Sensor mehr, den habe ich hier rausgekickt.
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Wozu brauche ich einen Binary Sensor,
wenn ich einen Switch habe?
Der ist einfach nur drinne,
weil ich den schon mal announced habe.
Aktuell habe ich den, ich habe den rausgeschmissen,
den Binary Sensor.
Moin, Deltrion.
So, also weiter.
Wir müssen jetzt drauf hören,
wenn einer im Web Interface auf den Knopf drückt.
Wie machen wir das denn am besten?
Ich muss das Topic subscriben.
Wie geht denn das?
Das bin ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen überfragt.
Wir machen mal sowas hier.
Public.
Void.
Sub.
String.
Topic.
Das wird so nicht funktionieren.
Ich bin mir aber gar nicht...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie das funktioniert hier.
Sub.
Subscribe.
Async.
Ich muss das Topic subscriben.
Ja, was?
Wie soll ich den Satz denn auf Deutsch sagen?
Ja?
Ich muss das Thema abonnieren.
Oder wie?
Klingt auch nicht besser.
Ich muss das Thema subscribieren.
Get Thema Subscrip...
Subscription.
Ich hab hier ein Emote, was super ist.
In Kombi mit allen PP-Emotes.
Zeig mal her.
Der Chainlock kennt sich was Emotes an.
Das ist tatsächlich gut.
Das adde ich gleich mal.
Das hab ich schon ein paar Mal gesehen.
Das ist wirklich ganz cool.
Kannst du das auch machen?
Das kannst du im Prinzip mit allen Emotes zusammen verwenden.
Äh, was?
Du hattest vorhin schön das Beispiel gelöscht.
Wirklich?
Stimmt.
Ich hab das vorhin gelöscht.
Tatsächlich.
Okay.
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal an, wie das funktioniert.
Also Sub.
Subscribe.
Wobei, wir gucken einfach bei denen auf der...
Auf der Shit-Hub-Seite.
Alles zu hier.
Alles weg.
Hier.
Manage Client.
Da waren die Examples.
Subscribe.
Async.
So.
Subscribe.
Async.
MQT-Topic-Filter-Bilder.
Also die QT-Typen, die diese Library programmiert haben, die stehen unglaublich auf irgendwelche Bilder.
Jetzt mal, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Warum?
Warum nicht so?
Ich mein, was ist der Vorteil von diesem Ding zu dem hier?
Moment, das geht auch?
Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Das ergibt tatsächlich Sinn.
Man kann das Topic...
Topic direkt angeben oder wenn man mehr Options braucht, dann nimmt man das.
Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Es macht Sinn.
Zu früh geflamed passt tatsächlich.
Okay.
Topic.
Es ist in Ordnung.
So.
Wie krieg ich denn jetzt überhaupt mit, ob das was...
Also ob das subscribed hat?
Also es muss ja irgendein Event oder irgendein Callback oder sowas geben.
Wie...
Ich mein, sub...
Subscribe.
Ist so schön und gut, aber...
Was kommt denn da als Antwort?
B?
X?
Ich muss ja irgendwie ein Callback oder sowas kriegen, wenn ich subscribed hab.
Hä?
Moment, da brauch ich irgendein Exempel dafür.
Messe...
Ah.
Okay.
Da, wo es interessant wird, hört natürlich die Hilfeseite auf.
Subscribe.
Async.
Braucht der irgendein Exempel für...
Tests.
MQTT-Klein-Subscription-Manager.
Was?
Was für Dinger?
Okay.
Subscribe.
Async-Topic.
Test.
Application-Message-Received-Händler.
Ach du große Scheiße.
Was ist das denn?
Application-Message-Received-Händler.
Ist das...
Ist das ein Event?
Ist das ein Callback?
Ist das ein Callback, den ich angeben muss, oder?
So.
Hä?
Monka?
Was?
Was für eine Ausgeburt des Bösen gibt das denn hier, wenn es fertig ist?
Okay, das darf ich auf jeden Fall hier schon mal nicht im Subscribe machen.
Das muss ich hier oben machen.
Ach du Kacke.
Okay, das machen wir jetzt mal hier.
Also, wir testen jetzt einfach.
Also, Subscribe.
Received-Händler.
Alles klar.
Arcs.
Was gibt es da?
Tag.
Application-Message.
Äh.
Klein...
Ja, Client-ID.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Application-Message.
Gibt es da sowas wie...
Topic oder...
Ah, hier.
Application-Message.
Wisst ihr, warum das so kompliziert ist?
Ich gehe davon aus, die, die die Library programmiert haben, haben das erstmal ursprünglich so klassisch eventbasiert, Callback-mäßig gebaut.
Und haben es mit der Zeit umgebaut in Async-Await-kompatibel.
Und da kommt dann halt so komische Dinger bei raus.
Ich hatte im Studium Leute, die so ihre Java-Methoden benannt haben.
Es gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich meine, du kannst dir wenigstens was darunter vorstellen.
Was ich persönlich jetzt natürlich ganz sinnvoll finden würde, wenn es nicht Application-Message-Received-Händler heißen würde,
sondern, äh, keine Ahnung, Subscription-Message-Received oder sowas.
Irgendwas, wo man sich was darunter vorstellen kann.
Weil, wer kommt denn auf sowas?
Application-Message.
So, Application-Message.
Topic.
Payload.
Convert Payload to String.
Wunderbar.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Ich muss mal kurz Hooster Man machen.
So, also.
MQTT-Client.
Subscribe.
Await.
Ich bin froh, dass ich das gerappt habe.
Das kann man wenigstens halbwegs verwenden.
Ähm, Topic.
Alles.
Ich will alles angezeigt bekommen.
So.
Von der Idee her, wenn ich jetzt was publische, sollte ich das eigentlich angezeigt bekommen.
Kann ich mal irgendwas publischen?
Irgendwas, was, irgendwas Kleines?
Was nix damit zu tun hat.
Hier.
Ja.
Leck.
Kleck 3D.
Funktioniert.
Easy.
Kleck 3D.
Das, das funktioniert.
Es ist aber ganz schön...
Soll ich sagen, umständlich gemacht.
Kleck 3D.
Also, wenn man weiß, wie es funktioniert, ist das nice.
Das Blöde dabei ist jetzt nur, dass das global ist.
Das heißt, wie dispatche ich jetzt das von hier in irgendeiner Art und Weise hier?
Ich will das ja hier subscriben und dann hier kriege ich ein Event.
Ich weiß, was ich mache, Leute.
Big Brain Library.
Reactive.
Rx.
Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's richtig, du Arzt.
System Reactive.
Jawohl.
Bam.
So, jetzt, jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich hab, ich hab die Idee.
Willste mal talk?
Was?
Hä?
Ach so!
Nee, nee, passt schon.
Ich hab ihn unverstanden.
Hä?
Willste mal talk?
Nee, nee, nee, brauch ich nicht.
Krieg ich schon, krieg ich schon hin.
Äh, falls du der Library maintainst.
Schön, dass du so ein Library gemacht hast, auch wenn ich ein bisschen am Flamen bin, gell?
Es ist, also, mach dir, mach dir da nix, äh, aus.
Also.
Wir machen das jetzt anders.
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab die, ich hab, ich hab die Idee.
Pass mal auf.
Massive.
Massive Big Brain Idee.
Ähm.
Wenn man subscribt, kriegt man ein Eye Observable.
Ein Eye Observable, äh, String.
Einfach nur Payload zurück.
So.
Alles klar.
Muss ich nur gucken, wie krieg ich das da rein.
Wofür du postest den Code auf GitHub?
Ja, das muss ich mal gucken.
Warum geht das net?
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Achso.
Äh, ja, ja.
Passt, passt schon.
Das fixt sich gleich, fixt sich gleich von alleine.
Ich muss ja was zurückgeben, sonst klappt das Ganze nicht.
So, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab die Idee, Leute.
Also.
Äh, wir subscriben jetzt.
Wir subscriben jetzt.
Und jetzt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt mache am besten.
Ich bin, ähm.
Die Idee find ich sinnvoll.
Also, wenn ich subscribe, krieg ich hier nen Stream von, äh, Messages zurück.
Das ist, das ist schon mal besser, besser als hier.
Ähm.
Ja, du hast recht, das muss ein Task sein.
Was aber Blödsinn.
Ich muss das noch nicht mal erstmal machen.
Ähm.
Okay.
Wie krieg ich die Messages von hier da rein?
Lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Man konnte doch so nen, so nen Standard, so so so so so so so so so so receiver, Sender
Ding.
Warte mal, ich hab ne Idee, wie man das machen soll hier.
Privat, ReadOnly.
Irgendwie Subject oder so hieß das.
String.
So.
Guck ob das funktioniert, ob das schön ist weiß ich net, aber funktionieren könnt
das ganze.
So, und jetzt?
subscribe topic und hier oben sagen wir jetzt next war das glaube ich next so args application
message payload convert ne string wie war das noch mal nicht payload payload convert payload
to string sowas was kann reactive extensions da besser als einfach ein channel also wenn man
könnte das wahrscheinlich auch mit einem channel machen reaktiv reaktiv in den channel wäre
wahrscheinlich noch viel sinnvoller ja du hast komplett recht ja ja eigentlich eigentlich ist
bescheuert hier ja das könnte man auch mit einem channel machen so subscribe das ist das ist eine
message q kurz gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert was ich mir da überlegt habe return subject so
und jetzt und jetzt mal gucken ob das geht
ja jetzt ist das muss ich nicht erwarten okay sap subscribe ist vielleicht ein bisschen dumm aber
von der idee her sollte es jetzt schon mal funktionieren message cw message so hups ran
geht geht okay das ist doch schon mal viel schöner als dieser komischer standardmäßige application
publish ich möchte
des sch pén exponenten ist ja ich bin verrückt ich würde vielleicht mal etwas subtilisieren
aber sonst was wenn mich stört es ein bisschen das sap subscribe ist aber ich war besser als die ursprüngliche
variante ist auf jeden fall sowie können wir das ja so ein bisschen verschöner利Sieren wingt man hat
Ich muss auf Topic filtern.
Stimmt, ich muss auf Topic filtern.
Dann bleibe ich doch bei einem Observable,
weil das kann ich filtern.
Dann ist so wahrscheinlich sogar noch besser.
Umreha?
Message? Message?
Ach nee, das ist jetzt ein String.
Ah!
Sack!
Okay, dann machen wir hier oben keinen String,
sondern Application Message draus.
Was?
MQTT Application Message.
Und dann konverten wir es nicht dahin,
sondern Application Message.
Und jetzt filtern wir und sagen
Where Message Topic
gleich Topic
Select Message
Payload
to String. Bam!
Huge!
Guckt mal hier.
Sack!
Jetzt machen wir hier mal hoch.
Ich darf das nicht.
Äh, hier.
While true.
Do.
Sleep 1.
Dann.
Funktioniert nicht.
Äh.
Ah, wegen dem Topic funktioniert das nicht.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Das mit dem Topic Raute wird wahrscheinlich so nicht funktionieren.
Ähm, wir machen mal ein richtiges.
Wir machen mal ein richtiges Topic.
Topic L.
Topic L ist es in dem Fall hier.
Okay.
Topic L.
Da ist es.
Kleck 3D.
Einmal in der Sekunde.
Funktioniert.
Huge.
Wir haben einen ordentlichen MQTT-Client,
den man bedienen kann.
Sehr gut.
Ohne, ohne, ohne
25.000
Bilder, Bilder in Bilder
geschachtelt.
Wie ist der Emoji-Support?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Rider Emojis kann.
Das probieren wir jetzt.
Gleich mal aus.
Allerwichtigst.
Ja, kann.
Gut.
Easy.
Dann ist gut.
Dann kann ich es weiterverwenden.
Okay.
Kleck 3D.
Wunderbar.
Okay.
Ich kann MQTT-Sachen
publishen
und ich kann MQTT-Sachen
subscriben.
Ach so.
Emojis in Topics.
Äh.
Das müsste wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren.
Ich denke, das funktioniert.
Das ist ganz normales Unicode-Zeug.
Ich denke, das geht.
Funktioniert.
Emoji-Tablet.
Ich wette mit dir,
Sachen, die in C++ programmiert wären,
da hätte das nicht funktioniert.
Weil
der Standard-String in C++
ist halt, was Unicode-Support angeht,
nicht existent.
Der hat schlicht und ergreifend
keinerlei Unicode
oder keinerlei Encoding-Support.
Man kann ja gar nicht sagen, Unicode,
das stimmt ja gar nicht so genau.
Unicode sind ja bloß die,
die vorgeben,
welche Zeichen aufgenommen werden,
an welchen Positionen
und das eigentliche Encoding ist ja dann das Wichtige.
Also UTF-8, 16 oder 32.
Windows ist UTF-16, ja.
Windows ist UTF-16
und .NET ist intern auch UTF-16,
wohingegen Rust komplett intern UTF-8 ist.
Das hat aber bei .NET historische Gründe,
soweit ich weiß.
Die haben damals schon,
bevor es das als Standard gab,
sich dafür entschieden,
dass in,
also quasi 2-Byte-Zeichen zu machen,
was eigentlich wirklich so das Schlechte
aus allen Welten ist, ja.
Also UTF-16 ist richtig hängen geblieben.
So nach dem Motto,
du hast immer 2-Byte,
aber du kannst trotzdem 4-Byte-Zeichen
nicht gescheit reinpacken.
Es ist Mist.
Also UTF-8 ist das einzig Sinnvolle, finde ich.
UTF-8 ist einmal ASCII-kompatibel
und das nächste ist,
du musst eh gucken,
ob es einen Continue-Flag quasi gibt
fürs nächste Zeichen.
Doch, UTF-8 reicht für alles,
klar.
UTF-8 ist, finde ich,
auch das einzig Sinnvolle.
Ja, man könnte noch sagen,
UTF-32 ist irgendwie sinnvoll,
weil du quasi immer feste Zeichen hast
und quasi alles, was es gibt aktuell noch,
ich glaube, mehr als 4-Byte gibt es nicht,
bekommst du irgendwie rein,
aber,
also ich finde,
UTF-8 ist das einzig Sinnige.
Wird ja auch quasi nahezu
für alles mittlerweile verwendet,
solange es nicht eine Webseite
aus Frontpage ist.
Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Ach, aktuelle Version von 2003.
Na, okay.
Es gibt Sachen,
denen weite ich nicht nach.
Also ich bin ja für UTF-69.
Wie auch immer das aussehen soll,
weil eigentlich muss es ja immer was
hoch 2, also Zweierpotenz sein.
Aber da kann man mal...
Ist 420 eine Zweierpotenz?
Eher nicht, oder?
Frontpage kann bestimmt schon Angular und Vue.
Naja, Frontpage kann ja im Prinzip
Syntax-Highlighting für HTML
und ja, das ist ja auch so.
Ja, das ist ja auch so.
Du kannst in Frontpage
bestimmt Vue basteln,
aber das wird Syntax-Highlighting
komplett versagen, weil das
nicht mit neuem JavaScript-Zeug
zurechtkommt.
Yep, okay.
Also.
Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Was haben wir denn jetzt hingekriegt?
Also wir haben einen MQTT-Client, der funktioniert.
Damit bin ich schon mal wirklich
sehr
zufrieden. Das gefällt mir.
Wobei,
weil ich diese Syntax hier nicht so wirklich
schön finde, ne?
Subscribe, subscribe. Das ist schon ein bisschen
ein bisschen Painschampig, aber
Gibt es bei 20.000 Twitch-Follower
Fußleak?
Habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht, aber
es wird wahrscheinlich weder bei 20.000
noch bei 30.000 noch bei 100.000
Fußleak geben, zumal ich meinen Fuß
sogar schon öfters geleakt
habe.
Ich habe Fotos mit der Katz, da ist mein Fuß
drauf. Also wenn du meine Füße sehen willst,
Chain-Lore.
Ich meine, ich könnte, also
wenn du subscriben willst, kann ich auch eine Onlyfans
machen, ja?
Ne, aber wenn du
sehen willst, kannst du auf Twitter gucken.
Da gibt's
das bestimmt irgendwo, ja?
Nackter Fuß. Ne, ich glaube, nackten Fuß
habe ich noch nicht geleakt.
Wie sind eigentlich die Onlyfans-Pläne, was
Porn angeht? Ich habe gehört, die haben jetzt
zurückgerudert. Die haben ja erst gesagt,
sie wollen keine
Sachen mehr promoten und anbieten und
dann haben die gesagt, fuck, dann ist ja
nichts mehr von uns übrig.
Und das haben sie es sein gelassen. Jetzt
geht das ganz normal weiter.
Okay, also wie können wir das hier? Können
wir das hier vielleicht noch ein bisschen
verschönern? Ich meine, Sub. Sub.
Subscribe. Ich habe eine Idee. Wir können
es weniger hässlich machen.
Wir sagen hier einfach Refactor. Rename.
Wir nennen es einfach Filter. Und dann
Subscribe.
Ich meine, ich könnte jetzt auch, ich könnte
auch ich könnte es auch mqtt client filter message bilder nennen dann sind wir ein bisschen näher
dran am original aber so ist das doch wirklich ganz nice ich finde das wirklich recht schick
du sagst mqtt client filter dann sagst du topic also in dem fall wir müssen jetzt natürlich auch
mal erstmal gucken ob das funktioniert was ich hier gebaut habe topic command topic set message
so und von der idee her sollte da jetzt kommen on off wenn ich den schalter drücke im webinterface
probieren wir das mal zack zack zack zack zack zack funktioniert nicht lul ausrufezeichen wieder
vergessen noch mal zack zack zack zack zack zack bam on off on off also ja nice man kriegt das mit
gut jetzt bekomme ich mit wenn einer den schalter im webinterface gedrückt hat jetzt ist die nächste
frage
wie sage ich dem denn jetzt also ihr seht ja wenn ich den schalter drücke und dann keine
bestätigung kommt dann geht dann wieder aus ich muss jetzt eine message schicken wahrscheinlich
an state ja genau ich muss an state topic jetzt zurückschicken ist aktiviert okay das
probieren wir jetzt mal aus also await wenn das async machen await mqtt client filter
kleinen abschheit垇 wollen wir jetzt abschäfen und zwar wollen wir jetzt auf das state das müssen
wir unbedingt kapsel in ein paar ecken je nachdem wenn das zusammenbaut aber nicht so so ist wirklich
abartig hat er jetzt für schmerzen als geht's okay message muss dann sein in dem fall na ja
wir schalten ist jetzt an wir machen jetzt einmal hardcode und da überein schauen wir mal also da
sollte sich jetzt einschalten und dann auch noch mal wahlen auf jeden fall wenn wir dann auf 4D machen
schalten und dann angeschaltet bleiben und und und und da bleibt eingeschaltet
nice hier kann man jetzt auch nachgucken was
dafür maust hier aus triestens receive messages on
sehr schön gut wir können die message im prinzip hier reinschreiben dann schaltet
er an und aus of of on das funktioniert guckt und jetzt sollte der knopf auch
hier funktionieren der button es tut es schaltet zwar noch nicht die
heizung aber es funktioniert im web interface schon mal an aus wunderbar
das hat er vorher noch nicht funktioniert wollen habe ich drauf
geklickt es ist einfach gar nichts passiert
und sagt ja sehr schön sehr gut das gefällt mir ja gut ich muss sagen das
finde ich jetzt schon mal ganz gut das finde ich schon mal nice
das finde ich schon mal nice so jetzt ist natürlich die nächste sache
wir müssen das irgendwie mit der heizung integrieren das wird aber cool dass das
jetzt so alt dass das schon mal funktioniert das ist dass das home ist
es in mqtt zeug klappt da bin ich schon mal bin ich aber beruhigt dass das an
sich geht
was gibt es eigentlich ein video oder ist ein super dein werbe habe habe ich
schon gemacht
ach so ja doch aber habe ich das stimmt das habe ich nicht das stimmt das
stimmt das habe ich noch nicht gemacht ja ich hab ich glaube mehrere videos
dazu gemacht was ich jetzt aktuell mache und so drumherum aber werde gang das
eigentlich eine gute idee da schreibe ich immer auf ja das könnte ich machen
das ist eine gute idee ich weiß ich habe sie im stream ja schon öfters erzählt
ich weiß ich habe sie im stream ja schon öfters erzählt
aber ich das ist eine gute idee das habe ich glaube ich noch nie in einem
video gepackt noch nie ein video gepackt also das einzige video was ich
dazu gemacht habe wo ich mich ausführlich darüber ausgelassen habe ist
das mache ich auf der arbeit von 2019 also hier bei mir auf youtube und ich
habe mit dem neuen mannen video darüber gemacht allgemein zur
fachinformatiker ausbildung wer das noch nicht gesehen hat kann ich das auch
gucken da haben wir uns 20 minuten über dinge ausgelassen ist ein echt gutes video geworden
digital ocean code punkt kombi was ist das für eine komische scams seite das ist doch
irgendeine scams seite das kann mir doch keiner erzählen warum sind irgendwelche antworten die
lux haut das muss ich mir meine linux vm angucken das mache ich nicht unter windows auf private
ich mache das mal kleiner nicht nicht dass da jetzt gleich in der porn seite kommt oder so
immerzu hallo das ist nicht das ist nicht das was ich haben will porn at verlinkung ja das ist was
so das ist eine werbeseite die mein video gerippt hat okay was auch immer man weiß nicht so aber
richtig so strike der
skv ja wir gucken mal wo die sitzen moment moment wie hieß das wie ist die seite jetzt
noch mal bis ich habe jetzt schon zugemacht und digital ocean code punkt kommt da fuck
ja wo ist wo ist wo ist wo ist oh nein die sind beim gleichen domain registrar wie ich da weißt
du schon mal wer bei dem ist das ist das sind irgendwelche ich
bin ja auch noch bei denen weil die keinerlei anschriften kontrollieren weil ich kann bock
an ausweis und sachen hin zu schicken weil die keinerlei anschriften links und billig sind
ok man bekommt sich raus also mit welchem programm läuft eine linux feier mit welches
dienst du das ist vor allem bei workstation und die habe ich einfach im zweiten desktop von windows
deswegen kann ich auch so schnell zwischen windows und und linux hin und herschalten
Und das ist, genau wie der Bot das schreibt, das ist ein Manjaro Linux mit i3-WM.
Excellent Mod.
Ja.
Big Brain Mod.
Arch, by the way, Leute.
So, also, machen wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also, wir können jetzt Sachen in Home Assistant anlegen und wir können Sachen schalten.
Und wir bekommen mit, wenn sie einer schaltet.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Das sind auch schon mal so die Basics für alles, was wir sonst viel brauchen.
Jetzt muss ich mir mal überlegen, wie könnte man das denn gescheit irgendwie in ein paar Klassen packen.
Weil, ich meine, ich will jetzt ja wohl kaum für jeden Eintrag so ein Ding hier machen.
Das erste, was ich mal ausprobieren will, ist das hier.
Also, dieses, diesen Eintrag hier für Device, das ist das, was man hier sieht bei Device Info.
Oh.
Also, sprich, das hier.
Also, hallo?
Das da.
Device Name, Hersteller, Modell und sonst was.
Das ist ja bei allen Sensoren, die ich hier anlege, gleich.
Deswegen ist die Frage, könnten wir das nicht, könnten wir da nicht irgendwie eine eigene Klasse draus machen, die das dann ordentlich serialized.
Also, quasi sowas wie hier Public, Class, ähm, tja.
Wie nennt sich denn sowas hier?
Device Info.
Ich, ich werd da mal, warte mal, ich werd da mal was, was, was, noch was ordentliches reinschreiben, was das dann da auftaucht.
Also, was gab's denn da alles, was gab's denn da alles zur Auswahl?
Ähm, mit Curl hat man das aus, ne.
Irgendwas mit Garagentor.
Hat man doch da hier, also was gab's denn da alles?
Identifier Name, Model gibt's noch.
Model, Manufacturer.
Ha, MQTT.
MQTT.
Mal gucken, was ist das?
Was es da alles, was es da alles zur Auswahl gibt.
Model, also Identifiers haben wir, Manufacturer, Model Name, Software Version, okay, also, Manufacturer, Manufacturer, der, der, der Twitch Chat, was sonst?
Ohne Twitch Chat hätt das natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Cute, Cute Chat, beste.
Edgar hat immer noch besser als Piehole, ähm, ich seh schon ein paar Versionen her, wie kommt die da jetzt überhaupt drauf?
Ich hab mir das vor, fragt mich nicht, vor einem Jahr oder so mal angeguckt.
Achso, das war jetzt, weil das jemand im Chat, das Bot-Kommando.
Oder vor einem halben Jahr, ja.
Also, ich muss sagen, rein von der Usability her, hat mir das deutlich besser gefallen als Piehole.
Ja.
Wie das jetzt aktuell ist, weiß ich wirklich nicht.
Also, Manufacturer, der Chat.
Äh, Model.
Oh, ey, was, warum?
Warum macht man sowas, dass man das nicht anklicken kann?
Das ist doch einfach nur hängen geblieben.
Warum, warum baut man sowas?
Okay, Model, äh, ist, tja, äh, keine Ahnung.
Raspberry Pi 4, ich schreib jetzt einfach mal irgendwas rein, so, und Software Version hatten wir noch, Software Version ist natürlich eindeutig.
0.0.0.0.0.1, so.
Sehr schön.
Äh, run.
So, mal gucken, ob der das jetzt da einträgt, im Web-Interface.
Guck mal, hat funktioniert.
Hier.
Zack, jawoll.
Nice.
Also, Device-Info nennt man das Ganze anscheinend.
Da machen wir jetzt nämlich mal eine eigene Klasse für diese Device-Info-Geschichte, weil, egal welchen Sensor ich anlege, ob ich jetzt einen Binary-Sensor anlege, einen Schalter anlege, einen Sensor anlege, äh, irgendwas, alles, was ich hier an Geräten anlege für die Heizung, ist ja, bekommt immer diese Infos.
Alles.
Also, probieren wir mal, ob wir da eine eigene Klasse für machen können.
Public-Class, das nennen wir einfach dann, äh, keine Ahnung, HA-Device-Info oder so.
HA-Device-Info.
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Ah, das geht nicht in der, in so einer, das muss man unten drunter machen, das ist natürlich doof.
Das ist natürlich doof, ja.
Wäre jetzt praktischer gewesen, man könnte es hier oben anlegen.
Also, was, was haben wir denn hier einmal?
Identifiers Name Manufacturer.
Also, fangen wir an.
Manufacturer.
Ist, hallo, String Manufacturer.
Next.
String Name.
Next String, was war sonst noch?
Model.
String, äh, Version.
So, äh, ach, Identifier haben wir noch.
Identifier, eigentlich reicht doch, guckt mal, das ist zwar ein, das ist zwar ein Array von Identifier,
aber.
mal ganz im Ernst, eigentlich reicht doch einer,
oder? Ich werde da nie im Leben
mehr als ein Identifier angeben.
Das
String Identifier.
So, und können wir das jetzt?
Das ist jetzt die Frage,
wenn ich jetzt dieses Objekt hier oben
einmalig anlege, nennen wir es mal
irgendwie ein Root Device oder sowas.
New, ha,
Device Info. Wenn ich
das jetzt einmalig anlege,
Manufacturer, Cute Chat,
den kann man nochmal schreiben, ne?
Model,
oh, wie paste mir.
Hustchamp, Alter.
Geht los hier.
Ich hab das schon seit ein paar Tagen.
Ich mach nachher mal Corona-Test.
Ich bin aber doppelt
geimpft, seit ein paar Wochen schon.
Ich kann eigentlich kein Corona haben.
Ich weiß, jetzt kommen die Leute wieder
und sagen, doch, doch, Max, trotz Impfung kannst du
auch Corona kriegen. Ich weiß, aber die
Chancen sind deutlich, sind ziemlich gering
und ich wäre doch nicht gerade in der einen,
in dem,
einen Tag, letzte Woche
oder so, wo ich in Frankfurt war,
wenn ich mir noch nicht gerade Corona eingefangen habe,
das dann auch noch trotz Impfung
ausbricht. Das glaube ich nicht.
Außerdem würde es mir da wahrscheinlich deutlich schlechter
gehen, wenn ich Corona hätte.
Hatte jemand von euch Corona?
Oder seid ihr alle
verschont geblieben?
Manufacturer, Cute Chat.
Das ist Arbeitsallergie.
Muss doch heute gar nicht
arbeiten.
Heizchamp.
Und als nächstes haben wir noch Version.
Version. Moment, Identifier, Cute Chat,
ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Identifier muss Heizchamp
sein. Äh, Version war hier
das da. Gut.
So, und jetzt ist natürlich die große
Preisfrage, kann man das jetzt
anstatt dem Kram
da reinschreiben?
Nee.
Du könntest auch an und an und
nee, kann ich
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das könnte ich machen, wenn ich
Newtonsoft.json.com
net nehmen würde. Aber das hier ist
die neue .net Jason Implementierung.
Keine Ahnung, ob der das kann.
Nee, toString funktioniert
nicht. ToString
wäre einfach nur
Das ist
Paintschamp, ja. Ich wollte es mal ausprobieren.
Ich dachte, hey, steht .net 6 im Titel?
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen .net 6 machen.
Ich hatte Newtonsoft.net
schon installiert. Und da habe ich mir
gedacht, Moment, ich habe doch letztens was drüber gelesen,
dass man das jetzt mit .net 6 viel besser machen kann.
Ähm, als noch mit .net 5.
Bei .net 5 war das ja auch alles
read-only und sowas.
Ein implizierten Cast-of-Jason-Object.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Kann man, okay, ähm,
Jason, aber ich
Serializer ist eigentlich das
Falsche, weil da kriege ich einen String raus.
Ich will ja keinen String rauskriegen.
Ich will ja,
dass der
das hier für mich serialized.
Das wird doch so nicht funktionieren.
Das klappt nicht, Leute, das klappt nicht.
Ich gucke mal, was der da draus macht,
aber das wird nicht funktionieren.
New Jason Object.
Das ist eine gute Idee, das kann ich, das probiere ich danach mal aus.
Aber guckt mal hier,
das wird nicht, wir machen mal kurz
Watch, Watch Run.
Ne, ne, ne, guck, das, äh,
das klappt nicht.
Das ist eine gute Idee. New Jason,
ne, nicht J-Object, Jason Object.
Man kann da reinschieben,
ne, man kann da bloß
Jason, äh,
E-Value Pairs, sonst wie.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ja, mit Newtonsoft Jason würde das funktionieren.
Dann würde das allein schon funktionieren,
weil du es als Dynamic
könntest du das sogar machen dort.
Tja.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht steht, vielleicht steht das in der
Hilfeseite drinne. Oder was heißt
Hilfeseite in diesem komischen
.NET 6 Jason?
Du meinst, ob das was hat
zum,
was?
Hä?
Glaube ich nicht.
Pass-Value.
Das ist System Text Jason, ja.
Das ist System Text Jason, aber
die .NET 6 Variante,
die angeblich, sagt Microsoft,
habe ich letztens in einem Web, äh, in einem Talk gehört,
die genauso komfortabel
zu verwenden sein soll wie, äh, Newtonsoft
.NET. Erst serialisieren,
dann parsen?
Tja.
Wie könnte das jetzt funktionieren? Ich hab,
wirklich, gerade, echt, keine Ahnung.
Ey, warte mal, wir machen das mal anders.
Wir, wir, wir speichern das mal und jetzt,
vielleicht können wir das irgendwie so, warte mal,
Dynamic, lull.
Geht das?
Ja, das wird nicht funktionieren, das kann ja nicht sein.
Nee.
Hahaha.
Ähm.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ey, du könnt's ja mal ausprobieren.
Ähm, okay. Wie könnte das, wie könnte das funktionieren?
Das war, das war, vielleicht, versteht er irgendwas. Äh,
GIFs oder was, was haben sie hier gemacht?
Tatsächlich, n Gif.
N Gif und dann nicht, nicht mal animiert.
Ja, das weiß ich, dass das funktioniert aber das wollen wir ja nicht.
Wir wollen ja
das miteinander verbinden.
Was ...
Übrigens .NET 6 hat nen Bug.
Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon gehabt.
Der endlos reloaded bei nem Watch.
Deswegen hab ich keinen Watch genommen.
Easy.
Ist aber bald, ist Release.
Ich glaube, es dauert noch einen Monat oder so.
Okay, zwei Monate.
Zwei Monate dauert es noch.
Mal gespannt, ob sie bis dahin alles gefixt haben, was es so zu fixen gibt.
So, geht das irgendwie, was ich mir hier vorstelle?
Sonst installiere ich doch NewtonSoftJSON.net und dann ist gut.
Mach einen Builder, der das JSON-Objekt returnt.
Ja, meinetwegen, aber wie würde ich das überhaupt zusammenbauen?
Mir fällt ja noch nicht mal ein, wie ich das jetzt von Hand zusammenbauen würde.
Heute ist iOS 15 Release.
Mal kurz weiter gucken.
JSON-Objekt to JSON-String?
Was ist denn das?
Was ist da der Unterschied?
To JSON-String?
Was ist der Unterschied?
Ah, es wird nicht...
Pretty Printed.
Okay.
Normales to String formatiert es schön.
To JSON-String gibt es einfach aus.
Ohne irgendwelche hübschen Formatierungsgeschehen.
Das ist eigentlich auch ganz sinnvoll.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Aber erklärt ihr mal noch nicht, wie das funktioniert?
Würde denn sowas funktionieren?
Moment.
Würde denn...
Würde denn sowas funktionieren?
Tag w gleich new?
Nee, das funktioniert auch nicht.
Nee, das funktioniert.
Also das funktioniert...
Ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht.
Aber wie würde ich denn jetzt hier was hinzufügen?
Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Write to this object is...
Ich würde halt für das Hauptobjekt eine Klasse bauen und einfach serialisieren.
Ja, aber ich muss es doch irgendwie zusammenbauen.
Und das Serialisieren aus dem Hauptobjekt wird ja nicht funktionieren,
weil meine...
Mein Sensor steckt ja da nicht irgendwie drinnen.
Es muss doch möglich sein, das zusammenzufügen,
das zusammenzubauen irgendwie.
Add.
Okay, man kann hier nicht irgendwas hinzufügen.
Aber wenn schon...
Warum gibt es nicht add...
Add value.
Ah.
Chasen value vielleicht?
Okay, das würde vielleicht sogar noch Sinn ergeben.
Device.
Device gleich new chasen value.
Nein, nein, anonymes Objekt geht auch nicht.
Habe ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt mal versuchen nachzuvollziehen, wie...
Wie hat sich das Microsoft gedacht?
Wie, es gibt doch chasen value.
Eben...
Hä?
Bin ich jetzt total verwirrt?
Eben...
Eben gab es das doch nicht?
Oder wahrscheinlich einfach hier drinnen nicht?
Chasen value?
Create?
So was hier vielleicht in der Richtung?
Ich müsste...
Es muss doch...
Es muss doch sowas geben wie insert raw value oder sowas.
Sowas suche ich.
Raw value.
Wie sowas hier machen könnte?
Probier mal das mal aus.
Na, das wird nicht gehen, oder?
Echt?
Okay, er ist schon mal der Meinung, dass es kompiliert.
Und wir wissen ja alle von Herr Endpunkt, wenn es kompiliert, dann geht es.
Aber...
Hey!
Nice!
Das funktioniert.
Man muss einfach nur wissen, wie.
Sehr schön.
Guckt, und jetzt kann ich mehrere Sensoren anlegen.
Und ich kann immer wieder das gleiche verwenden.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Jetzt haben wir auch was gelernt.
Ähm...
Wobei das jetzt ja nur die halbe Miete war.
Also ich weiß jetzt, wie ich meine Sensoren anlege.
So, mal in mich gehen.
Wie könnten wir das denn jetzt...
Ich will es jetzt nicht gar so übertreiben.
Ich will jetzt nicht 50.000 Unterklassen oder so machen, aber...
Man könnte ja für so einen Sensor eine eigene Klasse machen.
Dass man zum Beispiel sagt, ja...
Aber müsste Identifiers nicht ein JSON-Array sein?
Das ist korrekt.
Das wird so nicht funktionieren.
Also müsste Identifier eigentlich sowas sein.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Gibt es da sowas wie Serialize S?
Lass ich dem sagen.
Lass das aus.
JSON-Ignore?
Könnte ich dem sagen, JSON-Ignore?
Ah ja.
Ach Quatsch.
Ich bin doch hier komplett falsch.
Das muss hier oben...
Das ist das Blöde, wenn das alles in einer Datei drin ist.
Ähm...
Dann siehst du überhaupt nicht, wo du steckst.
Wo du bist.
Hier müssen wir hin.
JSON-Ignore.
Also...
Doch, doch, es gab einen Array.
Da müsste ich das ja beim Anlegen auch so angeben.
Also es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten.
Entweder ich mache das so und lege noch eine zweite Sache an, die private ist, falls er das mit serialisiert.
Weiß ich nicht.
Oder ich mache es einfach zu einem Array.
Wir machen das mal in zwei Schritten.
Also machen wir mal String-Array draus.
Ähm...
Identifier.
Da muss ich ja wieder hochscrollen.
New.
Genau.
Zack.
Plopp.
Das muss jetzt...
Das wird auf jeden Fall funktionieren, so.
Äh...
Achso.
Muss vielleicht noch angeben, was er ausgeben soll.
So.
Ja, das funktioniert auf jeden Fall so.
Aber was wir jetzt bei der Gelegenheit gerade nochmal ausprobieren können, was ist, wenn ich sage...
JSON-Ignore.
Property.
Ups.
Achso, was macht denn ein...
String.
Identifier.
Ja, Identifiers.
Geht das sowas?
Und was wir jetzt sagen...
Ne, das ist wirklich Painstamp.
Ich wollte sagen, wir können das ignoren.
Und wir können aber sagen, wenn das hier...
Wenn das hier einer Get macht, dann wollen wir in Wirklichkeit haben...
Ähm...
New.
Dings.
Identifier.
Gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Hey.
Das gefällt mir aber sogar besser.
Ja.
Das gefällt mir besser.
Serialisiert er das auch, wenn man es private macht?
Ja, das serialisiert das auch.
Ne.
Macht er nicht.
Okay, das finde ich jetzt aber beides irgendwie ein bisschen hässlich, oder?
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, die einfachste Variante ist tatsächlich...
Wir lassen das einfach weg.
Get set.
So.
Dann ist wenigstens klar, wie es funktioniert.
Identifier.
Das New.
Oh.
Dann ist wenigstens klar, was es ist.
Ja, da muss es...
Wir müssen es jetzt ja nicht übertreiben.
Gut.
Wunderbar.
So können wir das lassen.
Ähm...
Jetzt muss ich mir eher noch überlegen, wie kriege ich das denn jetzt so gescheit zusammengebaut?
Ich meine, schön ist es...
Schön ist es nicht.
Könnte ich nicht die Klasse machen für, sagen wir mal, irgendwie...
Ähm...
MQTT...
Oder HA...
Device Discovery oder sowas.
Also könnte man...
Könnte man nicht sowas hier machen.
Sagen wir mal Public.
Oder machen wir mal Interface.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das funktioniert, was ich jetzt bastle.
Aber ich schreibe mal einfach irgendwas.
Interface HA.
Was weiß ich.
Discovery.
Alles klar.
Das muss...
Das lassen wir jetzt so.
Discovery.
So, lassen wir irgendwie da Interface machen.
Und dann machen wir irgendwie Classes.
Dafür sowas wie zum Beispiel...
Public...
Class...
Oh, jetzt mag er nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist es irgendwie broken.
Dann sowas wie...
MQTT Switch.
Switch.
Und dann sowas wie...
Sensor.
Irgendwie sowas.
Und...
Beide...
Beide.
So.
Irgendwie so.
Von der Hierarchie her.
Und damit das dann funktioniert,
braucht jeder Sensor...
Vielleicht mach ich da gar kein Interface,
sondern irgendeine Base Class dafür.
Weil was soll ich in das Interface groß reinschreiben, ne?
Also was braucht denn so ein Sensor, damit das funktioniert?
Der braucht den...
Der braucht den MQTT Client.
Sonst geht's nicht.
Sonst kann er nicht...
Nicht...
Schreiben und nicht...
Messages pushen.
Und er braucht ein...
Wie hab ich das genannt?
HA Device Info.
Wir machen jetzt mal die Noob-Variante.
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach nur den Switch.
Ohne irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten.
Weg damit.
Und gucken wir einfach mal, ob das funktioniert.
So.
Das könnte man doch da drin relativ gut kapseln.
Wird...
Wir lagern das alles mal in eine eigene Datei aus,
weil mittlerweile, jetzt wird es mir
zu viel, jetzt blicke ich hier nicht mehr durch.
So, da muss ich nichts dran machen.
Das kommt auch in eine eigene Datei.
Nein!
Chebated hat es mich.
Es hat mich zum Löschen
Chebated.
Okay, jetzt aber.
Move new file.
Warum geht denn das? Eben hat das doch noch funktioniert.
Refactor.
Move to another file.
Jawohl.
Bam.
Da sind wir.
Info.
Okay, also.
Das heißt, anstatt, dass ich diesen ganzen
Krempel hier mache,
machen wir das hier mal weg.
Aber das machen wir das hier auch mal weg.
So.
Machen wir mal zack.
Kommentieren wir das mal aus.
So, anstatt, dass ich den ganzen Mist hier mache,
könnte ich doch einfach sagen,
ähm,
so oben können wir eigentlich auch mal weg machen.
So.
Da ich den ganzen Mist hier, können wir einfach
New
ähm,
HMQTT Switch
Switch
und der kriegt
den Client übergeben
und, äh,
gut,
okay, das root device zu nennen ist natürlich schon doof.
Äh, nennen wir es einfach
device info.
Genau.
Moin, was ist das für ein Editor?
Das ist Rider. Genau.
Oh, Jet Brains.
Da sind die gleichen Leute,
die auch IntelliJ machen.
Für unsere,
für die Java-Fans unter uns.
Hat jemand von euch
die Ehre
auf der Arbeit, Java zu programmieren?
Oh.
Wir sind da, wie lange sind wir schon?
Alter, wir sind vier Stunden fast schon zu Gange.
Ernsthaft?
War ne blöde Frage.
Ist jemand auch schon fast vier Stunden,
ist,
ist jemand schon vier Stunden hier?
Das Stripes ist, glaube ich, bis,
bis am an, fast von Anfang an da.
Meine Güte.
Lull.
Fast.
Wahnsinn.
Ja, nice, dass ihr so lange am Start seid.
Es ist ja schon ein bisschen trocken vielleicht, ja,
geb ich zu.
Aber was soll ich machen?
Der Heizchamp muss funktionieren.
Nix Java, nur Jamelprogrammier-
Oh ja, Jamelprogrammierung ist meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache.
Also ich würde sagen,
also,
Jamel,
aber dicht gefolgt von HTML-Programmieren
ist beides ungefähr auf einer, auf einer Ebene.
Allerdings, ich persönlich sehe das Ganze ja nicht so eng.
Also wenn jemand zu mir sagt,
was weiß ich,
wenn ich mir vorstelle,
wir haben einen neuen Azubi
und ich frage ihn so nach dem Motto,
und wie sieht es in dem Bereich aus,
wie sieht es in dem Bereich aus
und wir kommen irgendwie auf Programmiersprachen oder so
und er sagt mir, er kann HTML programmieren,
ich werde nicht den Klugscheißer machen,
von wegen HTML ist keine Programmiersprache,
bla bla bla.
Ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung,
wenn einer sagt, er kann HTML programmieren.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man da immer so einen Akt machen soll.
HTML ist mittlerweile so komplex,
ja, und hat, und hat so viele
Dinger drin.
Es mag formell keine Programmiersprache sein,
aber
das ist XML auch nicht.
Oder JSON oder Jamel oder was auch immer,
das ist auch keine Programmiersprache, aber trotzdem,
ähm,
gerade Jamel kannst du so viele Sachen damit konfigurieren
und,
je nachdem,
guckt euch mal sowas wie Ansible an zum Beispiel.
Ansible ist Jamel,
aber,
du kannst in Ansible,
dadurch, wie das Jamel interpretiert wird,
das kann man dann schon Programmieren nennen,
weil da in Ansible hast du Logik drin,
hast du Schleifen drin,
hast du Variablen drin.
Hm.
Wenn du ein Kind hast, dann nennst du es JSON,
da bist du nicht der Einzige.
Ich glaube, das haben noch mehr probiert.
Wenn ich ein Kind hätte,
dann würde ich es Bashen alter Bashen nennen.
Oder Codra.
Nein, ernsthaft.
Also wenn ich ein Kind hätte, würde ich,
boah, habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Wie würde ich mein Kind nennen?
Ich bevorzuge es eigentlich gar kein Kind zu nennen.
XX der Kind XX.
Genau.
XX der Kind XX,
das ist es.
So wird es heißen.
Nee, ähm,
da habe ich mir noch keine,
keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich habe es auch nicht vor,
wenn sich es verweilen lässt.
Naja.
Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Also erstens,
gibt es aus mehreren,
aus mehreren Gründen kann das,
funktioniert das ja aktuell nicht.
Mir fehlt aktuell die Voraussetzung dazu,
da man braucht ja irgendjemanden,
mit dem man Kinder kriegen kann.
Zusammen.
Und das nächste ist,
ich habe absolut keinen Bock auf Kinder.
Kinder gehen mir so unglaublich auf die Nerven,
ich will gar keine.
Also es kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Kinders,
ja.
Ich bin heute wieder im Kindergarten vorbeigelaufen,
auf dem Rückweg vom Rewe
und das Geschrei ging mir schon so auf den Keks.
Boah,
nee,
hör mal auf.
Nee,
das ist nichts für mich.
Was halten,
was halten Sie von Veracrypt?
Das wird es aber äußerst förmlich heute.
Äh,
ich habe selbst Veracrypt.
Ich finde Veracrypt sehr sinnvoll.
Ich finde Veracrypt,
ich finde Veracrypt,
ich finde Veracrypt.
Wenn man Microsoft traut kann,
natürlich auch BitLocker verwenden,
aber Veracrypt,
ist somit das sinnvollste,
was man offenbar machen kann mit seiner Windows Installation.
Es geht gar nicht so sehr darum,
dass,
keine Ahnung,
das FBI vor der Tür steht.
Darüber mache ich mir auch keine Gedanken.
Ich benutze Veracrypt und Festplattenverschlüsselung aus einem ganz einfachen
Bequemlichkeitsgrund.
Also das erste ist,
ist es kaum langsamer als nicht verschlüsselte Festplatten.
Also das ist ein fast nicht feststellbarer Unterschied.
Und das nächste ist, du kannst Festplatten einfach auf den Müll schmeißen
und du musst dir keine Gedanken machen ums Löschen
oder dass irgendjemand wieder irgendwann irgendwas herstellen kann.
Und noch anders, wenn die Festplatte kaputt ist
und du kannst sie nicht ordnungsgemäß löschen,
was machst du da mit deiner Festplatte?
Willst du die wirklich mit sensiblen Sachen vielleicht wegschmeißen,
so dass sie doch eventuell noch einer restoren kann?
Das Problem kann man komplett mit Festplattenvollverschlüsselung lösen.
Du hast einfach die Causa.
Du kannst es natürlich auch wie Google machen
und da irgendwelche Bolzen durchbohren, wie ich schon gesehen habe.
Aber das Einfachste ist tatsächlich die Festplatte zu verschlüsseln.
Wenn die Festplatte verschlüsselt ist, dann hast du keine Probleme.
Du kannst die quasi nehmen, Fenster aufmachen und rauspfeffern
und du musst dir keine Gedanken machen,
keine Gedanken mehr drüber machen.
Das ist der reine, der praktische Faulheitsgrund bei mir,
warum ich Festplattenvollverschlüsselung auf den Geräten habe.
Ich will einfach die Festplatte oder die SSD nehmen können,
rausrobben, auf den Müll schmeißen können
und ich muss mir keine Gedanken machen, dass irgendjemand drankommt.
Ja, SSD ist ja das Nächste.
SSD zerstören ist gar nicht mal so einfach.
Es sei denn, du schmilzt sie ein.
Übrigens, das ist auch schon was, wo ich mir Gedanken drüber gemacht habe.
Ich habe ja jede Menge ESP32 und ESP2866 hier irgendwo rumfliegen.
Nicht alle in Benutzung, aber geflasht mit WiFi-Credentials,
WLAN-Passwort und so.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, die kannst du eigentlich nicht wegschmeißen,
weil dort im Flash von der Firmware oder eben im normalen Flash
stehen meine WLAN-Zugangsdaten.
Und das ist ja auch schon was, was ich mir gedacht habe.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, die kannst du eigentlich nicht wegschmeißen,
weil dort im Flash von der Firmware oder eben im normalen Flash stehen meine WLAN-Zugangsdaten.
Eigentlich kann ich die Dinger gar nicht wegschmeißen.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, was mache ich denn damit jetzt?
Und ich habe mir überlegt, das Beste wäre eigentlich irgendwie einschmelzen,
aber schmelz mal so einen PCB mit Metall ein.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, das einzuschmelzen.
Einfach öfters die WLAN-Credentials rotieren.
Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon gedacht,
aber das ist mit jeder Menge China-Kamera-Geräten,
wo du dich dann wirklich auf jedem Gerät einloggen musst
und alles, was du da machst, das ist nicht so einfach.
Also, das ist nicht so einfach.
Alles ändern, gar nicht so einfach.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt aktuell bestimmt schon ein Jahr
meine WLAN-Credentials nicht mehr geändert,
aber das ist halt auch ein richtig ewig langes Passwort.
Was ich auch ein bisschen doof finde,
dass es mit dem normalen WLAN-Authentifizierung
keine Möglichkeit gibt,
Authentifizierung nur für ein Gerät zu machen.
Dass man quasi sagt, hey, oder mehrere User.
Ich weiß, dass das geht, das geht mit Enterprise-Authentifizierung,
aber tja, macht es mal mit normalen.
Endgeräten.
Ja, also, dass man zum Beispiel sagen könnte,
hey, für diese SSID gibt es fünf verschiedene User,
weil dann könnte man auch Wegwerf-User machen,
die man wieder löscht.
Das ist alles nicht so schön.
Nicht so big brain.
Können die China-Geräte nicht gerade, das meine ich ja.
Ja, aber ein ESP32 oder ein ESP2866
habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nie explizit geguckt,
aber ich glaube, dass das nicht so schön ist.
Aber ich würde mich sehr wundern,
wenn die Enterprise-Authentifizierung könnten fürs WLAN.
Gucken wir doch mal.
ESP32, WLAN, oder wir können auch Radios suchen,
aber wir müssen eigentlich Enterprise.
Ja, können die bestimmt nicht.
Hä?
Das hat doch damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Was schreiben die denn da für komische Dinger wieder?
Das hat doch überhaupt nichts mit, mit, ähm, was, Zertifikat?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, kann man,
weiß jemand, ob man Enterprise-Authentifizierung
und normale Authentifizierung
parallel laufen lassen kann für die gleiche SSID?
Das geht ja, glaube ich, auch nicht, ne?
Also anscheinend geht das.
Vielleicht geht das doch.
Aber es ist halt dann auch schon ein bisschen aufwendig.
So, wir machen jetzt noch, wir machen jetzt hier noch ein paar Sachen.
Ähm.
Aber Leute, also ich bin, ich bin jetzt noch,
ich bin noch eine Stunde ungefähr on.
Dann gehe ich was essen.
Du könntest ja alternativ mehrere SSIDs
mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern machen. Ja, das könnte ich machen.
Das mache ich ja auch so. Das mache ich ja auch so.
Das ändert aber nichts daran,
dass es nicht einfach ist, äh,
Passwörter zu rotieren.
Weil wenn man, wenn man einen SS,
wenn man eine SSID haben könnte
und die Geräte alle Enterprise, äh,
Authentifizierung unterstützen,
dann könnte man nämlich einfach für jedes Endgerät
eine extra, einen extra User anlegen
und wenn man das Endgerät wegwirft,
löscht man einfach den User und fertig.
Das wäre die einfachste Variante.
Einfach mit der Bohrmaschine den 32 aufbauen?
Ja, das geht. Natürlich, du kannst das Ding schon,
ähm,
physisch zerstören.
Klar. Aber es ist gar nicht mal so einfach.
Wirklich.
Also, so nachhaltig,
also, nee, nachhaltig ist das Fall.
Es ist gar nicht so einfach, sagen wir,
nennen wir hier so ein Wemos T1 Mini.
Zerstör das mal so,
dass nichts mehr auslesbar ist.
Klar, du kannst da schon durchbohren.
Und es wird wahrscheinlich
in 99% der Fällen
auch der Fall sein, dass es dann
hoffnungslos kaputt ist.
Aber,
sagen wir mal so,
es ist keine wirklich gute Variante.
Also,
einfacher wäre es,
du hättest irgendeinen Häcksler,
dann würdest du das reinschmeißen
und der häckselt dir das.
Aber du wirst nichts für den Privatbereich finden,
der dir so Metalldinger
kleinschreddern kann.
Oder du schmilzt das ein,
was du bei den Dämpfen, die das absondert,
bestimmt auch nicht haben willst.
Mac Whitelisting, nee, das bringt nichts.
Das geht, aber das ist nicht
Weisheitsletzter Schluss.
Also,
ja, man müsste
eigentlich müsste man sich
lokal irgendeinen
wie einer im Chat geschrieben hat,
irgendein Unternehmen suchen, was das shreddert
und dann nimmt man eine Tüte mit
ich habe bestimmt mittlerweile 20, 30
so kleine Technik Sachen mit WLAN Credentials
zu entsorgen, schmeißt sie da in die Häckslermaschine
Ja.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Das wäre natürlich das Beste.
So, wie gesagt, eine Stunde bin ich noch da.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal
eine Sache.
Kannst du das bitte nochmal vertonen?
Nee, reicht jetzt.
Der
Brofessor. Ja, schicke ich dir
alle, gar kein Ding. Ich weiß, der Chat
also dem Chat vertraue ich mit Abstand
am meisten, mein
WLAN Passwort vertraulich zu behandeln.
Okay, Leute, ich muss jetzt nochmal
in mich gehen. Wir machen jetzt nochmal
die letzte Stunde oder die letzten fünf
wir machen jetzt nochmal was sinnvolles.
Ich will das jetzt mal ein bisschen ordentlicher
hier zusammenfassen. Also
Switch New
HA MQTT Switch. Wir übergeben
ein MQTT Client und ein
Device Info. Das ist doch schon mal
fein. Sehr, sehr
nice. Ist das nice.
So.
Ähm.
Also, lasst uns mal in mich gehen. Wie können wir das denn
jetzt halbwegs sinnvoll
encapsulaten?
Ähm.
Ich würde
sagen.
Wir legen uns erst mal ein paar Variablen
an für die unterschiedlichen Topics, die wir brauchen.
Also. Private Read
Only String. Was brauchen wir?
Wir brauchen ein State Topic.
So. Wir brauchen ein State
Topic.
Wir brauchen ein
Config Topic.
Also für MQTT. Und wir brauchen
ein
Command Topic.
Das haben wir hier alles schon eingegeben für
Command Topic,
State Topic, sonst was.
So. Wie bauen wir uns das
denn zusammen? Also das
Das kommt. Ne. Wir
fangen an mit dem Config Topic.
So. Das Config Topic
setzt sich. Ich glaube ich muss das mal kurz copy-pasten.
Sonst komme ich da im Leben nicht drauf.
Ähm. Also wie setzt sich das
denn jetzt zusammen?
Das ist immer
Okay.
Home Assistant Switch
ID. Ja was ist denn
Warte mal. Was ist denn nochmal die ID?
Äh.
Wait a minute. Ne. Die ID ist
Die ID ist Identifier.
Device Info
Identifiers ist das.
Die kann ich ja dafür nehmen.
Ja. Das ist ja
Identifiers ist in dem Fall halt Heizchamp.
Okay.
Ist ja relativ
Unique.
Ich glaube was anderes mit Heizchamp
habe ich nicht. Wobei ich das immer noch nicht
schön finde muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich fände das viel cooler
wenn das noch die
wenn das noch die MAC Adresse da dran
hängt. Wenn das nämlich die MAC Adresse noch mit dabei
hängt. Da kann ich mir wirklich sicher
sein das ist immer das gleiche
vom gleichen Gerät aus.
Und
wenn ich mehrere Heizchamps habe
was schwachsinnig ist, was ich nicht habe, aber was ich
haben könnte
dann
Hätte das
Ja gut. Aber ich könnte es ja auch auf der
gleichen Kiste mehrere laufen.
Irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
Irgendwann ist es auch mal gut. Ich muss es nicht übertreiben.
Ich meine hier mache ich das ja schon so.
DNS Name, Hausname und MAC.
Das ist eigentlich
ganz sinnvoll.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Du wolltest die ID von der
Heizung nehmen. Stimmt. Das ist richtig.
Die ID von der Heizung wollte ich nehmen.
Die müssen wir jetzt erstmal abfragen.
Moment. Wie frage ich
die ID von der Heizung ab?
Äh
ID von der Heizung
abfragen. Wo haben wir es denn hier?
Heizchamp.
Wo ist der Heizchamp?
Habe ich das gelöscht?
Äh Client
Endpoint
IP Endpoint. Stimmt.
Das habe ich gelöscht.
Habe ich das gelöscht?
Ja. Ich bin bescheuert. Ich habe es
weggeschmissen. Also.
Das war die IP von dem Raspberry im Keller.
1.129
Port
Wie Client
Äh
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
View Commands musste man glaube ich sagen.
Und dann
Get
Get Inventory war es glaube ich.
Get Inventory
Ich kann ja mal schreiben.
Das ist auch noch ziemlich kacke gemacht hier mit der Heizungskommunikation.
Oh
What?
View Commands
Send Commands
Ah. Ich muss warten.
Das ist alles
kacke gebaut. Das muss ich mir noch
was ordentliches überlegen.
Ja. Das ist die ID
von meiner Heizung.
004EE9C9
Null. Warum auch immer
Null da hinten dran stehen muss. Aber.
Null.
Das ist mir egal ob da Null hinten dran steht
oder nicht. Das ist hier die
ID von der Heizung.
Aber wenn man halt mal ganz klar sagen muss.
Die ID von der Heizung ist eigentlich
auch nicht wirklich so sinnvoll.
Als wenn ich es mir
nämlich richtig überlege. Weil die ID von der
Heizung ist ja immer die gleiche. Aber
ich könnte ja theoretisch mehrere
Geräte haben die das abfragen.
Was schwachsinnig ist. Ja ich weiß also.
Ich habe ein Gerät was das abfragt
und gut ist. Ich muss es nicht übertreiben. Aber nur rein
von der Logik her. Ich könnte natürlich
mehrere Geräte haben. Deswegen
ist die Kombination mit
Hostname und MAC Adresse
eigentlich besser.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach. Scheiß drauf.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach mit
der MAC Adresse vom Host.
Das können wir nämlich da hier reinpacken.
Guck mal. Das können wir in die andere Klasse packen.
Wir haben doch hier ein
HA
HA Device Info.
Da können wir das einfach hier reinpacken.
Diese Sache mit MAC
Adresse auslesen.
High Availability
Sekunde. Ich muss runter scrollen.
High Availability Heizungsabfragen
mit Hotspare. Komplett normales Szenario.
Natürlich. Was heißt
Was heißt hier mit
Hotspare? Mit Cold
Standby Heizung.
Hotswap.
Max wie bedienst du eigentlich deinen Home Assistant?
Hast du irgendeine Fernbedienung dazu oder
ein zweckentfremdes Tablet?
Mehrere Sachen. Also ich habe
einmal natürlich auf meinem
Smartphone
das das drauf zum Steuern auf
meinem iPad. Dann hat
auf dem anderen iPad auch noch und
ich habe im Flur
oben und unten
für
den Flur oben und unten habe ich jeweils
an der Wand noch einen
Android Fire also
Amazon Fire
HD.
10 sind das die
großen?
Fire HD 10?
Heng. Genau.
Die gibt es nämlich immer relativ günstig.
Warum?
Hä? Warum ist das so teuer auf einmal?
Na gut wahrscheinlich weil keine
Aktion ist. Die gibt es immer relativ
günstig wenn man
irgendwelche Aktionen
abwartet. Also bei Amazon
es gibt ja mittlerweile so viel Zeugs
bei Amazon.
Black Friday Cyber Monday
Black Friday Week
September
Specials
Prime Day
Die haben ja gefühlt jeden Monat
irgendwas. Und das einzige was sich
eigentlich immer lohnt wenn man das
braucht ist Amazon Geräte bei Amazon
zu kaufen.
Wenn die solche Aktionen haben. Weil die sind immer
relativ günstig. Und da habe ich mir damals
auch zwei Fire HD 10 gekauft. Jetzt
kosten die 150. Ich glaube ich habe damals
79 oder so dafür bezahlt.
Also irgendwie die Hälfte.
Oder 89 oder sowas.
Ohne Werbung ist ja lächerlich.
Das ist viel zu teuer. Das würde ich
lieber flashen oder deploaten
und dann ist es weg.
Ja so zwei habe ich an der Wand hängen.
Wie ich die befestigt habe? Gar nicht.
Ich habe glücklicherweise genau
im richtigen Abstand das Telefon
vor einer Tür Gegensprecher nahe gehängt.
Diese Box. Und ich kann die genau
so halb hinter
die Box und an die Wand schieben
dass es sich quasi da rein klemmt.
Ich habe keine Halterung
gebraucht. Wo ich wirklich
sehr froh drüber bin. Weil ich keinen Bock habe in die Wand
irgendwelche Löcher zu bohren.
Strom. Strom bohr.
Das könnte ich dir auf dem Bild zeigen.
Wenn ich das Bild finden würde.
Der Chat weiß das bestimmt.
Nämlich Image
Uhr. Ne.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr. Ich habe da von
Bilder und die habe ich auch mal im Stream gezeigt.
Ich habe durch den
durch das Leerrohr
wo. Moment.
Ich kann es dir zeigen. Aha.
Bitte. Ich habe doch letztens
irgendwas gepostet.
Ich weiß aber bloß nicht ob das
offen war oder nicht.
Die Abdeckung davon.
Übrigens. Auch so ein
Ding wo es sich extrem gelohnt hat Custom Firmware
zu flashen. Standardmäßig hält
das Ding ein halbes Jahr. Dann ist die Batterie leer.
Und jetzt bin ich irgendwie bei 88%
nach
warte mal nicht. Ein Dreivierteljahr oder so.
Hier. Ne. Man sieht es nicht.
By the way. Das sieht nicht mehr aus.
Das war Testaufbau.
Hups. Oh ne.
Come on.
Aha.
Sieht nicht mehr so aus. Also ich habe
durch den
durch das Leerrohr. Also hier
oben ist normalerweise das Tablet.
Hier ist das Tablet dazwischen geklemmt.
Das passt genau dahin.
Und ich habe durch das Leerrohr wo die ganzen
Sachen hier gehen. Habe ich
ähm
im Keller
12 Volt Netzteil angeschlossen.
Da angeklemmt an zwei freie
Adern. Und in jedem Telefonkasten
habe ich einen 12 Volt
auf 5 Volt
Spannungswandler drinne.
Wo ich dann per USB die Tablets
versorge die hier dran hängen.
Das hier ist übrigens das USB Kabel fürs Tablet.
Was hier runter hängt.
Glaube ich. Zumindest.
Oder auch nicht. Müsste eigentlich das
Kabel vom Tablet sein.
Also hier. Genau.
Hier kommt ein USB Kabel raus.
Und das kann ich dann hier ins Tablet stecken.
Was für Wand hast du denn da?
China
Chinesen AliExpress von Amazon.
So rote.
Also im Prinzip
ein bisschen sowas wie der
hier. Nur das es anders aussieht.
Ja sowas
hier in der Richtung.
Warte mal. Ich guck mal kurz auf dem Handy.
Dann kann ich dir sagen wie das Ding hieß.
Hm.
Amazon
Orders
Na was suche ich denn da jetzt?
USB
Wenn ich nach USB suche
finde ich 50 Seiten.
FTDI Adapter
Ok nach USB hätte ich nicht suchen dürfen.
Meine Güte habe ich schon viel gekauft
mit USB drinne.
Das hört ja gar nicht mal auf.
Hier. Da ist es doch. Ich habe es gefunden.
Äh
Dual
USB 12 Volt
Ey
Sag mal.
Ich sehe es doch gerade bei mir auf dem Handy.
Das Ding.
Habe ich.
Amazon hat es nicht gefunden weil es nicht verfügbar ist.
So ein Teil kriegst du bestimmt
tausendfach hier noch. Guck da.
Alle möglichen. Das ist China Chinesen
Zeug. Kostet 3,50 Euro oder so.
Guck hier.
Wie viel sind denn das?
Fünfer Pack für 10 Euro.
Dann zahlst du 2 Euro das Stück.
Ja. Das ist. Das ist.
Du musst aber halt gucken. Guck mal.
Die sind sogar mittlerweile 6 bis
40 Volt zu 5 Volt.
Wobei ich mich frage ob 40
Das wird ein bisschen warm.
Oder?
40 Volt auf 5
Also 12 auf 5
ist kein Problem. Funktioniert ohne Dinger.
Ja. Die habe ich hier oben drinne.
Aus dem Leerrohr in der Wand
kommt dann halt das Kabel.
12 Volt DC drauf.
Da oben in der Ecke habe ich mit Klebeband
den Kram reingepappt.
Reingemacht.
Und hier vorne hast du halt ein USB Kabel raus.
Es müssen übrigens.
Es müssen übrigens tatsächlich.
Also man könnte sich jetzt natürlich fragen.
Hey. Warum habe ich im Keller
ein 12 Volt Netzteil angeschlossen und nicht
ein 5 Volt Netzteil wie man für USB braucht?
Ist doch ein Schaltregler das höhere
Ich bin immer wieder
überrascht wie viele
Elektrikstelzleute wir hier im Chat haben.
Da habe ich überhaupt keine Ahnung von.
Also.
Big Brain Chat wieder.
Ja. Und.
Das muss ich machen.
Weil 5 Volt ist im ersten
Stock drauf ist die Spannung zu gering.
Dann laden die Tablets nicht.
Also wenn ich ein 5 Volt Netzteil
im Keller anschließe.
Und von dort dann ins Erdgeschoss ans Tablet
und durch das Leerrohr in den ersten
Stock gehe. Dann ist die.
Dann habe ich oben. Ich habe es mal gemessen.
Ich habe oben dann noch irgendwie 4 Volt
oder irgendwie sowas übrig gehabt.
Oder 3,8 oder sowas.
Und das hat sich.
Das hat halt gesackt. Da hat das Tablet
nicht mehr geladen.
Also zumindest das Tab. Doch das stimmt nicht.
Das Tablet hat geladen. Aber das Tablet hat quasi
schneller verbraucht als geladen.
Obwohl es im Standby war. Also kannst du vergessen.
Und das Problem hast du bei 12 Volt
halt nicht. Umso höher die Spannung
umso weniger hast du da Probleme.
Ja. Und jetzt.
Vielleicht kommen jetzt von den 12
oben noch 11,5 oder so an.
Und dann geht das in den.
Spannungswandler rein.
Und dann direkt per USB ans Tablet.
Ist echt ganz praktisch.
Hast du keinerlei Kabelsalat.
Also das ist ja nicht normal hier.
Das hier war mein Testaufbau für
Tür Gegensprechanlage
zu Fritzbox.
Also zu DECT. Zu Telefon.
Der übrigens jetzt im Keller steht und wunderbar funktioniert.
Der Chat
hat mich übrigens auf die Idee gebracht.
Muss ich nochmal sagen.
Es gibt einen Mikrocontroller den du mit .NET
programmieren kannst. Ja.
Ich glaub irgendwie so heißt der Kram.
Ist aber
relativ teuer.
Ähm.
Ist für Low Power Szenarien
jetzt auch nicht so sinnvoll.
Und dazu kommt das sie die ganzen
Libraries fehlen.
Ich hab die gebackt auf Kickstarter
damals.
Ich hab so ein Ding hier.
Ich hab die auf Kickstarter gebackt.
Weil ich das eine richtig coole Idee fand.
Und es ist eigentlich auch eine coole Idee.
Also auch Performance mäßig ist das
wunderbar das Teil.
Das hat einen ESP32 drauf plus
einen STM32.
Also du hast da viele viele Dinger drauf.
Also an sich eine richtig coole Idee.
Das hauptsächliche Problem ist, dass dir komplett
alle Libraries fehlen.
Willst du irgendeinen LCD Display
ansteuern? Ja Pech gehabt.
Klar du kannst das natürlich
von Hand machen.
Weil das ist dann wahrscheinlich irgendein I2C Display
oder so. Aber das willst du ja nicht.
Du willst dir irgendeine Display Library das du sagen kannst.
Oder so ein String in die linke obere Ecke oder so.
Dir fehlen schlicht und ergreifend
es gibt kein .NET
Microcontroller Ökosystem.
Es gibt noch das
Microframework oder sowas.
Das hast du aber ähnliche Probleme.
Es ist leider
ist .NET keine gute
Microcontroller Plattform.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es anders wäre.
Ihr wisst ich bin halt großer .NET Fanboy.
Aber da kommste
um C leider
bzw.
C++
was ja so ziemlich das menschenverachteste ist
was es irgendwie gibt
kommste leider nicht drum herum.
Es gibt noch andere Varianten.
Es gibt beispielsweise
Micropython gibt es noch
oder Lua
aber das hat ähnliche Probleme.
Micropython dürfte noch
das mitverbreitetste sein
neben C und C++
Es gab auch mal Versuche für Rust
Im Prinzip ist das alles Müll.
Du kommst nicht dran vorbei.
Du musst C bzw. C++
wenn es Arduino ist verwenden.
Keine Chance.
Haben sie Core RT
nicht sogar eingestellt?
Tiny Go
Ja Tiny Go wäre cool wenn das funktioniert.
Aber Tiny Go geht glaube ich
auf dem ESP32 nicht.
Oder doch?
Aber Tiny Go hat auch so die Probleme.
Dir fehlen halt die ganzen Libraries.
Das ist halt, das suckt halt einfach nur.
Ja aber es gibt keine gescheite
Build Environment für Rust auf dem ESP32
Also das letzte was ich gesehen habe war
von 2 Jahren aktualisiert.
Deswegen, also das gesamte
Ökosystem, gerade wenn man
die Arduino kompatiblen Sachen
verwenden will, also du kannst eigentlich
nur C++ verwenden.
Das ist halt doof
weil ich wie gesagt, für mich ist C++
somit das painst champigste
was es gibt.
Ich weiß nicht was mit dem C++ Gremium
los ist, aber viel schlimmer als C++
geht es eigentlich kaum noch.
Ich würde gerne Fortran oder Kobold programmieren
bevor ich C++ programmier.
Aber es ist leider
das einzig benutzbare.
So jetzt schauen wir mal kurz weiter.
Also Host Info.
Übrigens Leute, ich merke leider
dass ich auch langsam nicht mehr richtig nachdenken kann.
Schon so lang on.
Aber das machen wir jetzt noch kurz. Fertig.
Übrigens, wem der Stream gefällt
und auch PrimeSub übrig hat,
ich würde mich freuen.
Ich habe mir auch vorgenommen, ich bin in nächster Zeit
wieder öfters da.
In den letzten drei Wochen.
Ich habe mich durch so viele Dinger ablenken lassen.
Ihr habt ja auch gesehen, ich habe auf Youtube kaum was gemacht.
Ich war auch auf Twitter nicht so aktiv.
Und auch auf Twitch.
Ich habe alles mögliche zusammen.
Ich muss daheim viel basteln.
Ich habe hier ein neues RPG am Start, wo ich relativ viel spiele.
Alle möglichen Sachen.
Aber ich habe mir vorgenommen, ich streame jetzt wieder mehr.
Vonifreak, Dankeschön für den PrimeSub.
Exzellent, Exzellent.
Einfach Kreiselkreis streamen.
Ich spiele kein MMORPG.
Ein ganz feiner Singleplayer RPG.
Was ziemlich gut geworden ist.
Was ziemlich gut geworden ist,
muss ich sagen.
Kingmaker war schon nice.
Das hier meine ich.
Steam mochte Kingmaker nicht,
weil die Leute zu dumm waren, den ersten Dungeon zu packen.
Kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen.
Das Spiel hat ein paar Bugs,
aber es ist wirklich
ein enorm riesig umfangreiches RPG.
Du kannst locker 100 plus Stunden
den Singleplayer spielen,
ohne dass du alles gemacht hast.
Kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen.
Was mit Steam immer los ist.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Kann man nur empfehlen.
Die Steam Bewertungen sind teilweise
wieder ein bisschen
painstampig.
Das hat schon ein paar Bugs,
aber es ist bei weitem nicht so schlimm,
was Steam daraus macht.
Die Leute auf Steam
sind wieder komplett unfähig.
Da reden die Leute sich dann drüber aufregend,
dass sie irgendwelche Gegner nicht down bekommen.
Die müssen dann einfach mal in die Infos
von den Gegnern reingucken, wo dann drinnen steht,
du musst Elektro-Damage machen,
dass sie sterben.
Steam ist wieder komplett unfähig.
Aber am schlimmsten fand ich
die Bewertung bei dem letzten
Pathfinder-Game von Steam,
wo die Leute wirklich negative Bewertungen gegeben haben,
nach irgendwie 2 Stunden Spielen,
weil sie den ersten Dungeon nicht geschafft haben.
Ihr müsst wissen,
in dem ersten Dungeon gibt es komplett
Lost.
In dem ersten Dungeon gab es quasi so
Insektenschwärme als Gegner.
Das war ein Übungs-Dungeon.
Und das Game sagt dir,
bevor du in den Dungeon gehst,
nimm dir Brandbomben mit
oder
Feuerzauber.
AE-Feuerzauber.
Das sagt das Spiel.
Und die Leute auf Steam
can't beat first Dungeon,
balance suck,
overtuned shit.
Erstmal voll abgeraged wieder.
Einfach zu dumm gewesen.
Und das ist bei solchen Games leider so.
Die Leute auf Steam sind einfach hängen geblieben.
Irgendjemand hat auch was gesagt
mit der
Inventory-Nummer.
Heizung.
Man hat auch gerade was geschrieben,
ob ich noch was zu sagen wollte.
Die ID der Heizung ist doch sinnvoll,
du schaltest ja die Heizung nicht den Client,
der die Heizung schaltet.
Jaja, das ist richtig.
Deswegen, es würde eigentlich auch komplett reichen,
wenn ich die Heizungs-ID nehme.
Aber ich könnte ja doch zwei verschiedene.
Zum Beispiel,
nur mal ein Beispiel.
Wenn ich da jetzt hardcoded reinschreiben würde,
die Heizungs-ID.
Ich stelle dir vor,
ich lasse das Programm unten auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen.
Dort, wo auch die ganze
Heizungsgeschichte drauf läuft.
Aber ich möchte zum Testen
bei mir lokal das Ganze
nochmal ausführen.
Dann würde ich bei beiden mich
bei Home Assistant mit der gleichen ID melden.
Deswegen ist es vielleicht mit
Hostname und MAC-Adresse doch sinnvoller.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt einfach mal.
Also, ich lese die MAC-Adresse aus.
Ich lese meinen Hostname aus.
Da kommt dann hier sowas bei rum.
Und da bauen wir jetzt einfach mal
einen Identifier zusammen.
Identifier.
Das sind so Wörter,
bei denen tue ich mir immer total schwer,
die zu schreiben.
Identifier ist einer davon.
So, also.
Hostname.
Ups.
Ah, ich muss in das
IF, wäre vielleicht noch sinnvoller.
Hostname.
Und
Underscore und dann
die MAC-Adresse. Jawoll.
Gehen wir mal aus,
ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist, was da rauskommt.
Aha, wunderbar.
Warte mal, ich muss wieder
Hust-Champ machen.
Alter.
Hm.
Ja.
Nice.
Ich mache nachher,
ich habe mir beim Lidl
einen Corona-Test
geholt. Naso-Check.
Den mache ich nachher mal.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit schon am Husten.
Ich bin geimpft, muss ich sagen.
Also eigentlich sollte hier nichts gehen.
Ach, du weißt ja nie.
Corona.
Hast du noch andere? Nein, ich habe wahrscheinlich kein Corona.
Ich habe keinen Fieber, glaube ich zumindest.
Und nichts. Ich habe gar nichts.
Ich habe nur Husten. Husten und irgendwie
was im Hals.
Das ist richtig.
Sonntags ab 10 ungefähr machen wir immer
gemeinsames Video gucken.
Aufwach-Stelz-Stream.
Time.
Ja. Also, random Frage.
Weshalb mit C-Sharpen und nicht mit Python?
Die Frage
könntest du genauso gut umgedreht stellen.
Ich nehme das, womit ich
am besten klarkomme, beziehungsweise
was ich am liebsten verwende.
Die Frage kannst du ja im Prinzip in alle
nur erdenklichen Richtungen
stellen, ja. Zum Beispiel,
wenn ich es mit Python gemacht hätte,
käme jetzt irgendjemand an und sagt, hey, warum nicht mit Rust?
Weil Performance und Rust
beste oder warum nicht mit Go
oder Node.js oder was auch immer.
Also es hat jetzt keinen
spezifischen Grund, dass ich sagen würde, ja,
ich muss das mit der Sprache machen,
weil nur da gibt es
xy, was ich brauche.
Ich nehme einfach das, was... Warum
nicht C++? Ja, die Frage ist einfach
zu beantworten, weil C++ suckt.
Aber das wusstest du.
Das war ja die
Gbait-Frage.
Oder Kobol oder so.
Warum gibt es nicht eigentlich
Kappa lang?
Moment. Warum gibt's das?
Was?
Was? Was?
Was bin ich sehend?
Alter. Okay, das ist...
Die Kappas 4.
Okay, das...
Pip install Kappi.
Ja, das ist mir zu hoch jetzt. Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Kappa lang.
This is stupid. Don't leave a look at it.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Kappa lang.
Code literally in...
Es war doch klar, dass irgendjemand
sowas schon gemacht hat.
Brainfuck. Brainfuck mit Twitch Emotes.
Jawoll, da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
Endlich.
Ja, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Kappa lang.
Irgendwie war klar, dass es das gibt, oder?
Irgendwo war es klar.
Was ist mit
kekw lang? Das kannst du ja mal suchen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es das gibt.
Man muss sagen, so bekannt
kekw
mittlerweile auf Twitch ist, aber
so Mainstream-technisch ist
Kappa mit Abstand, aber wirklich mit
Abstand das bekannteste Twitch Emote.
Vielleicht
lul kennen die Leute auch
noch, aber Kappa ist das...
kekw kennt jeder auf Twitch.
Aber...
Kappa ist
das mit Abstand bekannteste. Was ich auch lustig
finde, weil es
auf YouTube das nicht gibt.
Auf YouTube in den
Comments, wenn einer Kappa schreiben will, hat sich
das jetzt durchgesetzt.
Weil YouTube mal die ganze
Zeit das...
schwarze oder das schwarze.
Weil YouTube hat Kappa mal
eine Zeit lang mit
diesem Symbol übersetzt,
wenn du es geschrieben hast und
deswegen schreiben die Leute lustigerweise
auf YouTube immer Full Moon with Pace.
So, also wir machen jetzt eine
Sache noch. Wir machen kurz noch das mit der
MAC-Adresse fertig. Und ihr merkt schon, ich habe schon
Probleme, hier richtig normal
zu reden.
I
Identifier
Ich vergesse jetzt schon sogar
welche Typen da.
Identifier, das kann man eigentlich
abkürzen.
Damit wir nicht doppelt zuweisen.
Identifier, so und jetzt
Get
Ups
New
String Array Identifier
Ja, so ist das doch ganz schick.
Kann ich nämlich das
mit Identifier rauslassen.
Da wird jetzt komplett
selbst generated.
Das finde ich gut.
Pipelang gibt es auch.
Wundert mich nicht.
Pipelang.
Gibt es da einen GitHub Eintrag?
Esoteric Programming Language.
Okay, das heißt an
der Anzahl der Es erkennt
er irgendwas. Alles klar.
Die Leute haben teilweise echt zu viel Zeit.
Ja, Pipelang
gibt es wirklich.
Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, dass es
das meiste, was mir an Schwachsinn
einfällt, schon gibt.
Aber eins gibt es
noch nicht.
Keck WSAService
Keck WSAService gibt es nur hier.
CD Repo
Keck WSAService
Das haben wir nur hier.
Passt mal auf.
Run
Also Keck WSAService ist das einzige.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Passt mal auf. Keck WSAService
Also wer es noch nicht gesehen hat.
Also der beste Microservice
auf der Welt.
Das ist das nächste Millionen Startup.
Ich sag's euch.
Der rotatet einfach random Keck W.
Bei jedem Seitenrefresh.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Denke auch AWS
fragt bald bezüglich Übernahme.
Ich kann zu den aktuellen Verhandlungen nichts sagen.
Ist das öffentlich auf Git?
Ja.
Das besinnt aber nur zwei Zeilen Code oder so.
Das ist auf GitHub.
Aber der eigentliche Sinn von diesem Service
ist das wir eine Testanwendung haben.
Wo wir unsere Cloud Geschichten mitmachen können.
Also die eigentliche
Anwendung ist
Das ist alles.
Das ist die Anwendung.
Das war's.
Das ist alles. Keck WSAService.
Mehr brauchst du dafür nicht.
Dass die Seite rotiert.
Wir haben natürlich die Bilder
pregenerated.
Guckt hier.
165 Degree.
Keck W.
Aber der eigentliche Sinn von dem Projekt
ist ja das wir was zum Deployen haben.
Für unsere Cloud Ausflüge
und Spirenzchen hier.
Die Streams kommen ja auch immer ziemlich gut an.
Übrigens Ausrufezeichen
Hetzner in den Chat.
Wenn ihr auf der Suche nach einer
günstigen Hostingmöglichkeit für Linux
virtuelle Linux Server seid.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt mal vorbei gucken.
Bei meinem Partner Hetzner Cloud.
Und euch einen 20 Euro
Startguthaben sichern.
Hab ich gut auswendig gelernt.
Aber ernsthaft.
Ich verwende das selbst schon jahrelang.
Ich hatte damit nie Probleme.
Ich bin damit
eigentlich wirklich recht glücklich.
Ich hoffe sie haben demnächst
Kisten ohne IPv4 Adresse.
Dass es noch günstiger wird.
Aber ansonsten.
Wenn ihr es ausprobieren wollt.
Ihr könnt euch eine kleine Kiste kaufen.
Für 4 Euro ungefähr.
Und die könnt ihr eine Weile laufen lassen.
Für 20 Euro.
Wenn es euch nicht gefällt.
Dann lasst das sein.
Er gilt übrigens nur für neue Kunden.
Ihr könnt das im Registrationsprozess
einlösen.
Den Code.
Ne.
Ich glaube den Code kann man einlösen.
Indem man nachdem man sich registriert hat.
Das Profil geht oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja der Kram ist wirklich günstig.
Also kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren.
Es war noch vor kurzem noch günstiger.
Aber ich hoffe es wird wieder.
Wenn die sagen IPv4 geht komplett ohne.
Weil irgendwelche Backendsurfer.
Ab denen brauche ich eigentlich gar keine
Public IPv4 zu geben.
Eigentlich total bescheuert.
Ich hoffe die machen das.
So.
Okay wie viel Zeit haben wir noch?
Noch 20 Minuten oder wie?
Eine Sache machen wir jetzt noch.
Wenn wir gerade noch was fertig ausprobieren.
Wir haben eine Zufalls ID.
Device Info.
Wir haben eine Zufalls ID generiert.
Okay.
So.
Also den ganzen Mist hier oben.
Könnte ich eigentlich weg machen.
Hättest du ein paar Gutscheine für Bestandskunden?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Vor allem wenn es das.
Das wäre natürlich sehr cool.
Wenn das funktioniert.
Da muss ich mal fragen.
Also nur ich habe
Admin Zugriff auf den Nightbot.
Also die Mods.
Ihr könnt glaube ich Kommandos hinzufügen.
Und löschen.
Aber ich glaube.
Admin technisch könnt ihr nichts machen.
Ja genau.
Das gibt es hier halt aktuell nicht.
Wenn du den Server anlegst hat der immer eine IPv4 Adresse.
Immer.
Die brauchst du eigentlich gar nicht.
So.
Also eine sinnvolle Sache machen wir jetzt noch.
Warum fragst du?
Du machst FPS.
Wie kommst du denn da drauf?
Unmöglich.
Kann nicht sein.
Ich bin Wobblors.
Mann.
Digga alter Lan.
Ich bin Wobblors.
Brainstamp.
Bestandskunden.
Ich kann es mal probieren.
Ich kann ihm mal anschreiben.
Ob wir nicht für Weihnachten irgendwas organisieren können.
Also Gewinnspiel technisch.
Dann habe ich zu viel mit Timer.
Es reicht ja schon das Ausrufezeichen.
Add Wobblors in den Chat.
Ja.
Leute ich glaube das war der längste Stream seit langem.
Okay eine Sache.
Eine Sache wollte ich jetzt noch machen.
Also wir haben den Kram jetzt hier generiert.
Ich will jetzt einfach mal gucken.
Ob das im Prinzip funktioniert.
Was ich hier gebastelt habe.
Also State.
Wir brauchen ein State Topic.
Das ergibt ja schon überhaupt keinen Sinn jetzt.
Alter was mache ich denn hier.
So State Topic.
Ist immer das gleiche.
Immer Switch State.
Nur mit dem Unterschied.
Achso Name muss ich noch übergeben.
Für den Sensor.
Name braucht das Ding auf jeden Fall.
Also Name.
Den brauchen wir bestimmt nochmal.
Name.
Ich kann echt nicht mehr reden.
Ich mache jetzt unten einen Corona Test.
Ich sage es euch.
Ich habe noch einen.
Alter.
Es tut mir sogar ein bisschen den Hals weh.
Ja das ist nice.
Ja deswegen.
Das ist auch die Sache warum ich angefangen habe.
Ich habe selbst so viele Stellenanzeigen gesehen.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe.
Das kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein.
Das könnt ihr doch nicht ernst meinen.
Da habe ich mir dann irgendwann überlegt.
Das kommt ja auch immer gut an.
Echt hattest du Corona?
Ich bin aber geimpft.
Doppelt.
Und das ist schon ein paar Wochen her.
Ich kann gar kein Corona haben.
Aber ich habe ja auch keinerlei Probleme mit sonst irgendwas.
Ich habe keinen Fieber.
Ich habe keine Atemprobleme oder irgendwas.
Mir tut einfach nur der Hals weh.
Kochsalzlösungimpfung.
Was denkst du über Battlefield 2042?
Auf Reddit sind alle panisch.
Reddit kann es nichts geben.
Ich fand das was ich gesehen habe gut.
Ich hoffe es gibt demnächst ein Anspielevent.
Wo ich mitmachen darf.
Offiziell weiß ich es ja nicht.
Da kann ich mir selbst ein Bild davon machen.
Sollte das so sein.
Dann werde ich mal gucken.
Warum soll das auf einmal sacken?
Reddit kann es nichts geben.
Sollte das auf einmal sacken?
Was?
Robled Быel?
Wie heißt das denn?
με απTw scalp?
Demon Hunter О grate células da driving magazines
關
Mann im lorbeesse
...
Let's get down.
zurzeit wird wahrscheinlich entweder haben sie festgestellt dass es doch mehr bugs gibt die
gameplay technisch nicht so gut ankommen diese fixen wollen oder ich mag vielleicht sind auch
ein paar wichtige leute krank geworden man kann das echt schlecht beurteilen und bei strike weißt
du kommst gerade richtig ich wollte jetzt aufgehen demnächst wir machen leute hat es euch gefallen ich
glaube schon so viele es waren so es war durchschnittlich glaube ich 230 250 leute
da richtig nice das schöne wenn es euch gefallen hat wir machen auch demnächst weiter ich kann
euch mal richtig reden ich will erst mal ich mache jetzt mal corona test klar corona macht
eigentlich der fraser der mal wieder angewiesen letzter zeit der frist irgendwelche irgendwelche
web mobile
games alter der fraser wieder am start an die waifu games ja redet ihn doch gerade mal habe
ich das letzte mal schon gemacht hat er sich glaube ich sogar noch darüber beschwert es
kommen die ganzen leute dazu ich rede heute nicht ich glaube nicht dass das was ist was
euch großartig interessiert raid coder 2k wer ist ein coder 2k kenne ich jetzt kommt irgendein
cam streamer oder so oder 2k 2 ist das c++ okay es ist es ist es ist was mit gaming da lasse ich
mir es doch irgendwie gefallen ja das dann lasse ich mir das dann lasse ich mir das schon auch
gefallen wir gucken mal was gibt es denn so was gibt es hier denn so das ist das ist der
xqc des terminals ich wusste gar nicht dass er streamt ich wusste gar nicht dass der streamt
was er rpi cloud kanäle auf deutsch refactoring wir kauen ein retro game gibt es denn da so ich
wusste gar keinen gut da kann das sein dass die kategorie nicht so beliebt ist na gut das ist
jetzt auch auf deutsch auf deutsch lehrer wie sieht es denn international so aus auf
der und game development aber da programming grills
javascript den kenne ich der macht auf youtube gute tutorials javascript css zeug da lernt man
css keine ahnung und ich gehe jetzt auf geht's was essen was trinken das heißt gucken ob mir
der hals morgen auch noch weh tut dann was da rauskommt was plaxi moder gibt sich mühe okay
wenn der chat wenn der chat das sagt muss man kurz gucken wer ist das twitch nach mir gar nichts
gemacht sind wir aber was ist das hier gerade mal von den anderen
strecken elemente automatisch generieren ergibt sich ich habe schon nie gehört guckst du den öfters baldisos okay ist das schon mal ne ordnliche programmiersprache da bin ich bin ich ganz begeistert komm wir wollen mal nicht so sein auf geht's raid bamm ich bin dann aber nicht im chat ich gehe jetzt gleich runter was trinken tut der hals weh
ich dich jetzt gleich runter was trinken tut der hals weh
Von Unity habe ich auch überhaupt keinen Plan
Es ist auch echt sowas, wo es mich überhaupt nicht dazu hinzieht
Vielleicht will ich mir meinen Spaß an Games nicht verderben
So, wenn ich weiß, wie es funktioniert
Kein Schimmer
Also Leute, wir sehen uns, bis dann, macht's gut
See you